Na ja, es gibt ja immer was zu tun. Es gibt Filme zu sehen, Bücher müssen gelesen werden und ich bin ja auch kein Mensch, der in irgendeiner Weise woanders gerne wäre. Ich bin ja sehr froh, so wie alles ist. Ich gehe mal in ein Hotel für eine Nacht, um irgendwo was Kulturelles zu erleben. Aber eigentlich ist für mich Urlaub ein Konzept, dass ich nie so ganz begriffen habe. Aber du bist mitten im Urlaub und arbeitest aber trotzdem. Das ist ja sehr löblich.
Natürlich wird gearbeitet. Ich sitze noch auf dem Bett, denn der Küchentisch unten ist noch belegt. Es müssen Brötchen geschmiert werden. Wir hatten ja eine kleine virtuelle Begegnung vor ungefähr zweieinhalb Wochen. Ich schrieb dir mit einem Ping, also einem Location-Tag. Ich hänge in einer Hängematte im Wald kurz über Koblenz. Hoffnend, dass du mir am nächsten Morgen antwortest, ob das überhaupt geht. Und Grüße aus dem Steigenberger in Köln. Also tageweise machst du da doch Urlaub.
Ich hatte da einen Fototermin und so hatte sich das ergeben. Ich war dann auch noch abends in der Philharmonie. Das war sehr schön und es war wahrscheinlich etwas bequemer in dem Bett als in deiner Hängematte.
Ja, meine Hängematte war zu kurz, nur 2, 70 Meter. Sie hätte durchaus 3, 20 Meter sein dürfen. Nichtsdestotrotz habe ich jetzt einmal Übernachtung im Wald mitgemacht. Es ist wahnsinnig kompliziert in Deutschland herauszufinden, ob man gerade in einem Naturschutzgebiet ist. Denn wenn es so ist, darf man es nicht. Dann kostet es auch richtig Geld. Es gibt dann eine einzige App, die dir das anzeigt. Die benutzen vor allem die Drohnenpiloten, um zu schauen, ob sie denn hier ihr Fluggerät steigen lassen dürfen. Und danach orientiert man sich dann, ob man den hier seine Hängematte aufhängen darf. Es war alles ziemlich verrückt. Aber der Einsteig ist sehr schön. Ich empfehle das sehr. Ich bin jetzt auch materiell so gut ausgerüstet mit Rucksackwasserblase, die man im Rücken mit sich trägt, sodass man gleich etwas Kleines trinken kann, ohne den Rucksack absetzen zu müssen, was sehr gut ist. Denn der Rucksack wiegt am Ende dann doch 15 Kilo.
Ach ja.
Und wir sind tageweise Halbmarathons durch die Bergauf, Bergab, Rheinsteig, Weinberge gelaufen.
Und jetzt kannst du noch etwas Kraft sammeln mit der Familie zusammen, denn für dich sind es ja aufregende Tage. Ich darf das sagen, dein Buch erscheint am Freitag, am dritten, beziehungsweise am Samstag dann, die Altenrepublik, wie der demografische Wandel unsere Zukunft gefährdet. Endlich ist es da. Wir haben lange darauf gewartet. Du hast uns heiß gemacht auf das Buch. Ich habe es auch noch nicht gelesen, werde es natürlich jetzt umgehend tun, habe schon dein Interview in Galore gelesen. Und da fand ich schon wunderbar, wo du sagst, ja, die Altenrepublik, das ist ein Gemütszustand. Und als ich das las, habe ich sofort über meine Erlebnisse aus den vergangenen Tagen so nachgedacht. Und ja, mit diesem Gemütszustand lässt sich, glaube ich, sehr viel erklären, sehr viel einordnen. Und ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ja, die Leute fragen dann immer, warum heißt es nicht Rentenrepublik? So habe ich es doch kennengelernt. Ja, weil wir die Rente vermeiden wollten als Thema. Denn dann ist man immer zu nah am Geld und an diesen individuellen Sorgen. Wie sorgst du denn vor? Und die Antwort müsste dann immer sein, kann ich nicht, weil meine Wohnkosten sind so hoch. Damit wäre das Thema eigentlich abgeschlossen. Aber Altenrepublik ist ja so ein bisschen mehr. Und ich bin auch sehr gespannt. Viele erwarten eine stringente Argumentation. Viele erwarten ein großes Durcheinander. Viele erwarten eine Materialsammlung. Andere erwarten wieder irgendwie so ein seichtes Kommt wir bilden Schicksalsgemeinschaft und so weiter. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es gelesen wird. Und ja, Gemütszustand, das betrifft natürlich alle. Also ist auch ein Buch für alle. Also man kann es lesen, wenn man gerade noch lange vor seiner eigenen Berufslaufbahn ist, als Student zum Beispiel. Und dann feststellen daran liegt, ich hab immer gedacht und so weiter. Ich bin zu blöde. Nein, und die Alten können es genauso gut lesen. Also die Ur-Omas davon, die leben ja immer noch heutzutage von solchen Studenten und dieses ganz, diese ganz große Frage, wie schaffen wir das jetzt mit den ganzen Alten? Also ist das ein Buch gegen die Alten? Man kann sich das immer nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass die Alten, die heute so alt sind, weil sie jetzt ins Rentenalter kommen, mal Kinder waren. Und damals waren das ja genauso viele. Und Deutschland musste schon mal ganz schön viele Leute versorgen, die gar nicht mitarbeiten wollten, weil sie damals zu jung waren, also die Siebziger. Was haben wir damals gemacht? Wir haben nicht den Kopf in den Sand gesteckt und gesagt, das sind aber viele Kinder, wer soll denn die alle versorgen? Wer soll denn deren Essen bezahlen? Sondern wir haben in Universitäten gegründet in den Siebziger. Wie viel Reformunis gab es plötzlich? Ganze Städte sind explodiert, weil man gesagt hat, hier bauen wir jetzt eine Uni hin, das größte Gebäude Europas, nach Ceaușescu Präsidentenpalast. Das ist dann die Uni Bielefeld geworden und so. Und heutzutage so eine große Resignation. Und ich denke mir, wieso? Das muss doch gar nicht sein. Wir haben doch schon mal so eine Überversorgung, also so einen Überhang an Zuversorgenden gehabt. Und jetzt halt wieder. Kann man das nicht einfach mal konstruktiv angehen?
Und das finde ich auch so schön. Und das kann man auch schon an den Kapiteln, die du da hast, sehen, wie du das auffächerst als Thema wirklich. Mit natürlich den ökonomischen Implikationen, mit aber auch den Fragen, wie eigentlich ein sinnvolles Zusammenleben aussieht, was wir denn eigentlich unter Wohlstand und auch unter Lebensabend verstehen. Also diese Idee, die ich wirklich sehr originell finde, dass man den Lebensabend als einen sehr, sehr langen Urlaub begreift. Das ist etwas, was glaube ich überhaupt nicht so drin ist. Und auch dieses Identitätsstiftende, was du ja so deutlich machst, dass man sagt, man hat jetzt gearbeitet. Und das sollte ja auch immer die Identität sein. Identifizieren sich mit ihrem Beruf, mit ihrer Firma. Da ist ja all dieser Identity-Business-Diskurs heute omnipräsent. Und dann gehen aber Menschen in Rente und verlieren eigentlich ein unglaubliches großes Stück ihrer Identität. Und was machen sie dann eigentlich? Und zwar gibt es dann vom Staat eine Rente für manche eine gute, für manche eine schlechte, für manche eine sehr schlechte. Aber davon mal abgesehen, was bedeutet das dann eigentlich? Und wenn dann nicht noch gerade die Großfamilie da ist, wo immer irgendwas los ist, dann ist das ein Identitätsverlust, der ja gar nicht so leicht zu kompensieren ist. Und deswegen finde ich das auch, also muss man auch ganz klar sagen, dass das nicht in irgendeiner Weise ein Buch ist, wo man sagt Hilfe die Alten, sondern wo man eigentlich sagt, na ja, wie würde denn ein sinnvolles Altern aussehen?
Wir erfinden jetzt einfach alle gemeinsam und da sind wir nun echt mal die Pioniere. Das Alter, wir haben ja vor 200 Jahren die Kindheit erfunden. Jetzt erfinden wir einfach das Altssein. Die Herausforderung ist gar nicht so groß, wie man denkt, wenn man einfach mal vom Geld ein bisschen weggeht und in den Blick nimmt, was man für das Geld kauft, wenn man alt ist. Und das ist nun mal Geselligkeit. Wir stecken unsere Kinder natürlich in den Kindergarten. Warum? Nicht nur, damit sie betreut sind, sondern Peer Group und so weiter. Wir erinnern uns alle an die Kindheit. Ich habe das gestern erst wieder. In welchem Podcast war es? Florian Schröder und Serdar Sumuncu, glaube ich. Diese Verherrlichung der Kindheit, dass heute alle noch mal eine Serie über die 80er machen können, und dann gucken alle Stranger Things und fühlen sich total gut aufgehoben und so. Und diese Verherrlichung der Kindheit, weil damals so viel los war, so gesellig und überhaupt, warum nicht einfach das nochmal wiederholen? Die Menschen unterschätzen, wie alt sie wirklich werden. Das habe ich auch im Buch so ein bisschen amüsiert aufgeschrieben, wie Vereine plötzlich aufploppen, die heißen einfach 7 plus. Weil man fragt die Leute, wie lange willst du noch leben? Und dann sagt man ihnen, du lebst auch noch 7 Jahre länger, als du gerade vermutet hast. Was machst du in 7 Jahren? Und 7 Jahre, ich meine, was macht man alles in 7 Jahren? Beginnt ein Kind das erste Mal ins Wasser zu springen und danach ist es Weltmeister. Das sind so 7 Jahre. Man kommt in die erweiterte Schule, stellt zum ersten Mal fest, oh krass, hier muss ich alleine mit der Bahn hinfahren. 7 Jahre später schreibt man Abitur. Also 7 Jahre sind eine ganz schön lange Zeit und die kann man auch im Alter noch mal nutzen. Macht man aber nicht in Deutschland. Wir brauchen well of older people und die haben wir aber nicht. Klar, Geld ist das eine, wir müssen ihnen Geld geben. Also wir müssen ihnen schon viel Geld geben. Es ist nicht so, dass die Rente gar keine Rolle spielt, ganz und gar nicht. Aber sie brauchen auch irgendwie Geselligkeit und Anleitung. Und naja, wir haben auch schon mal über Steinmeier's, warum nicht noch mal die Jugend in die Pflicht nehmen? Warum nicht einfach mal die Alten in die Pflicht nehmen und ihnen noch mal zeigen, was nach dem Erwerbsleben alles so möglich ist und sie mit Geselligkeit entlohnen? Da wären ganz schön viele ganz schön überrascht, wie gut ihnen das tut, aber Zukunftsmusik.
Na ja, du wirst diese Musik jetzt ein bisschen mitgestalten. Das Buch wird sicherlich ein großer Erfolg. Es ist, ich mache jetzt noch ein bisschen Werbung. Ich bin ja im Influencer-Modus. Es ist dann in wenigen Tagen erhältlich oder jetzt auch vorbestellbar. Und ich freue mich sehr auf die Lektüre und freue mich sehr, wenn du sehr präsent bist mit deinen Thesen, medial, weil ich glaube, dass damit diese ewige Debatte, die nie eigentlich geführt wurde, aber immer präsent ist, mal auf ein anderes Niveau gehoben wird. Insofern viel Erfolg dir.
Sehr gut, vielen Dank. Wir sind alle gespannt. Ab dem Wochenende bin ich dann zurück und dann geht es los.
Und wir sprechen natürlich auch noch über Bücher, die du nicht geschrieben hast. Wir sprechen zum Beispiel im nächsten Salon über ein Buch, das wir noch nicht bekannt gegeben haben, aber das wollen wir jetzt gerade tun. Da sprechen wir über ein gerade frisch erschienenes Buch von Gideon Rachman, der ist so ein One-Man-Think-Tank, jemand, der die geopolitischen Zusammenhänge immer wieder sehr gekonnt aufschlüsselt in Büchern. Sein letztes habe ich mit Begeisterung gelesen. Und jetzt ist ein neues erschienen, Welt der Autokraten, wie Xi, Putin, Trump und Co. die Demokratie bedrohen. Und wenn man da reinliest in das deutsche Vorwort, dann sagt er, ja, ich hab am 21. Dezember, glaube ich, den letzten Satz geschrieben zu dem Buch, 21. Und in dem Buch gibt es den Satz, dass noch viel Leid diese Autokraten anrichten werden. Und dann schreibt er eben in diesem deutschen Vorbuch, na ja, und dann zwei Monate später, kommt Putin mit seinem Krieg. Und er kann das dann gleich noch mal so zusammenbinden. Und ich glaube, das wird ein Buch sein, über das wir gut auch diskutieren können, ob wir diesen Perspektiven zustimmen, die Rachman da einnimmt. Jedenfalls ist er originell. Und ich glaube, sein Buch wird auch gut sein. Und wir werden im Salon darüber sprechen. Und den Salon kann man jetzt über so viele verschiedene Wege aufrufen, hineingehen. Das will man ganz kurz sagen. Also man kann das ganz klassisch, und das ist unsere präferierte Variante, über Steady tun. Da hat man alle Vorteile, da hat man alle alten Folgen. Da hat man Kapitelmarken und so weiter und so fort. Steady findet man über unsere Neue Zwanziger Homepage. Man findet das, wenn man über Spotify diesen Podcast hört, auch über einen Button, dass man da direkt hin kann. Also da ist der Umweg dann nicht mehr da, sondern das führt direkt dann zu Steady. Dann kann man über Apple diesen Salon auch abonnieren. Zahlt da, weiß ich nicht, 40 Cent oder so mehr, weil Apple natürlich sich wieder noch entsprechendes abgreift, damit die ja kein Problem mit dem Cashflow bekommen. Und jetzt sind wir aber auch noch, weil es doch ein paar Leute gibt, die so irgendwie Gamer unterstützen, also so aus dem Gaming-Kosmos, so glaube ich zumindest immer, ist das sehr stark, sind wir auch noch bei Patreon. Das heißt, wer ohnehin schon bei Patreon ist, dort einen Account hat. Da kann man ja auch verstehen, dass man dann nicht noch einen Steady-Account vielleicht machen will. Also es ist jetzt auch möglich, uns über Patreon zu abonnieren. Da ist es aber dann so, dass dort die neuen Folgen sind, allerdings jetzt nicht das ganze Archiv.
Ja, genau, wir haben ein Salon-Archiv ab Februar 2020. Das gibt es leider nur über Steady. Steady ist auch für uns ziemlich einfach. Denn bei Apple habe ich es noch nicht gesehen, bei Patreon mal schauen. Aber Steady schickt uns zum Beispiel auch monatlich einfach eine Rechnung, die wir dann ans Finanzamt weiterreichen können, sofern die das mal sehen wollen. Das ist also nicht nur für euch das einfachste und das günstigste mit 2, 50 Euro im Monat, sondern es ist auch für uns wahnsinnig hilfreich, es nicht zu verkomplizieren. Apple macht es natürlich für diejenigen einfacher, die einfach bei Apple sowieso in der Podcast-App hören und dann einfach da die neue Folge vorgeschlagen bekommen mit der Frage willst du bezahlen ja oder nein? Und Patreon, ja wie du sagst, ich habe selber so gar keinen Bezug zu Patreon. Das scheint mir so ein amerikanisches Ding zu sein. Allerdings haben sie sich auch gleich bei uns gemeldet, nachdem sie sahen, dass wir da jetzt auch gelistet sind, um irgendwie Hilfe anzubieten. Das fand ich alles sehr nett. Haben wir aber in dem Falle, na gut, wir haben noch mal kurz mit denen geklärt, wie eine Jahresabrechnung ist, sodass nicht jeden Monat Zahlungsverkehr Kosten aufwirft.
Aber jetzt haben wir ein Jahresabbo abschließen.
Genau, man kann auch bei Patreon jetzt ein Jahresabbo abschließen und damit nur einmal einen Zahlungsverkehr bezahlen. Das macht es auch noch mal um 17 Prozent günstiger als die monatliche Abrechnung. Na ja, damit sind wir, glaube ich, jetzt gut aufgestellt. Ich glaube nicht, dass es irgendwo noch in der Ecke was schlummert, was man noch mal mit Bitcoin und so weiter ist, scheint ja vorbei zu sein.
Nein, das würden wir auch nicht machen. OnlyFans machen wir auch nicht, auch wenn wir noch über was Ästhetisches heute sprechen werden, also was man vielleicht auch mitbringen muss, um bei OnlyFans zu sein. Aber wir bleiben über der Gürtellinie, kann ich schon versprechen. Nun, viele Wege führen in den Salon und wir werden aber jetzt einmal ein paar Wege durch die Welt machen, denn es sind so langsam wieder alle auf Reisen oder versprechen auf Reisen zu gehen. Olaf Scholz war in Prag, man flog wohl diesmal mit Maske hin. Es gab ja hier einen kleinen Aufschrei, dass man nach Kanada flog ohne Maske mit einem PCR-Test und der sollte dann aber über Tage halten.
Na ja, es gibt jetzt eine Ergänzung. Also ich will überhaupt nicht über das Thema reden, es wurde in allen Podcasts behandelt. Aber die Regierung hat sich Gedanken gemacht, wie kriegen wir das wieder eingefangen? Und die neue Regel lautet PCR-Test 24 Stunden vorher und beim Einchecken am Gait ein aktueller Antigen-Test.
Ach, das auch noch?
Ja, es ist irre.
Ja, es ist, ich kann, ja, ich will da auch mich gar nicht zu äußern. Ich hatte Schmidt-Chandas im Interview gehört, wo er auch sagte, gut, mit der FFP2-Maskenpflicht sind wir dann wirklich das einzige Land der Welt, wo das so ist. Aber ja, es ist ein deutscher Sonderweg und mal sehen, wie lang dieser Weg dann noch gegangen wird, wie lang der als sinnvoll empfunden wird. Scholz war jetzt in Prag und hat da eine Grundsatzrede gehalten über Europa.
Hattest du mir oder hattest du gewusst, dass die Rede stattfindet?
Nein.
Du hattest mir nämlich geschrieben, ich bringe noch von der Rede Scholz mit. Ich auf dem Fahrrad so Deutschlandfunk gehört und gehört, sie fahren statt. Bin aber auch irgendwie schon ein bisschen aus allen Wolken gefallen, weil ich dachte, jetzt gerade macht er so eine Grundsatzrede zur EU, die eine Antwort sein soll auf vor 17.000 Jahren hat Macron in der Sorbonne und so weiter. Wir haben es ja alles besprochen und ich war total überrascht davon, dass es stattfand. Und ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt, was er gesagt hat.
Nun, wir wissen, er ist kein großer Redner und das hat er auch hier wieder unter Beweis gestellt, aber wir sollten tatsächlich uns diese Rede in ein paar Ausschnitten anhören. Er äußert sich auch natürlich sehr kleinteilig zum Krieg. Das ist für uns weitgehend irrelevant, was er da nochmal wiederholt und was er verspricht, noch zu tun und wie man die Ukraine unterstützen kann und so weiter. Aber das ist in gewisser Weise auch fast fehl am Platze, wenn man eine Grundsatzrede hält und das war eine eigenartige Mischung bei ihm, dass er anfängt mit so Worten, die man wählt, wenn man eine Grundsatzrede halten möchte und dann sich aber zwischendurch so in das Kleinteilige begibt, dass man denkt, sind wir jetzt gerade im Bundestag und besprechen wir jetzt da irgendwas, wo wir nochmal dies und das tun könnten. Nun, wir hören mal rein und gehen zu den Quellen.
Ad fontes zu den Quellen, so lautete der Ruf der großen Humanisten der europäischen Renaissance. Wer sich zu den Quellen Europas aufmacht, dessen Weg führt unweigerlich hierher, in diese Stadt, deren Erbe und Gestalt so europäisch sind wie die kaum einer anderen Stadt unseres Kontinents. Jedem amerikanischen oder chinesischen Touristen der über die Karlsbrücke hinauf zum Rajin läuft, ist das sofort klar. Deshalb sind sie ja hier. Weil sie in dieser Stadt zwischen ihren mittelalterlichen Burgen und Brücken, katholischen, protestantischen und jüdischen Gebetshäusern und Friedhöfen, gotischen Kathredalen und Art Nouveau-Palais, Glashochhäusern und Fachwerk-Gässchen und im Sprachgewirr der Altstadt das finden, was Europa für sie so ausmacht. Allergrößte Vielfalt auf engstem Raum.
Kannst du bestätigen, dass Peter Fiala, also der tschechische Regierungschef, nicht anwesend war als Scholz sprach?
Ich habe ihn zumindest nicht gesehen.
Weil er anderes zu tun hatte. Ich habe das nur durchs Konzept zu hören.
Und er hat ihn auch nicht, glaube ich, bei der Eröffnung angesprochen. Also er sagte nur, meine Damen und Herren, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber es ist gut möglich. Und na ja.
Das ist alles skurril, muss man nicht sagen.
Es war wirklich sehr skurril. Es war sehr skurril und jetzt zeigt er also uns nochmal das schöne Prag. Und wer schon mal in Prag war, kann das so nachvollziehen. Ja, das gibt es da alles zu sehen. Nun will aber Scholz eigentlich gar nicht so eine Rede halten. Und das passt ja auch gar nicht zu ihm, dass er jetzt hier anfängt, Advontis und nochmal zeigt Arnavaux in Prag. Und was weiß ich, das ist nichts, was einen Scholz eigentlich interessiert, sondern jetzt muss es um die Realpolitik gehen, die man neu definieren will.
Advontis zu den Realpolitik im 21. Jahrhundert heißt nicht, Werte hinanzustellen und Partner zu opfern zugunsten fauler Kompromisse. Realpolitik muss heißen, Freunde und Wertepartner einzubinden, sie zu unterstützen, um durch Zusammenarbeit stärker zu sein im globalen Wettbewerb.
Ja, wenn man das so hört, das ist natürlich, Merkel hat ja nicht gesprochen, nicht reagiert, als solche Vorschläge von anderer Seite kamen. Und eigentlich müsste man ja jetzt mit Handlungen überzeugen und nicht nochmal mit einer neuen Rede. Also eigentlich müsste ja Scholz jetzt wirklich ausführen, was Merkel nicht gesagt hat, um wieder deutsche Glaubwürdigkeit zu erringen. Denn um dieser Zwangslage jetzt wieder nur mit Worten zu kommen, die dann in Prag völlig überraschend irgendwie vorzuholen und dann ist aber schon wieder der nächste Termin. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob wir hier nicht doch nur noch Ampelprosa hören werden in diesem Ding.
Ja, was er hier eigentlich tut, ist, ein bisschen die Begleitmusik zu produzieren, zu dem, was Macron vor Jahren gesagt hat und worauf die Merkel-Regierung nicht hören wollte. Er stimmt auch einmal explizit, ich hab den Clip jetzt nicht mitgebracht, Macron zu, als es darum um eine Reform der EU geht und als es auch darum geht, dass man mehr in der Verteidigung zusammensteht. Was er aber überhaupt nicht aufgreift, ist ja diese Idee von Macron, mit der er ja lange Zeit hausieren ging, einer europäischen Armee, einer EU-Armee. Und das ist ja etwas, was man sich mal vergegenwärtigen sollte. All diese Länder jetzt, uns inklusive, die die Rüstungsetats nach oben schrauben, könnten ja immens viel Geld sparen, wenn sie sagen, wir brauchen nicht jeder sein eigenes Trüpfchen und das produziert dann, dass die einen können die anderen Waffen nicht bedienen und so weiter. Er spricht es auch mal so am Rande an, dass es da ja immer Hakelichkeiten gibt. Aber wenn man wirklich sich begreifen würde als ein Bündnis und man würde dann gemeinsam Investitionen machen, dann könnte man unglaublich viel Geld auf der jeweils nationalen Ebene sparen. Das wäre eigentlich das Sinnvolle. Das ist jetzt kein Vorschlag des Pazifismus oder so, sondern das wäre jetzt wirklich in meinen Augen Realpolitik. Und jetzt schafft man eigentlich Riesen-Geldsummen herbei. Und wir werden in zehn Jahren oder wenn wir 29 dann hier beisammensitzen, werden wir wahrscheinlich schon so eine lange Liste haben mit irgendwelchen Versäumnissen, wo man sagt, ja, da sind wieder zehn Milliarden reingesteckt worden, der Hubschrauber ist nicht abgehoben und das funktioniert nicht und es gibt auch keine Munition. Das werden wir alles wieder genauso erleben, weil das überhaupt nicht sinnvoll koordiniert wird und weil natürlich da auch irgendwelche Leute versuchen, so viel wie möglich für sich rauszubekommen. Also natürlich will das auch die Bundeswehr eigentlich nicht, dass man dann sagt, gut, wir schaffen hier mal einige Dinge ganz ab, denn das machen jetzt die Franzosen für uns oder so. Also das wäre aber eigentlich das, was zu tun, wenn man jetzt wirklich nur auf diese Idee aus ist, wir müssen als Europa eine bessere Verteidigung haben.
Ja, und wenn man sich das, also man muss es echt mal strapazieren. Das Verteidigungsthema ist ja das, wo zumindest auf der semantischen Ebene in den ganzen Reden noch am meisten drinsteckt. Da kann man ja ein bisschen Rückschlüsse drauf ziehen. Wie sieht es eigentlich bei den anderen Themen aus? Gemeinsame europäische Sozialpolitik, diese Agrarpolitik, die völlig lobbyverseuchter nur noch die hunderte Milliarden irgendwie hin und her schiebt. Als der Brexit passierte und England aus der EU austrat, haben die ja alles in Trümmern gelegt, bis hin zu ihrem North-Eland-Ding, was sie da gerade so richtig in den Sand setzen, weil Boris Johnson sich gar nicht dafür interessiert, was da eigentlich die Problemlage ist. Aber die Verteidigungspolitik, die ist ja unangetastet geblieben. England ist weiter in der NATO, es gibt diese ganzen europäischen Zusammenarbeiten und so weiter. Und wenn man jetzt diesen Bogenschlag mal macht, und wir sehen ja gerade, wie desolat die Verteidigungssachen sind, dass wir hier irgendwie so Ringtausche machen müssen, um die europäische Handlungsfähigkeit nicht zu gefährden und gleichzeitig noch die Ukraine zu unterstützen, wenn man da jetzt einen Rückschluss drauf zieht, wie die restlichen europäischen Zusammenarbeiten funktioniert, wo nicht mal in der Sprache irgendwas geklärt werden kann. Und eigentlich so dringend notwendig, dass ein deutscher Bundeskanzler hier für das größte Land Europas mal die Worte in die Hand nimmt und eigentlich ein paar Sachen sagt, die dann auch Folgen haben.
Aber vielleicht hat er die Altenrepublik schon gelesen. Hör mal.
Denn der Druck zur Veränderung auf uns Europäerinnen und Europäer wird wachsen, auch unabhängig von Russlands Krieg und seinen Folgen. In einer Welt mit acht, künftig wohl mit zehn Milliarden Menschen ist jeder einzelne unserer europäischen Nationalstaaten für sich genommen viel zu klein, um allein seine Interessen und Werte durchzusetzen.
Ja, Demografie ist halt auch für die alle so ein bisschen toxisches Thema, da man dann immer gleich in so rechten Diskursen ganz komisch aufgegriffen wird.
Aber auch Europa ist zu klein, wenn man das demografisch vergleicht. Also auch der Westen ist zu klein. Das macht Gideon Rathmann übrigens in seinem Vorgängerbuch, wo er einfach mal die Bevölkerungsentwicklung sich ansieht und sagt, naja, wenn man das rein demografisch betrachtet, ist natürlich der Westen nicht in der Überzahl mehr. Und das ist aber erstmal gar nicht ausschlaggebend für das, was man jetzt als politische Macht bezeichnen kann.
Also das letzte Jahrhundert war davon geprägt, dass dem Wirtschaftswachstum immer ein Bevölkerungswachstum vorausging. Wenn auch alles sonst kompliziert ist, aber diese Verklammerung ist da. Und jetzt haben wir diese Zäsur, dass wir unterschiedlich schnell schrumpfen oder sogar wachsen. Also Europa ist ja wirklich klein, was Bevölkerung angeht. 500 Millionen von 10 Milliarden. Das sind also 5 Prozent. Das ist nicht wirklich sehr viel. Und wenn man sich jetzt Afrika anschaut, alle Länder zusammengenommen, die von 1, 5 auf bis zu 4, 5 Milliarden prognostiziert wachsen. Das ist dann schon die Hälfte der Welt in weniger als 100 Jahren. Indien überholt jetzt China. China, wir sehen, wie es dazu geht. Nicht mal mehr Wirtschaftswachstum haben sie noch.
Sie haben drei Kindpolitik jetzt und zugleich wollen weniger Frauen denn je Kinder haben.
Genau, weniger Kinder als damals noch zu den Hochzeiten der Ein-Kind-Politik. Und Olaf Scholz ist ja eigentlich demografiepolitisch. Und ich bin sehr dafür, dass wir demografiepolitik jetzt mal ernsthaft machen, so wie wir Klimapolitik machen. Dass wir uns vor dem Thema nicht wieder so verstecken, nur weil wir da immer glauben, da führen die Falschen die Diskurse und so. Er war Arbeitsminister, er war Finanzminister, er ist Bundeskanzler. Niemand kennt sich so gut aus in diesen Themen wie Olaf Scholz, formal gesehen. Aber er traut es, sich nicht anzusprechen. Ich zitiere ihn ja dann auch, wie er im Bundestag als Finanzminister steht und einfach gar nicht über Ausländer reden möchte, über Migration, beim Thema Fachkräftemangel. Sich richtig weigert, sodass dann wirklich noch die Zwischenrufe der FDP kommen, ob es jetzt hier Demografieleugner vorne am Rednerpult gibt. Und der Finanzminister gemeint ist und so. Und in deren Sicht, keine Ahnung, ob man hier die Wende noch mal hinbekommt. Ich bin sehr dafür, dass die Politiker allen voran, die, die dann auch wirklich die Kompetenz und Kapazität gerade haben, machtvoll zu sprechen, das Thema dann wirklich auch mal richtig aufgreifen und nicht nur so verdrucksst in dieser Präampelsprache.
Auch das spricht er kurz an in dieser Rede. Er sagt, dass wir ja überall jetzt an den Flughäfen und in den Krankenhäusern merken, dass zu wenig Personal da sei und dass man schon über Migration jetzt nachdenken muss. Macht aber dann unglaublich viele Worte darum, dass man die illegale Migration bekämpfen muss. Und du weißt dann immer gut, da soll also Vortex dann noch mal stärker ausgestattet werden und die Festung Europa noch fester sein. Und dann würde man gerne sich die Rosinen auspicken, die dann nichts lieber wollen, als in Deutschland zu arbeiten zu widrigen Bedingungen. Also das ist auch eine sehr interessante Vorstellung, wo man sich auch fragen muss auf Dauer, wie attraktiv dann tatsächlich Europa noch ist. Also klar gibt es viele, die aus afrikanischen Ländern kommen, die unbedingt hier sein möchten. Aber wenn man da tatsächlich jetzt sagt, wir erhöhen da eigentlich noch mal die Zäune und dann suchen wir uns aber die aus, die wir brauchen, dann glaube ich, wird das auf Dauer schiefgehen. Und ich glaube auch, wenn dieser Diskurs schon gleich, sobald man sagt, wir müssen über Arbeitsmigration reden, dass man dann schon erstmal 100 Sätze über die illegale Migration, die sogenannte illegale Migration verliert, dann macht man damit eigentlich schon ein Zugeständnis an, wieder so einen rechten Diskurs, sodass man am Ende über so wenig Zuwanderung sprechen wird, dass es hinten und vorne nicht reicht. Nun, die neuen Partnerschaften, welche sind das?
Doch bei allem, was gerade Präsident Biden für unsere Partnerschaft getan hat, wissen wir zugleich, dass sich der Blick Washingtons stärker auch auf den Wettbewerb mit China richtet und auf den asiatisch-pazifischen Raum. Das wird für künftige amerikanische Regierung ebenso gelten, vielleicht sogar noch mehr. In einer multipolaren Welt, und das ist die Welt des 21. Jahrhunderts, reicht es daher nicht, nur bestehende Partnerschaften zu pflegen. So wertvoll sie sind. Wir werden in neue Partnerschaften investieren, in Asien, Afrika und Lateinamerika.
Ist er konkreter geworden?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Hat er mal Namibia, Nigeria genannt?
Nein, nein, nein. Es werden einfach nur mal so Großregionen aufgerufen, mit denen man gerne würde. Natürlich ist das auch etwas, was Macron aufgezeichnet hat. Wir können uns auf Amerika als wichtigsten Partner nicht mehr vielleicht so lange verlassen. Und wenn wir sehen, was jetzt gerade in den USA bei den Republikanern abgeht, es ist ja durchaus möglich, dass die einen Präsidenten wieder stellen werden. Und was ist dann eigentlich, was blüht uns dann, beziehungsweise wie stark ist dann diese Partnerschaft? Wir kommen ja auch noch heute auf China und Saudi-Arabien zu sprechen. Und da sieht man auch, dass da natürlich eine Welt macht, wie die USA sehr viel Unruhe gestiftet hat, wo jetzt das eine oder andere Machtvakuum gefüllt wird. Und dass es dann eine andere Ausrichtung braucht und auch vielleicht ein souveräneres Europa ist absolut richtig. Aber Scholz geht natürlich in dieser Rede überhaupt nicht mal in die Vollen, sondern das ist ja jetzt ein Satz, der hätte so auch von jedem anderen mal ausgesprochen werden können.
Das sind vor allem so Sätze, die stehen in allen Sachbüchern von Sachbuchautoren drin, um die Regierung aufzufordern, dann mal nicht nur solche Sätze zu sagen, sondern auch zu machen. Genau, zu handeln.
Er möchte ein bisschen reformieren. Also da hat er dann etwas Konkretes mitgebracht.
Also lassen Sie uns über Reformen reden. Im Rat der EU, auf der Ebene der Ministerinnen und Minister ist schnelles und pragmatisches Handeln gefragt. Das muss auch in Zukunft gesichert sein. Dort, wo heute Einstimmigkeit erforderlich ist, wächst aber mit jedem weiteren Mitgliedsstaat auch das Risiko, dass ein einzelnes Land mit seinem Veto alle anderen am Vorankommen hindert. Wer anderes glaubt, der verleugnet die europäische Realität. Ich habe deshalb vorgeschlagen, in der gemeinsamen Außenpolitik, aber auch in anderen Bereichen wie der Steuerpolitik, schrittweise zu Mehrheitsentscheidungen überzugehen. Wohl wissend, dass das auch Auswirkungen für Deutschland hätte.
Täglich grüßt das Murmeltier.
Da werden wir mal sehen, ob das kommt.
Ich meine, 2010 oder wann habe ich meine Diplomarbeit zum Thema Europa und Demokratie und da war das Top-Thema, weil das schon in dem Jahrzehnt davor, die ganze Zeit, wie kommen wir mal zu einem vernünftigen Abstimmungsmodus, bei dem nicht jeder einzelnen Veto vorlegen kann. Aber naja.
Ja, das ist also das neue Alte, was er mitbringt. Scholz spricht dann über die Wirtschaftspolitik und da, glaube ich, haben wir schon einen Paradigmenwechsel, den wir jetzt konstatieren können.
Aber auch wir brauchen ein Gameplay, so etwas wie eine Strategie made in Europe 2030. Für mich heißt das, dort, wo Europa verglichen mit dem Silicon Valley, Shenzhen, Singapur oder Tokio zurückliegt, wollen wir uns an die Spitze zurückkämpfen. Bei den für unsere Industrie so wichtigen Ships und Halbleitern sind wir dank einer echten europäischen Kraftanstrengung schon vorangekommen.
Ja, als SPD-Bundeskanzler hätte ich von der Agenda 2030 gesprochen.
Ja, sehr richtig. Wir haben jetzt diesen Chips Act. Wir haben den in den USA. Wir haben da die Bemühungen von Breton in der EU. Und jetzt passiert in dieser Grundsatzrede, also wir müssen uns das vorstellen, da ist der Bundeskanzler in Prag, hält eine Grundsatzrede, Advontis. Und diese Rede nimmt dann diesen Schlenker hier.
Erst vor kurzem hat zum Beispiel Intel Milliardeninvestitionen in Frankreich, Polen, Deutschland, Irland, Italien und Spanien angekündigt. Ein Riesenschritt hin zu einer neuen Generation von Microchips made in Europe. Und das ist erst der Anfang. Mit Unternehmen wie Infineon, Bosch, NXP und Global Foundries arbeiten wir an Projekten, die Europa technologisch an die Weltspitze führen. Ich möchte ein Europa, das Vorreiter ist bei wichtigen Schlüsseltechnologien.
Es werden hier einfach mal alle Unternehmen aufgezählt, die relevant sein könnten. Und da ändert sich doch jetzt gerade etwas. Also dass man sich in einer Grundsatzrede nicht nur auf die Wirtschaft bezieht, sondern auch noch konkrete Unternehmen aufzählt und dann jeden noch einzeln bedenkt. Adam Toos hat in seinem Podcast Once and Toos diese neue Politik etwa zwei Wochen bevor Scholz in Prag war, auch herausgearbeitet und er sagt, Industriepolitik, das ist das neue Buzzword.
Industriepolitik ist vielleicht das neue Buzzword. Wir sind nicht mehr so konzentriert, wie wir waren mit den Möglichkeiten der Quantität des Erholungs- und der modernen Militärtheorie und diesen Optionen. Das neue Buzzword von Politik auf beiden Seiten der Atlantik ist Industriepolitik. Die Kombination der Spenden, der Zusehung der Energie in diesem Bill, der Chips- und Science Act, das jetzt in der Regel in der Regel in der Regel geschehen ist, die 280 Billionen an Spenden für Science und 52 Billionen allein für die domestikische Produktion von Semiconductor in den USA, ist ein sehr dramatischer Schritt. Im Falle ist die Chips-Akt nicht nur ein Science- und Mikrochips-Akt, es ist auch ein Blue Sky Energy Transition Clean Energy Act, also enthält 67 Billionen Dollar für die Entwicklung von radikaler neuen Energieteknologien.
Das heißt, der Paradigmenwechsel ist jetzt, dass man einen engen Zusammen- schluss erlebt von Politik und Wirtschaft. Wir werden uns gleich noch ansehen, was damit Wirtschaft gemeint ist. Also es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass Scholz da stand und sagt und rein Metall und so weiter, sondern er bezieht sich dann auf Technologieunternehmen. Das können wir in den USA auch beobachten. Und was noch hinzukommt, ist, dass wir ja in den USA mit diesem Build Back Better Act zu tun hatten, der dann von Joe Manchin und einigen anderen torpediert wurde. Und nun gibt es ja denen abgespeckter Formen doch, aber es ist nicht mehr ein Klimaschutzprogramm und ein Sozialprogramm als Framing. Natürlich steckt da immer noch das drin, sondern es ist jetzt ein Bekämpfungsmittel gegen die Inflation. Es ist ein Anti-Inflation-Programm, das man da hat. Und unter dieser Prämisse, interessanterweise, hat dann auch ein Joe Manchin zugestimmt. Natürlich mit vielen Zugestellnissen, die gemacht werden mussten. Und da zeigt sich ja doch schon eine ganz deutliche Verschiebung, was jetzt offenbar funktioniert.
Ja, vor allem haben wir hier wieder Adam Toos gehört, wie er diese großen Zahlen nennt. Während er gleichzeitig, wenn er in Europa auftritt, immer nur sagen kann, ja sie müssen mal in diesen großen Zahlen denken. Ja, wir sind also sozusagen da auch einen Schritt zurück. Denn bislang ist es ja klar, in Magdeburg, Intel mehrere Milliarden, dann wieder Subventionen. Also die Initiative kommt von den Unternehmen und wird dann hier mit großen Steuererlässen und Förderungen unterstützt. Was wir aber eigentlich bräuchten, wäre ja, dass die Politik selbst das Geld so in den Raum stellt als Topf, als Budget und dann mal schaut, was damit passiert. Beispielsweise, indem man dann wirklich auch Universitäten noch mal bis hin zu neu gründet, um da einfach so ein Zentrum zu schaffen, um das herum dann eben solche Industrien sich ansiedeln.
Wenn du all diese Dinge hinzuweist, und wenn du auch die im Vorfeld von der Infrastruktur-Bille, die letztes Jahr verabschiedet wurde, die auch genügend Geld für die Energieversorgung enthält, dann kommt wirklich eine sehr radikale Beendung, die ist, dass die nächste Dezember die Bundesrepublik in den USA ca. 80 Billionen Dollar pro Jahr spenden wird, das drei Mal so viel wie in der vorigen Dezember, auf die erneuerbaren Technologien, die erneuerbaren Energietechnologien, das ist. Das ist ein sehr wichtiges Kompliment, ist es genug, die Energietransition gut zu verbreiten, wird Zeit sagen, generell ist das Investment wesentlich größer als das, aber historisch ist es unvergesslich, dass die Regierung auf dieser Kategorie Geld spendet.
Ja, wir haben, das hat mich damals gewundert, hier in Frankfurt einzelne Gebäude, denen man das gar nicht ansieht, da muss man dann erst bei Google Maps und dann guckt man so von oben, was wird da angezeigt als Firmenname und da sieht man auch irgendwas mit Krypto. Also irgendwelche alten Industriehallen, die noch mal benutzt werden, weil intern viel Raum und so. Und dann werden da so Krypto-Coins irgendwie, wahrscheinlich Bitcoin gemeint. Und diese Unternehmen verlassen so langsam Europa und ziehen nach Texas. Warum? Weil sie da einfach dazu buchen könnten, wie viel Strom sie brauchen. Also da sind einfach ganze Landschaften so hektargroß mit Solarplatten übersät. Und dann bucht man sich das einfach, so wie man sich Rechenkraft dazu bucht, wie man sie braucht in so riesigen Clouds, bucht man sich da einfach den Strom, wie man ihn denn braucht. So und das fand ich sehr überraschend, weil das glaubt man ja nicht von Texas. Wir haben ja immer noch diese Idee von, das ist der Ölstaat und da sind so die alten Wildwest irgendwie, da gehen wir hin, weil da finden wir das goldene, schwarze Gold und so. Aber nee, da geht man mittlerweile als hippes Startup hin, wenn man Strom on demand braucht, weil da einfach riesige Sonnenkollektoren stehen, die einem das einfach zur Verfügung stellen.
Wir hatten in einem der ersten Salons ein Buch, das hatte ich vorgestellt, Tools & Weapons, und das war von dem Microsoft-Anwalt und dessen These war, wenn wir die globalen Herausforderungen sehen, und er meinte dann ganz klar, China, aber wir können ja auch hier noch den Klimawandel hinzunehmen, dann war seine Prognose, dass jetzt es nicht mehr darum gehen kann, dass die Unternehmen versuchen, so einen Krieg zu führen gegen die Regierung. Das ist ja noch so ein bisschen der Modus, in dem Elon Musk mitunter bei Twitter unterwegs ist, um aber dann doch alles abzugreifen, was man bekommen kann. Das ist ja immer so eine sehr zweischneidige Angelegenheit. Und in Tools & Weapons war eher so ein Miteinander da, so eine neue Idee von Corporate America und Washington und alles zusammen. Und das ist etwas, was Adam Toos auch so beschreibt.
Die Entwicklung von Intel, die die Regierung sagt, was es braucht, um eine neue, absoluten, hohe Technologie-Chip-Planke zu bauen, um eine Fab zu haben. Keiner in Washington weiß, was das für eine notwendige Sache ist. Sicherlich nicht auf dem Niveau, den die Chip-Manufacturer selbst machen. Wir sehen hier eine neue Form der Schöpfung einer ganzen Serie neuer, untergezwungenen Komplexe, politischen Schleimstoffe, Staatsmöglichkeiten und hohen Technologie-Firmen.
Auf dieser reinen Hightech-Ebene stimmt das natürlich, dass die Politik das auch nicht in dieser Weise beantworten kann. Die kann nicht sagen, dass und das muss gemacht werden. Du hast ja schon mal beschrieben, wie kompliziert das eigentlich ist, ein solches Werk zu haben, dass solche Chips produzieren kann und das ist ein Spezialistenwissen, das natürlich dann nicht bei den Politikern da sein kann. Aber die Gefahr ist selbstverständlich sehr groß, wenn man ein solches Industriepolitikbündnis hat. Das kennen wir auch aus der Vergangenheit eben von den Ölkonzernen und so weiter, dass die einfach die Gesetze schreiben. Wir haben ja noch das Thema Gasumlage und Preise und so weiter heute auf der Agenda, wo man dann sehen kann, da hat die Industrie mitgeschrieben. Das ist nicht ungewöhnlich im Übrigen. Also manche haben sich auch da sehr überrascht gezeigt. Dann dachte ich mir, das wundert an sich nicht. Nur die Vorstellung, glaube ich, ist noch nicht so ganz durchgesickert, dass, wenn diese Art der Zusammenarbeit, die er hier beschreibt und steht, dann bedeutet das nicht, dass alle an einem Strang unbedingt ziehen. Also wenn man so ganz weit rauszoomt, dann kommt man vielleicht dazu. Aber sonst gibt es da durchaus Leute, die ihre Interessen haben. Und um das mal vorwegzugreifen, ich glaube, dass das etwas ist, was arg unterschätzt wurde. Ich will es nicht allzu gemein formulieren, aber dass ich bei Habeck, den wir ja auch schon hier gelobt haben, mitunter den Eindruck habe, er könnte alles auf so einer vernünftigen Diskursebene fast so Habermaßmäßig aushandeln. Und dann kommen wir zu einer vernünftigen Lösung. Aber nein, man muss auch wissen, in den Energiekonzernen und was weiß ich, Zulieferern, sind Leute, die nicht an dem vernünftigen Diskurs interessiert sind, um am Ende ein schönes Resultat für alle zu haben. Sondern da geht es einfach darum, wer kriegt noch eine Million mehr und was muss ich tun, damit ich die bekomme?
Ja, wir haben ja Habeck hier zweimal dokumentiert. Einmal beim Wohnbautag, wo er den Unternehmen, die anwesend waren, sagte, wieso fördern wir eigentlich noch diesen Standard, diesen 55% im Vergleich zu 1990 energetischer Bauen, obwohl der längst Standard ist, könnten sie uns da nicht mal Bescheid sagen, dass wir hier eigentlich Standards fördern. Und dasselbe ja nochmal beim Industrietag, wo er auch dem ganzen BDI-Unternehmen sagte, ich hoffe, wir verarschen uns hier nicht, sondern sie sagen mir einfach Bescheid. Und in der Hinsicht fand ich es auch folgerechtig, dass er da im Spiegel einfach öffentlich eingestanden hat. Also dieser Energiemarkt, das ist ja unglaublich. Ich hab mir das angeschaut und ich hab nicht durchblickt, wie die alle eigentumsrechtlich miteinander zusammenhängen und wer hier welche Hilfen dann noch abgreift und so weiter. Wo ich dachte, ja genau, er hat halt drum gebeten, nicht verarscht zu werden und hat festgestellt, hier wurde ich ganz schön verarscht bei seiner Gasumlage.
Logisch. Also man meldet sich doch nicht. Also man wird doch nicht sich melden und sagen, hallo, ich würde gern ein bisschen mehr zahlen oder das ist eine Förderung, die ich eigentlich gar nicht brauche. Sondern man hält selbstverständlich die Hand auf und wird, wenn man gefragt wird, immer so tun, als sei man besonders arm dran. Es gibt beim bei Prechts Leben des Galilei diesen wunderbaren Satz. Ich kriege ihn nur so leichtlich zitiert. Wenn du mir, wenn du mir das Pferd abkaufen willst, dann nennst du es ein Esel. Und wenn du es verkaufen willst, dann nennst du es ein Pferd. Also natürlich funktioniert auch so in einer Marktwirtschaft ein Geschäfte machen. Man geht ja, wird ja auch nicht in ein Autohaus gehen und sagen, also das ist ja so ein schönes Auto und das ist ja so toll. Ich glaube, sie verkaufen es eigentlich viel zu billig, sondern man würde sagen, naja, also da müssen wir mal mindestens 10 Prozent runter. Und genauso läuft es natürlich da. Was mich wundert ist, wir haben ja mit Karl Lauterbach schon einen Minister, der sehr für sich unterwegs ist, so muss man so zu sagen. Also mit den Fernsehkameras und allen Moderatoren natürlich auf du und du ist, aber der ja mit dem Ministerium und auch mit den so angedockten wie RKI oder so nicht kommuniziert, dann von Tilo oder so in der BPK darauf angesprochen wird, ist das nicht so und so und dann hat Karl Lauterbach eine interessante Wahrheitsauffassung. Nun wissen wir bei Habeck nicht, wie eigentlich die Kommunikation innerhalb des Ministeriums stattfindet. Ist das am Ende auch so, dass er da so sein Ding macht? Denn die Leute, die da im Ministerium sitzen, politische Beamte wie nichtpolitische Beamte, die sind ja schon eine Weile dabei. Und die wissen ja, wie diese Energieriesen so ticken. Da müsste doch eigentlich auf dieser Ebene mal so gesagt werden kann. Lassen sie sich da nicht verarschen, denn die machen das immer so. Das haben wir jetzt seit 15 Jahren so erlebt.
Also Habeck ist ja immer sehr stolz auf die Arbeit in seinem Ministerium. Da wird ja rund um die Uhr gearbeitet und so weiter. Und immer wenn ich das höre, dieses Loblied auf die eigene Belegschaft, frage ich mich natürlich entweder sagt er es, weil es wahr ist und es ist sein öffentlicher Dank, oder aber es ist sozusagen sein überbandegespielter Aufforderung, wie er sich das vorstellt und weil es nicht so ist, sagt er es nochmal öffentlich, damit sich alle um Zugzwang sehen. Es ist ein bisschen unklar immer noch. Aber wer weiß, das Ministerium ist riesig.
Es scheint ein Kommunikationsproblem offenbar zu geben, denn es müssen da Leute sein, die das durchblicken. Und das auch darauf hinweisen könnten, wenn man sie dann hören will. Das ist ja immer diese große Sache. Es gibt diesen Satz, das ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich den jetzt hier finde. Der war in den Blättern zitiert. Und der ist es wert, dass ich ihn auch zitiere jetzt mal gerade. Denn wir haben, ach ja, und zwar von Karl Deutsch. Der hat ein Buch geschrieben, Politische Kybernetik. Das ist aus den 70er Jahren. Und das wird hier in einem Aufsatz über China zitiert. Und ich fand diesen Satz sehr schön. Da heißt es, Macht hat in gewissem Sinn derjenige, der es sich leisten kann, nichts lernen zu müssen.
Das stimmt, alles delegieren. Das ist ja sowieso der Vorzug des Politikers im Amt, dass man niemals selber eine Excel-Tabelle anfassen muss. Anders als jeder Vereinsvorstand in Deutschland, der das dann wirklich können muss, für was er da eingestellt wurde. Bei Habeck, ich will es nur kurz anteasern, wir werden ja nachher noch drüber sprechen, Habeck will ja eigentlich gar keine Gasumlage, der will ja eine Übergewinnsteuer. Und es könnte durchaus sein, dass er die Gasumlage auch mit Absicht ein bisschen in den Boden rampt und noch rampt, um dann irgendwann den Punkt zu finden, in dem er sagt, wir können jetzt nicht weiter auf die FDP Rücksicht nehmen, wir brauchen jetzt die Übergewinnsteuer. Die Gasumlage hat nicht funktioniert. Aber wir hören das nachher noch mal etwas ausführlicher.
Das ist eine sehr, sehr belangte These. Ich bin gespannt. Wir sollten uns aber schon, wo wir gerade vom Klimawandel reden, etwas uns bewusst machen, was Adam Toos hier sehr klar noch mal sagt. Also erstmal verändert sich jetzt was bei dieser Industriepolitik. Hören wir erst das mal.
Die Inflation Reduction Act, so genannt, die wirklich ein Green Energy Transition Bill ist, ist, dass es den Moment markiert, in dem für das erste Mal eine genugführende Koalition von Interessen um Green Energy in den USA ausgebildet ist, um ihre eigene Industriepolitik zu bedienen. Es ist der Punkt, wo der Bewert zwischen Fossilfuelinteressen und renewable Energy Interessen in den USA geworden sind.
Das heißt, die neuen Technologien, die neuen Unternehmen, die den Klimawandel vielleicht bekämpfen oder zumindest sagen, ihn bekämpfen zu wollen, sind offenbar jetzt zum ersten Mal so mächtig, dass die fossile Industrie nicht mehr dagegen ankam, sodass das jetzt durchgekommen ist. Also das ist der Wechsel, der da ist. Jetzt könnten wir da schon gleich optimistisch werden. Und dann macht Adam Tussens aber was deutlich, was ich natürlich jetzt schon wusste, aber ist nochmal so zu hören, ist irgendwie auch wahnsinnig frustrierend.
Die Frage des Saving the Climate oder Stemming der Klima-Change ist gut über Amerikaner Reachen an diesem Punkt. Wir sind nicht mehr in den 1990ern. In 2020, das letzte Jahr, für das wir wirklich komprensive Figuren haben, hat die USA weniger als 13% der globalen Emissionsverbrauchung und China hat über 32% geschnitten.
Geben wir nicht mehr in dem Sinne den Ton an, der also wir können natürlich da ganz viel machen und können unterstützen. Und das ist ja auch immer diese Scholz Idee. Wir entwickeln hier die Technologien und er würde sagen, verkaufen sie in Afrika. Du sagst zu Recht, wenn, dann müssen wir die dahin verschenken. Das ist sicherlich so. Aber wir sind nicht mehr an dem Punkt, wo wir sagen können, der Westen produziert das meiste CO2. Und deswegen haben wir da noch die Führungsrolle in der Reduktion, sondern diese Führung ist uns quasi aus der Hand genommen durch die globale Entwicklung des Kapitalismus und auch der Demografie, sodass wir eigentlich in so einer interessanten Doppelposition sind. Zum einen sind wir da jetzt etwas marginalisierter, was unseren Anteil anbelangt. Zugleich haben wir aber noch diese enormen technischen Vorsprünge und auch die finanziellen Mittel, die uns wiederum ermöglichen, etwas zu entwickeln, was allen helfen könnte. Aber wir hätten, wenn man sich das deutlich macht, in den 90er Jahren eine Wende hinbekommen können, sodass wir wirklich da in dem Sinne Leader gewesen wären. Aber das hat nicht stattgefunden. Das heißt, wir haben diese Chance verpasst.
Ja, also als Rot-Grün regierte ab 98 war ja, das kennen wir ja alle, Deutschland 51 Prozent Weltmarktanteil bei der Windkraft und bei Solar auch weitführend. Gleichzeitig war das aber auch der Punkt, an dem Gerhard Schröder entschied, ah, dieses russische Gas, da kriegen wir auch einen guten Preis für. Da können wir so eine europäische Vormachtstellung aufbauen. Dass heute Unipa 34 Milliarden Euro, zwei Drittel der Gasumlage einheimst, hat ja damit zu tun, dass wir marktwirtschaftlich organisiert haben oder sagen wir mal privatwirtschaftlich, was eigentlich Staatsräson war. Wir kaufen russisches billiges Gas. So, wir können also beides bei Rot-Grün damals sehen, sowohl diesen gigantischen Ausbau der Erneuerbaren, als auch diese große Abhängigkeit und dieses Wieder, wir sinken wieder ab in diesen, wir holen uns das billige russische Gas. Jetzt dreht sich die Zeit so ein bisschen, weil wir zum einen sehen, ja, wenn wir alles einpreisen würden, war das doch gar nicht so billig, das alles zu verfackeln, sondern wir hätten vielleicht diesen Pfad der Erneuerbaren Energien weitergehen sollen, denn, und das ist ja so interessant, wie wir jetzt alle lernen, wie der Strommarkt funktioniert. Alle bieten Strom an und sagen, was es bei ihnen kostet, dann orientiert man sich bei dem teuersten Anbieter, das sind gerade die Gasproduzenten, zu liefern tut aber als allererstes der billigste. Wir benutzen also zuerst die billigen Erneuerbaren, haben aber diese gigantische Strompreise durch das Gas. Und das passt ja alles gar nicht mehr zusammen. Und so ist das ja auch in China gerade drunter und drüber, dass sie nämlich für sich auch sagen, komm wir bauen hier noch 140 Kohlekraftwerke, weil wir die billige Energie brauchen, weil Wirtschaftswachstum über alles. Gleichzeitig haben sie gerade gar kein Wirtschaftswachstum wegen ihrer Corona-Politik und stellen gleichzeitig noch fest, ganz schön blöd, dass der Yangtzee gerade den tiefsten Spiegel seit 150 Jahren hat und unsere ganzen Reisfelder, also Flächen so große wie Spanien und so weiter, komplett trocken liegen. Also die erwarten gar keine Reisernte dieses Jahr.
Größte Hitzewelle glaube ich in der Geschichte der Menschheit, also was da zu erleben ist.
Genau, so ein TikTok-Video geschickt, wie in den Supermärkten Schulter an Schulter die alten Leute da drin stehen, um sich einfach eine Abkühlung zu holen tagsüber. Weil das die einzigen Räume sind, die noch klimatisiert sind. Also es geht gigantisch drunter und drüber und auch China muss sich mal überlegen, wie man mit dem Klimawandel irgendwie umgeht, weil bislang haben sie ja dieses Programm komplett über Umweltschutz gefahren. Verrauchte Städte sind blöd, weil dann finden die Leute nicht zur Arbeit und so. Also schon allein, wenn man nichts sieht, aber auch wenn man dann nur krank zur Arbeit kommt und die Gesundheitskosten so hoch sind. In China wird es wahrscheinlich auch demnächst Klimapolitik geben, so wie wir es in Europa jetzt und in Amerika von 2C eben schon gehört haben.
Der Druck von der Bevölkerung ist allerdings noch nicht so hoch, auch weil noch da etwas anderes mit reinspielt. China hat ja momentan so gut wie kaum Inflation. Ich glaube, es sind so 2, 7 Prozent. Also verglichen zu den westlichen Staaten ist das ja wahnsinnig wenig. Und das liegt daran, dass die Energiepreise nicht nach oben gehen, weil das ja von den Staatskonzernen eingekauft wird und der Staat quasi den Preis damit übernimmt und das dann nicht ausspielt auf die Bürger. Die Frage, wie lange das in dieser Weise gut geht, aber dadurch bekommen die Bürger das, was wir jetzt hier erleben, in dieser Weise nicht mit. Also die sehen die Klimakatastrophe jetzt, in dem es da furchtbar heiß ist, aber sie glauben, dass das mit der Energie noch alles super läuft. Und das ist sicherlich das Problem und zugleich das Glück für die, dass die jetzt dadurch keine Inflation haben. Also diese Art der Preisdeckelung ist ja auch etwas, was die SPD hier sehr wieder zum Thema gemacht hat.
Ich kann dazu ja mal was spiegeln, was so halb passt, aber was ich super interessant fand, so aus der persönlichen Richtung. Wir waren also drei Tage im Rheinsteig und hatten alles dabei, was wir glaubten zu brauchen. Es war die erste Wanderung, nicht von allen von uns, aber von mir. Was bedeutet, naja, man hat so eine Idee von der Planung und dann zieht man diese durch und hat den Rucksack ganz schön voll mit Kram, den man vielleicht doch nicht braucht und manche Sachen fehlen. Aber ich hatte eine 30.000 mAh Powerbank dabei, von der ich wusste, na die lädt mein Handy ungefähr siebenmal. Das war ziemlich optimal. Man kommt also durch drei Tage mit einem kleinen Akku. Wenn man nichts weiter braucht als ein Handy. Und von dem aber den Anspruch hat, ich will aber nicht Energie sparen müssen, im Sinne von das Video jetzt mal lieber nicht drehen, weil Strom sparen. Also man kommt durch drei Tage. Man kann den Strom mitnehmen. Beim Wasser ist es interessanterweise so, dass man erstaunlich weit kommt mit wenig Wasser. Ich hatte also eine Trinkblase mit zwei Liter, dann noch mal einen Reserveliter dabei. Ich wusste natürlich, irgendwo wird uns schon was zu kaufen geben. Dann hatte ich noch einen Liter für Kram, den man halt so, keine Ahnung, mal die Hände waschen oder so. Erstaunlicherweise kommt man doch ganz schön weit mit so einem Liter für sich, wenn man ihn ordentlich rationiert. Also dieses, ich gehe mal zum Wasserhahn und spüle meinen halben Liter fassenden Proteinbecher mit zwei Litern Wasser aus, weil da ja irgendwo noch so ein kleines Ding war, was ich auch mit dem Lappen hätte wegwischen können. Aber nee, ich muss noch mal ein Liter Wasser durchjagen. Es gibt dieses Gesetz, man hatte mir den Namen mal genannt, wenn man einen Benchmark hat, dann optimiert man auch dahin. So und das wird einem total gewahr, wenn man bergauf bergab läuft und genau weiß, ne, das sind so kleine Dörfer, hier gibt es keine Dorfstenke, hier kannst du nirgendwo was machen. Und dann, ah, Friedhöfe. Man plant also eine Wanderung um Friedhöfe, weil man weiß, da ist immer eine Frischwasserleitung, weil die ja ihre Blumen gießen wollen. So, und dann steht man da und nimmt sich einfach eine halbe Stunde, mischt sich seine Vitamine, mischt sich sein Protein, wäscht sich die Hände und mal das Gesicht. So, ja, und man kommt mit Zeit und wenig Wasser und noch weniger Energie wirklich bequem, sodass alle Spaß haben, durch drei Tage. Wenn man dieses Verhalten mal zu Hause hinbekäme, könnten wir locker 90 Prozent von dem, was wir alles verbrauchen, einfach mal sparen, statt uns so händeringend, oh Gott, wie schaffen wir diese 20 Prozent und so weiter? Also vielleicht brauchen wir echt einfach nur einen anderen. Und jetzt kommt das Wort, an dem man erkennt, dass es natürlich nie so kommen wird. Man braucht einfach mal ein anderes Mindset.
Ja, also ich möchte kein Mindset dieser Art haben. Also was du da jetzt als so schön und praktisch beschreibst, klingt für mich nach einem Horrorausflug. Also diese drei Tage hätte ich wahrscheinlich nicht überlebt.
Du wahrscheinlich nicht. Dich als Orchidee müssen wir dann irgendwie noch durchbringen durch die Gesellschaft. Aber in Frankfurt... In Frankfurt, zwei Drittel des Grundwassers der Stadt kommt aus dem Stadtwald, dessen Bäume zu 95 Prozent einfach keine Erwartung auf Überleben der nächsten fünf Jahre. Jetzt ist echt die Frage, was machen wir denn da? Und ich glaube, es ginge irgendwie, aber man muss dann doch so ein bisschen die Benchmarks setzen.
Aber man muss auch ganz klar, dass an die... Also diese Forderungen an die Industrie primär richten. Also wir haben das jetzt auch zum Beispiel beim Gas. Im Juli wurde ja auch die ganze Zeit gesagt, wir müssen weniger Gas verbrauchen. Nun ist es so, dass Privathaushalte im Juli so gut wie kein Gas verbrauchen. Also da ist vielleicht mal irgendwo ein Gasherd noch an oder so. Also das spielt einfach keine Rolle. Und dann kann man sehen, also der Gasverbrauch im Juli ist vor allem einer der Industrie. Und wie viel weniger wurde dann verbraucht, trotz all diese Aufrufe und auch der Selbstkasteiung, die eingefordert wurde und was weiß ich, na ja, 3%. Und das war wahrscheinlich ja noch von den Privathaushalten. Das heißt, also da wird gar kein Schritt gemacht, wenn man sie nicht dazu zwingt. Kommen wir noch einmal zurück nach Prag mit zwei Clips, und zwar zu Scholz, der jetzt noch sich sagt, bei dieser Grundsatzrede könnte ich ja noch über mein altes Leib und Magenthema Finanzpolitik sprechen. Wir hören da mal rein.
Meine Damen und Herren, das Feld, das uns Europäer neben der Migration in den vergangenen Jahren am meisten in Zweite war, die Fiskalpolitik. Das in der Corona-Krise beschlossene historische Aufbauprogramm markiert jedoch einen Wendepunkt. Erstmals haben wir zusammen eine europäische Antwort gegeben und die nationalen Investitions- und Reformprogramme mit Mitteln der EU unterstützt. Wir haben uns darauf geeinigt, gemeinsam zu investieren, um unsere Volkswirtschaften zu stärken. Das hilft uns übrigens auch in der gegenwärtigen Krise. Ideologie ist Pragmatismus gewichen. Davon sollten wir uns leiten lassen, wenn es um die Frage geht, wie wir unsere gemeinsamen Regeln auch über die Corona-Krise hinaus weiterentwickeln.
Ideologie ist Pragmatismus gewichen. Und jetzt denkt man, wenn Ideologie Pragmatismus weicht, was ist denn eigentlich? Kommt jetzt das Neue? Also verkündet er jetzt vielleicht doch noch irgendetwas? Nee, wir gehen jetzt sofort mit Olaf Scholz wieder zurück zur Ideologie.
Nun haben die Krisen der vergangenen Jahre die Schuldenstände in allen Mitgliedstaaten steigen lassen. Deshalb brauchen wir eine Verständigung darüber, wie wir diese hohen Schuldenstände abbauen. Diese Übereinkunft muss verbindlich sein, Wachstum ermöglichen und politisch vermittelbar sein. Und zugleich muss sie allen EU-Staaten ermöglichen, die Transformation unserer Volkswirtschaften durch Investitionen zu meistern. Anfang des Monats haben wir als deutsche Regierung unsere Vorstellung zur Weiterentwicklung der europäischen Schuldenregeln vorgelegt.
Sie folgen der alten Ideologie. Also Schuldenabbau, ich würde sagen Schuldenerlass.
Also was er auch hier wieder versucht, ist ja die Quadratur des Kreises, dass er sagt, wir brauchen mehr Investitionen. Was für ihn besonders wichtig ist, da wir als Exportland darauf angewiesen sind, dass wir die anderen Länder mit unseren Gütern beglücken. Die sollen das bitte von uns kaufen, weil wir vor allem davon leben. Und sollen aber zugleich sparsam sein. Das ist das, was Heiner Flassbeck in all den Jahren immer und immer wieder wiederholen hat. Und was Heiner Flassbeck immer analysiert hat, wie verrückt eigentlich diese Ideologie ist. Und Scholz kommt da jetzt wieder und sagt, wir haben das jetzt mal vergemeinschaft. Da haben wir an einem Strang gezogen während der Krise. Und sagt aber, jetzt müssen wir mal schauen, wie wir die Schulden wieder abbauen. Ist es eigentlich eine Grundsatzrede, die in ihren hellsten Momenten sich ein bisschen was von Macron klaut und sonst eigentlich das Übliche ist, was man von deutscher Politik in Europa kennt?
Ja, fast liegt die Verschwörungsgedankenwelt nahe, dass Scholz gewartet hat, bis Draghi abgeschossen wurde im Italien. Um dann kurz mal anzumerken, ja, wir könnten durchaus mal ein bisschen mehr europäisches Geld vertragen. Mit Draghi ging ja auch dieser große Plan von Macron und Draghi, einfach mal diese EU-Verschuldung richtig zu forcieren. Stattdessen wissen wir ja, mit wem Olaf Scholz regiert, Christian Lindner, und der sagt nun wirklich eindeutig und explizit, nein, diese Verschuldung Europas gab es ja nur wegen Corona. Und das ist ja alles vorbei. 2023 sind doch alle Krisen vorbei. Dann werden wir doch die Schuldenbremse wieder einhalten. Es ist einfach zum Schreien, aber haben wir ja hier auch schon viel gemacht. Bleiben wir mal so ein bisschen knapp beim Thema. Es ist in Deutschland eine neue Antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte am Werk. Wir kennen sie alle, Ferda Attermann, denn sie hat schon mal Sachen über Deutsche geschrieben, mit den Worten Kartoffeln und so weiter. Alle die Diskussionen, die uns gar nicht interessieren müssen, weil es gibt ja schon tausende andere Podcasts, wo sowas diskutiert wird.
Du liest ja auch nicht gerade Winnetour nämlich an.
Ach du Gott, nein. Und ich gucke mir auch diesen Film nicht an. Wir hören hier im Fernsehen eine Moderation zum Thema der Antidiskriminierungsbericht wurde vorgestellt.
Wer Hass und Diskriminierung nicht selbst erlebt, kann es oft nicht fassen. Für Betroffene aber ist das viel zu oft Alltag. Diskriminierung in Deutschland bleibe auf hohem Niveau und sei alarmierend, sagte die neue Antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte Ferda Attermann, als sie heute den Jahresbericht vorstellte. Mehr als 5.600 Anfragen gingen bei der Antidiskriminierungsstelle des Bundes im vergangenen Jahr ein. Die Dunkelziffer sei aber viel höher. Die meisten Probleme bereitet Rassismus, aber Diskriminierung hat viele Seiten.
So, die meisten Probleme bereitet Rassismus, aber Diskriminierung hat viele Seiten. Jetzt ist ja so, dass der Antidiskriminierungsbericht sich zusammensetzt aus dem, was tatsächlich da aufgelaufen ist. Es gibt eine Adresse, wo man sich melden kann oder wo auch immer durchgezählt wird. Während wir Antidiskriminierung immer nur, das findet halt bei Twitter statt, typische mediale Wellen, die dann so durchgeritten werden. Es gab zum Beispiel einen Texthinweis, vielleicht ein Salonkandidat, muss ich mal noch schauen, nächste Woche, eine technische Auswertung, dass es gar keinen Winnetou Shitstorm gab. Sondern inzwischen gibt es nur noch die Vogue-Stürme. Aber es gibt gar niemanden, der wirklich der finnische Ministerpräsidenten gesagt hat, es ist aber nicht gut, wie du tanzt. Oder der wirklich gesagt hat, Winnetou soll jetzt aber hier durchgeboxt werden usw.
Also das wird doch alles miteinander vermischt. Dann geht es plötzlich um Karl Mays Winnetou. Hier geht es aber einfach um ein Kinderbuch, das so ein bisschen an diese Winnetou-Figur von Karl May angelegt ist. Dann sagt man, in Verlag macht es nicht mehr, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, weil sich irgendjemand angeblich beschwert hat. Dann geht etwas in Gang, was überhaupt nicht existiert. Es gibt gar nicht diese Fronten. Die Fronten entstehen dann dadurch, dass man behauptet, sie sind da. Und dann bilden sie sich. Das ist etwas, was dann auch immer abstrusere Züge annimmt. Dann gibt es ja sofort Leute, die dann das entsprechende Kalmai-Zitat zur Hand haben. Eigentlich würde ich mir so eine Debatte gefallen lassen, wenn man dann sagt, Moment, stopp, wir haben jetzt diese Debatte. Wir müssen jetzt aber erst mal Lektüre leisten. Und jetzt lesen wir alle die 32 oder 34 Kalmai-Bände. Dann müssen wir die Auseinandersetzung von Ernst Bloch, Arno Schmidt und Postcolonial Theory lesen. Und wenn wir das alles haben, dann noch die Gedichte zu Kalmai von Roger Wilhelmsen, dann treffen wir uns nochmal und reden darüber. Und das Schöne wäre dann, bis das alles getan ist, ist die Debatte schon längst in der Vergessenheit. Und das passiert aber nicht. Und stattdessen gibt es so eine Hochkitzel. Und man sucht, ob man einen Shitstorm herstellen kann. Ich habe gestern etwas entdeckt bei Twitter. Ein User hat auf das Phänomen hingewiesen, dass manche Profile entstehen und sagen wir mal, so ein bisschen linksliberalen Content von sich geben, wo sie irgendwie sagen, ja, man muss ein bisschen gesünder sich ernähren und Tiere und ein bisschen Klimawandel usw. Also man verschafft sich so ein bisschen Reichweite, paar hundert Follower. Und dann haut man irgendwann so einen ganz merkwürdigen Tweet aus, dass man sagt, also wenn die, wer nicht bereit ist, vegan zu leben, der muss auch in Zukunft damit rechnen, dass er hungern wird. Oder so Sachen, also sowas richtig gegen arme Menschen. Und dadurch hat man dann die linksliberale Gruppe, die man dort erst um sich gescharrt hat, gegen sich, die retweeten das und kommentieren das entsprechend, die Rechten werden darauf aufmerksam. Und so kann man dann eine extreme Reichweite mit einem eigentlich Shitposting-Profil zielen und bindet dadurch unglaublich viele Kräfte. Also das heißt, da sind dann Leute stundenlang damit beschäftigt mit diesem Tweet und die können sich in der Zeit nicht mit was anderem beschäftigen. Und ich erinnere daran, dass in einem Interview vor einigen Monaten Ulf Poschert auch sagte, wenn er bei Twitter schreibt, Freiheit für die Böller oder sowas, da sagt er, da sind die Linken dann tagelang mit beschäftigt, da bindet er Kräfte, das sei wunderbar, deswegen tue er das.
Genau, wir bräuchten hier eigentlich so eine neue Aufklärung eines platonschen Höhlen, Raumes oder sowas, wo dieses, du hast es ja auch in der Filmanalys zum Känguru-Dings, Leute gehen ins Kino und kämpfen nicht mal mehr gegen Windmühlen, sondern nur noch gegen so laue Windchen, die ihnen so entgegengepustet werden von der Leinwand, weil da irgendwas dargestellt wird, wie es angeblich und so, als ob hier irgendwie Kängurus rumrennen und tatsächlich gegen Verschwörung, also als ob es da irgendeine Grundlage gäbe, auf der man überhaupt operiert. Und das ist mir hier auch aufgefallen, bzw. ich stelle es als Frage in den Raum, denn wir haben jetzt diesen Unterschied, gut, wir haben eine Gesetzeslage, Artikel 3 Grundgesetz wird uns vielleicht nochmal vorgelesen, aber wir haben eben auf der einen Seite dieses Twitter-Diskurs-Phänomen und auf der anderen Seite echte Menschen beschweren sich über echte Vorfälle bei der echten Politik und die schreiben dann einen echten Bericht. Und jetzt kann man mal die Prioritäten hier hören, denn man hat natürlich Ferda Atemann zum Gespräch gehabt, sowohl in den Tagesthemen als auch im Heuder-Journal. Und wir hören mal in der Liste der Prioritäten, die sich politisch ergibt, welche Form der Diskriminierung von ihr jetzt besonders scharf mal beobachtet werden muss. Ich vermute, sie macht das hier nach Priorität, ihre Auflistung.
Sie sind jetzt seit einem Monat im Amt. Sie haben sich Schwerpunkte gesetzt. Worauf wollen Sie sich fokussieren?
Mir ist es wichtig, dass alle Menschen ihre Rechte kennen. Wir wissen, dass ein Drittel der Bevölkerung gar nicht weiß, dass Diskriminierung verboten ist und dass man gegen Diskriminierung vorgehen kann. Und ich glaube, viele Menschen wissen auch nicht, welche Diskriminierungsgründe geschützt sind. Also Alter, Behinderung, Geschlecht, sexuelle Identität, Religion und Weltanschauung, die Herkunft, also rassistische und antisemitische Diskriminierung.
Sie nennt einfach Alter zuerst. Und ich finde das sehr interessant in dieser Altenrepublik, weil ja, Alter ist in Deutschland ein Megaproblem. Sowohl für die Alten als auch für die Jungen, die nämlich entsprechend ihres Alters diskriminiert werden. Bettina Schaußen liest uns hier mal den Artikel 3 Grundgesetz vor.
Niemand darf wegen seines Geschlechts, seiner Abstammung, seiner Rasse, seiner Sprache, seiner Heimat und Herkunft, seines Glaubens, seiner religiösen oder politischen Anschauungen benachteiligt oder bevorzugt werden. So steht es in Artikel 3 unseres Grundgesetzes.
So, dann haben wir natürlich noch als Ergänzung das Allgemeine Gleichbehandlungsgesetz, das dann Gründen der Rasse, ethnische Herkunft, Geschlecht, Religion, Weltanschauung, Behinderung. Dann kommt das Alter und dann kommt sexuelle Identität. Aber auch im heutigen Journal nennt Vater Mann das Alter zuerst.
Ich freue mich sehr, dass ich die Möglichkeit habe, für alle Menschen eine Bundesbeauftragte zu sein. Und das ist ja zum ersten Mal so, dass wir eine Bundesbeauftragtenstelle haben dafür. Für alle Menschen, die Diskriminierung erleben, aufgrund des Alters, wegen einer Behinderung, wegen verschiedenen Gründen, die sie auch schon vorhin genannt haben. Und das ist mir eine große Ehre und eine Verpflichtung.
So, Alters spielt anscheinend schon eine sehr große Rolle in einer konkreten Politik, wo man tatsächlich mit diesen, sozusagen, empirischen Diskriminierungsformen zu tun hat. Und nicht da, wo man darüber diskutiert, kulturelle Aneignungen.
Und das will ich nur mal... Also eine Diskriminierung, die beispielsweise antisemitisch ist oder rassistisch ist, die ist ja sehr klar zu definieren. Und wie ist es aber jetzt beim Alter? Also was verstehe ich da unter einer Altersdiskriminierung? Also das gibt es natürlich jetzt bei Bewerbungen oder solchen Dingen. Da kann man sicherlich das auch ziemlich konkret machen. Aber es ist ja doch auch in unserem Verständnis etwas anderes, wenn jemand jetzt, sagen wir, antisemitisch beleidigt wird. Oder wenn wir sagen, diese alte Esel, warum muss er überhaupt noch Auto fahren? Da würde man jetzt nicht sagen, oh Wolfgang, das ist aber ganz schlimme Altersdiskriminierung. Also ich glaube, die wenigsten würden das zumindest sagen.
Also die Altersdiskriminierung ist knallhart in der Arbeitswelt. Wenn du dich einfach bewirbst und genau weißt, weil du 55 bist, wirst du hier nicht eingestellte. Die wollen keine alten Knacker. Die wollen junge, innovative und auch gut aussehende Menschen. Das gehört auch dazu. Dann natürlich, du hast jetzt 20, 30 Jahre lang gearbeitet und endlich kannst du dir dein Traumauto kaufen, brauchst aber einen Kredit. Gehst zur Bank und die sagen, sie sind schon zu alt dafür. Leider, sie stoßen ja schon, bevor der Kredit zurückgezahlt werden kann an die Altersgrenze, ihre Berufstätigkeit usw. Also Alter ist, wenn es ums Geld geht, eine ziemlich harte Diskriminierungs- sache, von der ich wirklich glaube, dass sie da ganz häufig genannt wird.
Da wird sie aber gar nicht richtig angegangen. Also das ist nicht diese Debatte. Also das ist sowas, was man der Privatwirtschaft quasi überlässt. Oder klar, es gibt dann schon mal so Regelungen bei Bewerbungen, dass das dann zumindest nicht in dieser Weise begründet werden kann. Aber natürlich kennt man aus dem Bekanntenkreis Menschen mit 55, war zumindest sehr lange so. Ich weiß nicht, wie es jetzt bei all dem Personalmangel ist. Aber da war es zumindest so, also in den Nullerjahren für Menschen, die 55 waren, war es ganz, ganz schwierig, überhaupt einen Job zu bekommen, egal von welcher Position wir da jetzt sprechen. Und gerade so dieses mittlere Management oder so, da wurde man sehr schnell ausrangiert. Das ist definitiv so. Und zugleich haben wir aber doch, wenn wir über das Alter sprechen, das als sowas Positives, wenn es um Jüngere geht. Also man hat jetzt die Artikel gelesen, dass der Papst neue Kardinale berufen hat. Und einer zum Beispiel ist 48, was natürlich für katholische Verhältnisse extrem jung ist. Und man hat dann aber auch diese Altersdiskriminierung insofern, als man ja nicht mehr den Papst wählen darf, wenn man über 80 ist.
16 oder 20 dürfen noch den Papst wählen.
Genau, also so Sachen haben wir dann da. Oder wir haben viele deutsche Bischof, die über 80 sind, die dann nicht mehr wählen dürfen. Und dass sich das jetzt auch alles sehr wegentwickelt von Europa, vom Westen auch wegentwickelt, dass der Papst dann da tatsächlich andere Regionen, Ozeanien und so mit rein nimmt bei der Kardinalswahl. Übrigens auch die Konservativen, die sich jetzt gerade da für die Abtreibungsverbote starkmachen. Diese Bischöfe hat er übergangen. Ja, also auch ist ganz bemerkenswert, dieser einen Bischof, der sich da mit Pelosi angelegt hat und ihr die Kommunion verweigert hat, den hat er auch nicht benannt. Der wäre auf der Liste gewesen, eigentlich ganz bemerkenswert. Aber da haben wir so eine Fokussierung auf das Alter und finden das ja auch gut. Also wir haben da auch so eine Altersidentitätspolitik irgendwie. Und wissen aber zugleich, das Alter grundsätzlich, also Jungsein hilft nicht. Also ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal wiederholt. Aber guck dir die jungen Bundestagsabgeordneten an. Die sind ja nicht besser als die 70-Jährigen.
Ja, also Attermann hat ja hier gesagt, viele kennen gar nicht die Gründe, aus denen sie Diskriminierung anmerken, wenn nicht sogar einklaren, also die Folgen einklaren können. Ich wäre total dafür, dass alle unter 18-Jährigen in Deutschland mal ihr Wahlrecht einfordern, im Sinne eines Diskriminierungsunterlassungsanfangs.
Dann hat die FDP dann 30 Prozent.
Das stimmt, aber dann rutschen die halt automatisch mal in den Blick der Wahlgruppe.
Aber das hat doch nichts mit Altersdiskriminierung zu tun. Also ich kann das gerne mit mir darüber reden, ob man ab 16 wählt oder nicht. Aber das hat ja nichts mit Diskriminierung zu tun, ist man manche Dinge dann noch nicht. Es ist ja eher eine Frage von von Mündigkeit. Jetzt kann ich auch sagen, manche 70-Jährigen sind auch nicht besonders mündig. Oder man kann auch eine Frage stellen bei manchen Wahlentscheidungen, ob davon mündig wird auszugehen ist. Aber das ist doch nicht eine Frage der Altersdiskriminierung.
Also ich würde sagen, es ist eine Frage, was ist eigentlich Diskriminierung? Denn Attermann will hier eine neue Kategorie der Diskriminierung aufnehmen, über die wir mal kurz diskutieren.
Tatsächlich wird das sehr wahrscheinlich eine große Rolle spielen und das hat auch eine gewisse soziale Sprengkraft, dass Menschen erleben, dass sie eben wegen ihres sozialen Status oder weil sie Sozialhilfeempfängerinnen sind, nicht genug in den Blick genommen werden oder bestimmte Zugänge nicht haben. Und da müssen wir auch, oder da muss der Gesetzgeber auch nachjustieren. Im Moment ist Diskriminierung aufgrund des sozialen Status nicht vom Gesetz erfasst, vom Diskriminierungsschutz. Sie haben es gerade schon gesagt. Und das müssen wir jetzt mit der anstehenden allgemeinen Gleichbehandlungsgesetzreform, ein sehr langes Wort, angehen.
Das ist natürlich das totale Paradox.
Das ist jetzt der Klassismusdiskurs, den sie jetzt hier aufgreift. Und der Klassismusbegriff ist ja eine schwierige Angelegenheit. Also zum einen ist damit ja verknüpft, dass man sagt, es geht nicht, dass Leute diskriminiert werden aufgrund dessen, dass sie zum Beispiel wenig Geld haben oder dass sie arbeitslos sind, was auch immer. Das ist ja etwas, was sehr stark durch den amerikanischen oder den englischsprachigen Diskurs geprägt wurde durch Bell Hooks und einige andere Theoretiker. Und da gibt es aber das große Problem bei diesem Klassismus, dass es ja nicht nur darum geht, schöne Worte zu finden oder schlimme Worte zu vermeiden, sondern die Frage ist, und deswegen haben sehr viele Linke auch ein Problem mit diesem Klassismusbegriff, eigentlich wollen wir ja nicht, dass einfach nur die Armen auch nett und lieb behandelt werden, sondern es geht um die Abschaffung der Armut.
Ja, aber hier steckt ja drin, also Geld regelt, wie wir mit knappen Gütern umgehen. Es ist also prinzipiell so vorgesehen, dass wir mit Hilfe des Geldes diskriminieren, nämlich Chancen und Zugang verweigern. Gleichzeitig haben wir eine Antidiskriminierungsbeauftragte, die sagt, und das ist dann das, was sie eigentlich sagen will, aber dann nicht wenigstens noch beleidigen. Also sie fordert im Grunde mehr Höflichkeit bei, wir verwähren dir aber Zugang zu dieser Dienstleistung oder diesem Gut, du kannst es nicht kaufen, aber du darfst nicht auch gleichzeitig noch beleidigt werden dabei. Und das ist natürlich total verrückt, sowas in Gesetzesform zu gießen, weil wir dann in so Diskursen drin sind, was ist eigentlich Höflichkeit und so weiter.
Und man manifestiert damit am Ende die Armut. Also ich glaube, ich bin sehr natürlich dafür, dass man eine gewisse Sprachsensibilität an den Tag legt oder so. Und wir hatten ja diesen ganzen Diskurs im Zuge von Hartz IV, im Privatfernsehen, aber auch weit darüber hinaus im Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, von den Faulenzern, die alles vom Staat kassieren und so weiter. Also das ist natürlich etwas, was kritisch betrachtet werden muss. Und das darf auch nicht sein. Aber ich warne sehr davor, wenn man den Klassismusbegriff so eng auffasst, dass man nicht mehr eine Klassenpolitik daraus macht, sondern nur noch sagt, können wir höflich miteinander umgehen. Dann sagen wir eigentlich, ja, es gibt solche und solche. Das ist so wie Ständegesellschaft. Da sagt man, jeder hat im Untergottes Himmel seinen Platz. Der eine ist der König und der andere ist der Bettler und der andere ist der Bauer.
Ich meine, was für Probleme haben wir schon beim Gendern in der Sprache. Aber was soll das jetzt werden? Was für eine Diskussion wird hier jetzt, wenn man sozialen Status nicht mehr abbilden darf in der Sprache, weil das ja diskriminieren würde? Das ist völlig harnäckig, es überhaupt auf der Ebene anzuplanen, das in Gesetzesform gießen zu wollen.
Es ist furchtbar. Das war ja etwas, wovor einige linke und auch marxistische Theoretiker immer bei diesem Klassismusbegriff gewarnt haben. Dann konnte man aber auch immer die positiven Seiten natürlich daraus sehen, gerade wenn man sich solche Hartz-IV-Berichterstattung ansieht, dass das dann vielleicht durch eine Thematisierung in Zukunft nicht mehr stattfindet. Aber es ist genau das, wovor man jetzt gewarnt hat, dass man keine Klassenpolitik mehr eigentlich betreiben will, sondern dass man nur noch schöne Worte für das Elend findet. Und meine These ist auch, Menschen, die von Armut z.B. betroffen sind oder drei Minijobs machen müssen, um irgendwie über die Runden zu kommen, deren geringstes Problem ist wahrscheinlich, dass man hin und wieder irgendein abfälliges Wort fiel, sondern die hätten eigentlich gern mehr Geld.
Genau.
Und da würde es was kosten allerdings.
Genau, das würde was kosten. Das ist der Vorschlag, der hier kommt, von einer Seite, die es wirklich sehr gut meint, ist, wir müssen alle sozialpolitischen Probleme weiter verstecken hinter einer besseren Semantik. Wir machen jetzt Semantikpolitik, um die sozialen Fragen auszublenden. Das ist natürlich, das ist wirklich hane Büchen. Aber gut, übers Alter, über die Jungen, also über das Alter als Thema und dann die Jungen als Problem, müssen wir aber hier auch noch sprechen, und das war nämlich die Woche auch Thema. Wir haben es, und das koppelt ein bisschen an das Thema, von eben mit einer sehr krassen Lage am Ausbildungsmarkt zu tun. Wir hören uns das mal hier im O-Ton, das ist diese Woche an.
Die Lage auf dem Ausbildungsmarkt hat sich aus Sicht des Deutschen Industrie- und Handelskammertages noch einmal verschafft. Laut einer Umfrage des DIHK sei es noch nie schwieriger gewesen, geeignete Azubis zu finden. 40 Prozent der Betriebe hätten im vergangenen Jahr nicht alle Ausbildungsplätze besetzen können.
So, das ist eine gigantisch hohe Zahl. Und wir haben aber gehört bei ihm, geeignete Kandidaten zu finden. Und da schwingt ja bei vielen immer noch so eine Vorstellung von Fachkräftemangel ist eine ideologische Benutzung der Industrie, weil die wollen ja geeignete Kandidaten. Selbst wenn die sieben Bewerber haben pro Stelle, reden die davon, einen Fachkräftemangel zu haben. Und die Zahlen sind aber wirklich ganz andere mittlerweile.
Besonders stark betroffen sind auch Betriebe in der Gastronomie, bei Transport und Logistik, dem Handwerk und dem Bau. Für einige Ausbildungsplätze habe es in diesem Jahr noch nicht einmal eine Bewerbung gegeben. Die Unternehmen gehen deshalb neue Wege, um attraktiver zu werden. Von den befragten Betrieben werben 58% mit flacheren Hierarchien, 51% versuchen mit einer modernen IT-Technik Azubis anzulocken. Etwa ein Drittel bietet finanzielle Anreize. Diese werden vor allem im Bau und in der Gastronomie geboten, wo etwa mobiles Arbeiten nicht möglich ist. Ein Grund für die schwierige Lage ist nach Meinung des DIHK auch die Pandemie, weil eine Berufsorientierung in den letzten Jahren schlicht nicht stattgefunden habe.
Also ein bisschen Corona-Nachwehe ist natürlich auch dabei, aber es ist vor allem auch Demografie vor, also einschwenken ins demografische Problem. Ein Drittel ist mittlerweile bereit, mehr Geld zu bieten. Und trotzdem ist dieses ein Drittel mehr Geld noch auf Platz 3 erst. Sondern man versucht vorher noch mit technischer Ausstattung, was jungen Menschen sehr wichtig ist. Hier hören auch relativ viele, wenn man so bei Spotify guckt in der Statistik, relativ viele, gerade so Millennials irgendwie zu. 25 bis 35. Man kann sich nicht genau vorstellen, wie die 20-Jährigen heute wirklich drauf sind gerade. Also es ist eine ganz andere Generation. Da müssten auch nochmal Bücher geschrieben werden. Da kann man jedenfalls nicht einfach den Mindset von uns irgendwie über, und dann nervt schon irgendwie hin und so. Nee, die 20-Jährigen sind wirklich nochmal anders drauf. Und wenn man denen mit Arbeitszeitregelungen und, keine Ahnung, technischer Ausstattung und, bei uns hast du keinen Chef, sondern eine flache Hierarchie, das sind echte Anreize. Glaubt man immer gar nicht, aber da ist was los.
Und viele Unternehmen gehen ja auch auf TikTok, um dort Leute zu inspirieren. Das ist ja etwas, das sie versuchen, über TikTok an Leute ranzukommen, die überhaupt erreichen damit. Also das ist ja auch etwas, was man dann wissen muss. Hier gibts einen finanziellen Anreiz oder außerdem bekommst du noch drei iPads dazu oder was auch immer. Und das wird dann tatsächlich über so TikTok-Werbungen immer wieder versucht jetzt.
Genau, man muss die Leute wirklich da abholen, wo sie sind. Das ist in dem Fall nicht nur eine Floskel, denn wir haben eben schon gehört, manche Unternehmen bleiben bei Null Bewerbungen. Also die machen riesige Aufrisse, gehen zu diesen Berufsmessen usw. Und am Ende meldet sich genau niemand.
Laut dem Deutschen Industrie- und Handelskammer-Tag war es noch nie so schwierig, Azubis zu finden. Das ist auch eine Folge von Corona, weil durch die Kontaktbeschränkungen etwa die Berufsberatung deutlich schwieriger wurde. Das wird besser, was aber bleibt, ist die demografische Entwicklung. Deutschlands Unternehmen fehlt der Nachwuchs. Und so gibt es immer häufiger einfach keine Bewerbungen. Laut einer DIHK-Umfrage konnten über 40% der befragten Betriebe vergangenes Jahr nicht alle Ausbildungsplätze besetzen. Ein Rekord. Und jede dritte von diesen Firmen erhielt keine einzige Bewerbung. Am stärksten betroffen ist das Gastgewerbe, gefolgt von Transport und Logistik und der Industrie.
Und auch dies ist ein Versäumnis der Bundesregierung. Ich erinnere mich noch an einen Ausschnitt aus einer Talkshow. Ich glaube, es war Plasberg, wo nach dem ersten Lockdown, der zweite Lockdown dreute, ein Azubi da war, der eigentlich eine Ausbildung, oder der war noch kein Azubi, der eine Ausbildung anfangen wollte im Hotel. Das hat aber dann nicht geklappt wegen Corona. Dann haben die das erst mal verschoben. Und dann bekam der aber vom Staat keine vernünftige Unterstützung, war erst ausgezogen, musste dann wieder bei den Eltern einziehen, weil er sich das anders nicht leisten konnte. Und da wird es ganz viele geben, die erst mal dann dadurch ganz rausgefallen sind aus der Sache und dann nicht mehr reinkommen sind. Oder dann gesagt haben, na dann studiere ich lieber mal doch und fange nicht mit einer Ausbildung an, dann kann ich in eine andere Stadt, vielleicht bekomme ich das über BAföG und so, ein bisschen besser geregelt und dann bin ich da erst mal besser geparkt. Und damit ist dieses Ausbildungsthema dann erst mal gegessen. Und da hätte man auch von Seiten der Regierung eine viel stärkere Azubi-Unterstützung leisten müssen. Und nicht einfach sagen, na ja, da müsst ihr jetzt mal euch ein paar Monate gedulden. Also da waren ja Politiker anwesend, die dann dazu befragt wurden und die dann einfach gesagt haben, ja, aber sie sind ja noch so jung, sie ist noch so viel Zeit und das muss man sich wirklich dann von Alten auch nicht sagen lassen.
Sie sind ja noch so jung, sie haben ja so viel Zeit, passt auch gut zu diesem, sollten wir nicht noch einmal alle zusätzlich jetzt in ein Pflichtjahr, wirtschaftsferien irgendwo zwischenparken, ja, einfach eine ganze Generation. Also so Wahnsinn. Politisches Versagen hören wir hier nochmal. Es ist wirklich grotesk, in welchem Ausmaß das in Deutschland stattfindet. Wir wissen, Olaf Scholz ist ein Freund der warmen Worte. Im Koalitionsvertrag steht drin, die Ausbildungssachen auf akademisches Niveau zu heben, also Stipendien, Auslandssemester und so weiter. All das zu machen ist auch nicht verkehrt, denn so eine Berufsausbildung gerade im Handwerk kommt auch einem Studium wirklich sehr nahe. Nur mit Praxis statt nur Schreibtisch. Und diese Zahlen hier, die am 22. auch in den Nachrichten gibt, man kriegt die Kinnlade nicht so richtig wieder hoch.
In Deutschlands Klassenräumen verbirgt sich eine Zahl, die viel zu wenig wahrgenommen wird.
Mehr als 100.000 junge Menschen verlassen die Schule jedes Jahr ohne Abschluss. Diese riesige Zahl ist zuletzt sprunghaft gestiegen. Ihnen allen fehlen Perspektiven fürs Leben. Einige von ihnen bekommen eine weitere Chance und überraschend viele von ihnen nutzen sie und kommen doch noch mit einem Abschluss nach Hause.
So, ich will jetzt keine verqueren, funktionalen, analytischen Vergleiche anstellen, aber wir lesen und sehen vielleicht auch, dass Putin, wer sonst, in Russland Gas abfackelt, das für den europäischen Markt eigentlich sein sollte. Stattdessen schickt er nur 30% durch die Pipeline und der Rest wird abgefackelt. Gleichzeitig hören wir hier in den deutschen Nachrichten, dass 100.000 Schüler pro Jahr ohne Abschluss die Schulen verlassen. Das ist genau so ein Abfackeln von...
Der Partitätische hat ja genau davor gewarnt, also ich hab noch die Worte von Ulrich Schneider im Ohr, wo er sagte, wir haben ohnehin schon ein großes Problem mit Schulabbrechern, aber wir gehen davon schon jetzt fest aus, dass es Zehntausende mehr sein werden durch Corona, die einfach aus dem Raster gefallen sind, weil Homeschooling nicht funktioniert hat und er hat recht behalten.
Wenn wir uns über unsere Ressourcen, die wir in Deutschland haben, zum Zwecke der Wohlstandserhaltung verständigen und dann kommen solche Zahlen in die Nachrichten, das ist wirklich grotesk. Die Frage ist jetzt, warum ist das denn so? Könnte man da nicht irgendwas machen? Und stellt sich raus, ja, sie waren in einer Produktionsschule, so nennt das, wenn man mal nicht nur am Schreibtisch sitzt, um zu lernen.
Da sind 4 cm die Außenwände.
Ganz genau, wir müssen die Außenwände abziehen.
Plötzlich fällt Kevin das Rechnen gar nicht mehr so schwer.
Zu oft Schule macht meinen Kopf durcheinander und die Werkstatt macht meinen Kopf frei.
Andere probieren sich im Schnitzen aus.
Nur reiner Schulunterricht geht nicht. Das haben sie auch vorher auf den anderen Schulen nicht. Das haben sie ihren Abschluss nicht bekommen bei uns.
Denn hier in der Produktionsschule können sie sich ausprobieren. Die 21-jährige Cora versucht sich im Landschaftsgartenbau. Die Zahl der Schulabbrecher hat zugenommen. Warum, will ich von Ihnen wissen.
Kevin, da sind wir uns einig, das hat was mit Mobbing zu tun.
So, diese Schüler werden einfach gemobbt. Es scheitert nur daran, dass sie gemobbt werden. Man könnte ihnen auch einfach wohlwollend begegnen, und zwar flächendeckend, und dann sähe das schon ganz anders aus. Dann würde man nicht, als wenn das Kind schon in den Brunnen gefallen ist, feststellen, ach so, der braucht eine Werkstatt statt einen Schreibtisch. Dann geben wir ihm doch mal eine Werkstatt. Immerhin wollen wir ja auch, dass später Leute in Werkstätten arbeiten. Und die Frage ist ja wirklich, wer mobbt hier eigentlich in Deutschland? Und hier wird natürlich nur so gefühlig darüber gesprochen. Danach kann man ja nochmal die Verweise machen. Aber es ist wirklich die ganze Gesellschaft einfach.
Ich kam in eine Einschulung schon rein. Da fing es schon an mit Mobbing. Ich hatte früher auch mal so welche Gedanken gehabt, Selbstmord zu machen. Und ja, ich habe aber einfach weiter gemacht.
Auch Cora fühlte sich in ihrer Realschule immer wieder gemobbt und ausgegrenzt, weil ihre Eltern arbeitslos sind.
Die sind ja Kinder von Herz-Vier-Empfängern. Also das ist jetzt beispielsweise meine Erfahrung gewesen. Die kriegen ja so nichts auf die Kette.
Wenn wir das jetzt nochmal verbinden mit dem, was Ferda Atemann gehört hat, dann ist natürlich diese Klassismusgeschichte in einer Weise berechtigt. Das Problem ist nur, dass es, glaube ich, nicht dann um den eigentlichen Kern geht. Sondern, dass man mit Sprachregelungen versucht, was zu machen. Aber Mobbing, wissen wir ja, funktioniert auf einer ganz anderen Ebene. Also man könnte alle bösen Worte vermeiden und kann einen einfach durch Ignoranz mobben. Kann einen in den Wahnsinn treiben, ohne auch nur ein Schimpfwort zu sagen.
Ja, also wenn man in Atemanns Richtung hier weitergeht, dann kommt am Ende bei rum, ja wir sortieren dich nach der vierten Klasse aus, weil deine Eltern haben es leider nicht so was gebracht, du also auch nicht, aber wir sind wenigstens höflich dabei. Wir haben dich nie beschimpft, wir haben dich nur ignoriert. Wir haben dich hier nur geduldet, solange du da warst. Und das ist einfach genau der falsche Ansatz. Man muss übers Geld reden, wenn wir das Erwerbspotenzial mal so ein bisschen mobilisieren wollen. Und da kann man ja mal diese kleine politische Entscheidung auch außer im August hier, also sehr viel Tagespolitik, aber wir spontan historisieren sie sofort.
Also diese Diskriminierung, die einfach dadurch kommt. Und Diskriminierung ist ja auch ein Begriff aus der Volkswirtschaft, also dass man so Marktprozesse beschreibt. Diese Diskriminierung findet ja natürlich statt bei Menschen, die wenig Geld haben, dadurch, dass das permanent Ausschlüsse produziert. Also das ist ja gerade auch das Tolle an so einer Errungenschaft, auch wenn sie nur für drei Monate da war, wie dem 9-Euro-Ticket, dass das tatsächlich nicht diskriminiert ist. Und dann hat man sofort irgendwelche Journalisten im Fernsehen, die dann sagen, ja, das ist aber schlimm, dass da auch Reiche mitfahren können, weil man glaubt, man müsste jetzt da wieder neues Reclément schaffen. Aber es wird total ausgeblendet, dass fast alles mit so einer Diskriminierung von jenen einhergeht, die sich etwas nicht leisten können. Und das Problem für diese Leute ist nicht, dass dann wegen mir der Vermögende, aber Geizige sich auch noch in die Regionalbahnen setzt, wo man sagt, dann fahr doch erste Klasse verdammt nochmal. Sondern das Problem dieser Leute ist, dass sie sonst gar nicht fahren können, weil sie diskriminiert werden aufgrund der zu hohen Preise. Und die sitzen nicht in der Bahn und sagen, oh, ich hab ja gerade ein Gerechtigkeitsproblem, dass hier auch Leute mitfahren, die eigentlich sich eine teurere Karte leisten können. Das ist nicht deren Problem. Deswegen muss ich das nochmal ganz deutlich sagen, dass Diskriminierung vor allem über Preise läuft. Und das hat für die soziale Komponente einfach den Effekt, dass sich Menschen das nicht leisten können. Und das bedeutet auf der Kinder- und Jugendebene, wir hatten früher immer diese Debatten mit Markenklamotten oder so, das ist sicherlich stärker das Smartphone. Und bedeutet aber auch, gehen wir heute Abend oder heute Nachmittag noch weg in der Eisdiele oder was trinken. Und dann ist die Frage, wer kann mit und wer nicht. Und da beginnt die Diskriminierung, wer abends dann nicht dabei sein kann, ist der, der auch am nächsten Tag ausgeschlossen wird, ohne dass da Ferda Ataman ein böses Wort hört, sondern die reden nicht mit dem, weil er nicht dabei war.
Genau, und deswegen ist so wichtig das Thema Geselligkeit vom Geld, einfach mal zu entkoppeln und ernst zu nehmen, als würde man über Geld sprechen. Eine Sache, die wir vorhin hatten, die Alten und die Jungen, Altersdiskriminierung wie funktioniert, eine Altersdiskriminierungsgeschichte war ja auch immer so ein bisschen das Heranrücken an die Renten, ans Rentenalter. Und dann heißt es plötzlich, ja, wir müssen dich jetzt deiner Identität berauben. Das ist ja beschrieben im Buch, ist ja auch ein großes Thema. Man fällt aus dem Berufsleben raus und hat plötzlich nichts mehr. Vor allem ein Problem für Männer. Und jetzt versucht, also jetzt kann man das auch unter Geselligkeitsgesichtspunkten hier sehen. Man versucht so Brückenschläge.
Wer vorzeitig in Rente geht und sich etwas hinzuverdienen will, soll das künftig ohne Probleme tun können. Denn bisher gilt eine Grenze von maximal 6.300 Euro im Jahr. Ansonsten drohen Abzüge oder sogar der Wegfall des Rentenanspruchs. Auch bei der Rente ab 63. Eine Ausnahme von dieser Regelung gilt aktuell nur noch bis Ende des Jahres. Denn wegen der Corona-Pandemie hatte die Regierung die Hinzuverdienstgrenze befristet auf über 46.000 Euro angehoben, damit Frührentnerinnen und Rentner die Personalengpässe in der Pandemie ausgleichen können. Das soll nun dauerhaft möglich werden. Arbeitsminister Heil will die Hinzuverdienstgrenze für Frührentner ersatzlos streichen. Bei einer Erwerbsminderungsrente soll sie auf gut 17.000 Euro im Jahr erhöht werden. Beides soll das Bundeskabinett schon in Kürze beschließen. Der parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der FDP-Fraktion Johannes Vogel sprach in der FAZ von einem wichtigen Durchbruch. Wer nach dem Renteneintritt doch wieder mehr arbeiten wolle, der könne das künftig unbesorgt tun. Deutschland könne es sich nicht leisten, auf diese Menschen zu verzichten.
So, hier stellt man plötzlich fest, oh wir müssen ganz schön viel ändern. Und dann sagt man, du darfst nur 6.000 Euro hinzuverdienen, ansonsten rechnen wir es von der Rente ab, weil wir wollen ja ganz viel Geld. Die Frage ist ja, warum nehmt ihr das Geld ein, lieber Staat? Also warum nehmt ihr jemanden die Rente weg, nur weil er später mehr verdient? Ja, das machen wir nur, keine Ahnung, damit er es nicht hat. Das ist ja die einzige Antwort, damit er es nicht hat. Weil der Staat verwendet das Geld ja nicht plötzlich, der kann ja nicht plötzlich mehr machen, nur weil er auf eben irgendwie noch mal Rente genommen hat. Dann macht man diese Grenze auf 6.000 Euro.
Nach deren Logik schon. Da sagen die ja damit finanzierende Wiederkindergärten.
Genau, das wird dann im Bundestag so gesagt, ja damit haben wir jetzt das und das finanziert, refinanziert. So, dann stellt man während Corona fest, scheiße, wir brauchen ja die Alten, also lassen wir ihn mal 46.000 Euro. Und jetzt stellt man fest, ach, Demografie, scheiße, wir machen das mal ganz grenzlos. Es darf jetzt einfach jeder so viel dazu verdienen, wie er will. Und so eine Bewegung in finanzpolitischen Fragen wünscht man sich doch auch mal bei jungen Leuten.
Was das ein Kampf war, dass Kinder von Hartz-IV-Empfängern dazu verdienen können und nicht 85 Prozent abdrücken müssen, dann an den Start. Das sind ja wirklich Knebelbeträge. Es gibt ja dieses Wort Ertrosselungssteuer, das ist ja verboten. Und das war eigentlich schon Ertrosselungssteuer.
Du darfst als junger Mensch dein Leben nicht in die eigene Hand nehmen, solange deine Eltern arm sind. Egal wie innovativ du bist, egal wer dir eine Gelegenheit gibt, du musst alles abgeben. Darüber wurde dann gar nicht diskutiert. Ja, das ist dann einfach auch bei Behinderungen. Wenn du Behindertenförderung erhältst, 90 Prozent deiner Hizu-Verdienste musst du abgeben. Das ist immer noch nicht anders geregelt. Das ist so ein kleiner Subdiskurs, der noch irgendwie läuft. Aber es ist unendlich bescheuert.
Menschen mit Behinderung, die dann in den Werkstätten arbeiten, das ist ja auch eine Katastrophe, was da gezahlt wird. Also das sind ja ganz, ganz schlimme Löhne. Und ich also da, das ist also furchtbar.
Ja, man wünscht sich eine Grundsatzrede von Olaf Scholz. Allerdings in Suhl, der ältesten Stadt Deutschlands. Da kann man mal über solche Themen reden.
Suhl ist die älteste Stadt.
Und auch so ein bisschen die Provinzaufwärten. Ja, rangelt sich ein bisschen mit Hoyerswerda. Das war ja damals die kinderreichste Stadt im Osten, weil diese retortenmäßig aufgebaut wurde. Aber heute ist es Suhl. Das Durchschnittsalter liegt irgendwie zehn Jahre über dem bundesdeutschen Schnitt des Podcasts. Es ist irgendwo in der Nähe von Jena, aber ich war glaube ich noch nie in Suhl.
Vielleicht hören uns Menschen aus Suhl zu.
Weißt du, wer in Suhl seinen Wahlkreis hatte, weil er meinte, da habe ich bestimmt super geile Chancen? Hier der Dings, der ehemalige Fassungsschutzpräsident. Und dann hat er sehr amüsant...
Selbst da hat es nicht geklappt.
Es war super witzig, denn er ist nach Suhl gefahren, hat sich dort angemeldet im Einwohner-Meldeamt und hat dann so ein Bild gemacht von dem Schalter und meinte so, hier muss ich keine Schlange stehen wie in Berlin, da kriege ich sofort einen Termin. Ich dachte so, ja, das ist Suhl. Niemand geht nach Suhl. Klar kriegst du da sofort einen Termin, wenn du dich da einbürgern lässt. Alles wirklich bekloppt. Na gut, haben wir dieses kleine Suhl-Thema auch noch abgehakt. Ja, so viel zum Alter.
Nun sprechen wir über ein Ereignis im August, das nicht stattgefunden hat. Und wir hören uns dazu einen Clip aus der Nachrichtensendung Vion an.
Nach 940 Tagen könnte Xi Jinping aus China aussteigen. Er hat in Juli in Hongkong gehen müssen, aber das ist nur ein Vortrag.
Die Berichte sagen, dass Xi Jinping bis nach Saudi-Arabien reisen wird.
Er ist erwartet, nächste Woche zu kommen.
Warum ist das wichtig, diese Reise?
Wir haben euch bereits eine Grundlage gesagt. Sein erster Reise außerhalb der Mainland war im Juni. Er reiste in Hongkong, ohne dass er keine Städte besuchte in fast 940 Tagen. Eine andere Grundlage ist, dass Joe Biden letztes Monat da war.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob wir da eine Aufklärung in diesem Buch bekommen, was Auslandsreisende Autokraten angeht, weil das jedes Mal so mega thematisiert wird.
Nun ist es aber so, dass diese groß angekündigte Reise nicht stattgefunden hat. Und noch gerade eben habe ich gecheckt, ist Xi vielleicht jetzt in Saudi-Arabien? Da habe ich aber dann nur eine Meldung gefunden, vermutlich wird es nächste Woche sein. Also ob er tatsächlich dann nach Saudi-Arabien reist, ist nicht klar. Es gibt verschiedene Quellen, die sagen, es würde jetzt stattfinden. Es gab auch schon mal bei Business Insider oder im World Street Journal eine Quelle, die behauptete, im März würde er dahin reisen. Das hat dann nicht stattgefunden. Jedenfalls können wir sehen, es gibt offenbar eine Connection zwischen China und Saudi-Arabien, eine, die vielleicht auch ein bisschen intensiver wird. Und dem wollen wir also nachgehen und wollen aber erst mal noch ein bisschen hören, wie das dann eingeschätzt wurde, als angekündigt wurde. Es wird wohl diese Reise geben. Wir hören jetzt Phelm Klein von Politico, der bei CBS war.
Aber der zweite Grund, warum Xi in Saudi-Arabien will, ist, dass er gezwungen wird, er wird ihm die Kraft und die Influence zeigen.
Er wird die Radekarpett-Treatment in einer Weise, die Biden nicht wollte.
Da sind ja gleich zwei Sachen drin. Zum einen für die Bilder, das glaube ich, denn wir wissen, wie Trump da begrüßt wurde, als sie da auf dieser Kugel gebetet haben und der ganze Quatsch. Und dass man, nachdem man 140 Kohlekraftwerke baut, ich weiß nicht genau wie viele es sind, aber wahnsinnig viele, auch noch sich um Ölquellen kümmert. Das zeigt natürlich, in welche Richtung es da immer noch geht.
Ja, sehr richtig. Und wir haben diese Bilder von beiden vielleicht gar nicht so sehr vor Augen. Wir werden gleich so einen kurzen Clip spielen von dem, was wir da von beiden gehört haben. Wir haben auch gar nicht so viele Bilder von beiden, weil Biden nach Saudi-Arabien zwar ist aus Gründen der Energie, aber jetzt gerade nicht diese Red-Carpet-Geschichte machen wollte, denn da ist ja auch immer noch Khashoggi. Auch darauf kommen wir jetzt gleich nochmal zu sprechen. Man wollte also nicht unbedingt da gute Mine zum bösen Spiel machen, zumindest nicht zu sehr für die Medien. Wir hören jetzt noch einen kurzen Clip von ABC News Australia. Da war Graeme Smith zugeschaltet, der ist Politologe und hat eine These, warum Xi jetzt unbedingt nach Saudi-Arabien will.
Sie haben gerade die Leaders Retreat in Beidacher gefeiert, was das große Problem ist, dass sie zusammensteigen und das Ganze vor dem Parteikongress in November ansteigen.
Also, für ihn, den im Alltag zu gehen, mit diesem großen Kongress im November, ist es ein wirklich großer Deal.
Und warum Saudi-Arabien?
Man denkt schon fast an Safe Space. Das ist jetzt der Safe Space für die Autokraten. Man besucht sich untereinander. Da kann man auch nicht mit Protesten oder so rechnen. Das wird ja sowieso alles schon von Staatsseite unterbunden. Und Xi will wiedergewählt werden im November. In Beiderhu war man jetzt, hat ausgearbeitet, wie man sich aufstellen wird neu, wie die Partei und damit auch die Regierung ausgerichtet ist und das wird jetzt also seinen Lauf nehmen und dann kann man davon ausgehen, dass er wiedergewählt wird und er will jetzt auch zeigen, so die These von Smith, dass er in der Weltpolitik wieder zu Hause ist, nachdem er nie weg war mehr.
Diese Wiederwahl, ich dachte, der ist schon auf Lebenszeit ernannt.
Es gibt schon wohl diesen Proforma-Wiederwahl wird das sein.
Also es muss anberaumt werden.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, sonst war es befristet und jetzt muss es anberaumt werden. Ich weiß auch nicht genau den Prozess, vielleicht werden wir uns das im November nochmal ansehen. Wir hören uns jetzt erstmal etwas an von einem konservativen Think Tank, dem Hudson Institute in den USA. Da wird jetzt Bernard Haeckel, Professor von der Oststudien, über Biden und Saudi Arabien befragt und er antwortet Folgendes.
Das war sein eigenes Ziel, wie wir sagen. Er wurde zerstört und musste dann in Person gehen.
Und in so einem Fall verhämtete er den USA.
Im Fakt haben sie mehr als 100.000 Barrel Öl aufgeholt, in der aktuellsten OPEC-Plus-Sitzung.
Ich denke, Biden hat wahrscheinlich in der Wahl die Mittellinitiativen Ereignisse für ihn schlecht gehen.
Also wir erleben hier dieselbe These mit Xi, der muss gewählt werden, hat es natürlich noch ein bisschen leichter als Biden und will aber auch mit der Außenpolitik punkten. Ähnliches wird jetzt hier von Biden gesagt. Es hätte auch die Schwäche Amerikas noch mal demonstriert, dass man dann doch von diesem Öl abhängig ist und sagt, bitte, bitte, liebe Saudis, könnt ihr dann nicht mal mehr produzieren? Und da haben die ja dann auch ziemlich die kalte Schulter gezeigt. Wir werden uns gleich auch eine Bewertung an. Vielleicht noch ein Wort von Heike zur Strategie.
Aber was du in dieser Bewege hast, ist ein Lack langsamer Planungen, ein Lack strategischer Denkungen.
Und es ist alles taktisch.
Und die Saudis sind nicht interessiert in taktischen Bewegungen oder in der steigenden Produktion, um den amerikanischen Präsidenten die politischen Ansprüche zu helfen. Nämlich der Gefahr von Iran, der Gefahr von Iranens Proxys, wie die Houthis in Yemen, die Tausenden Missile und Drohnen, die auf sie geraten sind und die ihre Ölinstallationen aufbauen, sind wirkliche Sorgen.
Das sind wirkliche, konkrete Dinge.
Das ist wirklich so irre, weil Joe Biden ist ja auch nur unterwegs wegen Inflationspolitik. Du hast ja schon gesagt, der mitte auch 8 Prozent oder so. Und am Ende wird irgendwie in den Geschichtsbüchern stehen, richtig knapp war es nicht. Also das Gut Energie, sondern es war es waren so Marktmechanismen irgendwie, Entscheidungsprozesse und irgendwas. Und das ist so irre, diese Art der Weltpolitik. Auf der einen Seite so runtergedampft zu sehen auf, ist es jetzt ein Handschlag oder wird es nur ein Fistbump, weil Khishoggi und so, dann stellt sich irgendwie raus, ja alle müssen noch mal 1000 Podcasts dazu machen, also wirklich What's the Journal, New York Times, dass es nur ein Fistbump war und auch so kurz wie möglich. Dann findet das aber trotzdem alles in Saudi-Arabien statt und ist aber dann wiederum nur so eine Folgeerscheinung von, wir haben es nicht organisiert bekommen, Preise ordentlich zu gestalten. Und da hat ja Fratscher immer wieder darauf hingewiesen, Inflation, Inflation, ja klar, Inflation heißt für uns erstmal so, es wird teurer, aber es wird eben für sehr viele, auch sehr lukrativ, die dann Interesse haben, dass natürlich Preise sind, wie sie sind, wenn dann so eine 14-Fachung des Großmarkt-Strompreises und so weiter, dass man da keine politische Handhaber hat und irgendwie händeringend dann doch nicht dazu kommt, eine Übergewinnsteuer und sowas zu organisieren. Es ist so Hanebüchen und bei solchen Sachen endet es dann, das Xi in Saudi-Arabien und wir da so genau hingucken, weil dann da plötzlich so viel passiert, sich so fuzil kumuliert eigentlich.
Wir gehen nochmal später in diese Geschichte Saudi-Arabien-USA zurück, das ist ja doch eine ganz besondere. Also Saudi-Arabien wird ja de facto regiert von diesem Prinzen, Kronprinz Mohammed bin Salman Al Saud. Und der Internationale Währungsfonds prognostiziert ein Wirtschaftswachstum für Saudi-Arabien von 7, 6 Prozent. Und die Inflation liegt bei 2, 3 und die Prognose ist, dass das auch so bleiben wird. Und außerdem ist man natürlich auch sehr interessiert an der Belt and Road Initiative, also der Neuen Seidenstraßen. Es ist auch so, dass China ein großes Interesse hat, natürlich da an Energie dran zu kommen. Aber vielleicht, was ergibt sich dann noch eigentlich, zum Beispiel im Bezug auf Bauen. Wir hatten ja im Teaser kurz über The Line geredet und ich habe dann noch in einem Atemzug die chinesische Mauer um 20.000 Kilometer verkürzt. So war es natürlich nicht gemeint, also ich dachte, der begehbare Teaser. Nein, man kann ganz viel gehen und die chinesische Mauer ist über 20.000 Kilometer lang. Und wir sehen, dass The Line soll gebaut werden durch die Wüste mit Solar und alles. Also da versucht man sich eine neue Wirtschaft zu erschließen, da man nicht auf Dauer davon ausgeht, dass man mit Öl weiterhin reich sein kann. Also Öl ist ja jetzt momentan das Wichtigste und das ist das, was Saudi-Arabien und vor allem die Familie reich gemacht hat. Und das ist ja immer so eine heikle Angelegenheit, wie lange wird das mit dem Öl dann noch klappen, wenn wirklich so eine grüne Transformation kommt. Jetzt hat man nochmal so ein bisschen Zeit geschenkt bekommen, weil plötzlich alle doch wieder viel mehr am Öl interessiert sind. Aber das wird nicht auf Dauer so sein. Und was auch interessant ist, was in diesem Hudson Institute Talk gesagt wird, von Mohamed Khalid Alaya, der ist auch Experte für den Mittleren Osten. Und der sagt, Saudi-Arabien adaptiert auch einiges, was man aus Amerika kennt.
Es ist extrem tief, die Saudi-Arabische Beziehung, viel mehr so als du in der Kommentare in Washington oder im Medien liest. Saudi-Arabien hat ein System aus der USA-Technologie. Viele der Stadtplanungen in Saudi-Arabien sind aus der USA-Beziehung.
Al-Khobar ist aufgrund von Houston, Texas.
Die Ölinfrastruktur nutzt die USA-Technologie.
Und es gibt heute hunderts von Tausenden jungen Menschen, unter 30, die ihre höhere Bildung in den USA bekommen.
Nicht nur die anderen Hunderts von Tausenden Menschen der vorherigen Generation, die über 30, 40 oder 50 sind, die in die USA-Küste gegangen sind.
Der Prinz ist ja auch ein Millennial, kann man sagen. Und er ist ein Fan der Popkultur, der von Hollywood, von Disney. Und so ist es auch, dass man sich anders aufstellt. Man versucht ja auch im Ausland zu investieren. Wir hören hier mal Kristin Dievern bei Global Dispatches.
So they really need a lot of partners in making this transition and that means they want a lot of doors open in the United States, not just in Washington, but on Wall Street, Silicon Valley and in Hollywood, as well as they move into kind of more cultural fields. So they really want that acceptance and support.
And presumably that means in part an image rebrand and a rehabilitation. And you're seeing all of these attempts by the Saudi government, by MBS to do so through like investing in sports, like the live golf tournament or Newcastle United. But you're also saying they're making deeper plays into Hollywood and on Wall Street.
So jetzt haben wir schon gehört, Tourismus spielt eine wichtige Rolle, wenn wir bedenken, dass die Chinesen reisefreudig sind, beziehungsweise viele Chinesen erstmals die Möglichkeit haben, so viel Geld zu verdienen, dass sie auch mal eine Flugreise machen können. Und man dann in China hört, die Europäer sind gar nicht mehr so große Fans von uns und die mögen uns eigentlich gar nicht. Und das sind jetzt die Systemrevalen. Dann sucht man sich vielleicht auch neue Urlaubsorte. Und da könnte ja einer Saudi Arabien sein. Also ich glaube, dass man auch auf dieser Ebene über diese sich neu bildende Partnerschaft im Klaren sein soll. Jetzt gehen wir aber erst mal so einen Schritt zurück. Saudi Arabien und USA. Das ist vielleicht gar nicht so klar, wie eng diese Partnerschaft ist. Und das Wall Street Journal hat das mit Ryan Knutzen und Stephen Kellen mal ausgearbeitet. Wir hören jetzt nur mal einen etwas längeren Clip daraus.
President Franklin Roosevelt met the founding king of Saudi Arabia on a US warship actually just off the coast of the kingdom.
In cordial conversation with Colonel Eddy as interpreter, the Saudi Arabian king and American president discuss mutual problems of trade and relations with Saudi Arabia.
So that's really where this relationship begins. Its economy was expanding. Und für die Saudi war es ein ziemlich zügiges Land in ihrer Infanz, und das Wettbewerb, das sie aus Öl eröffnen, erlaubte ihnen, das Land zu bauen.
Das wiederholt sich ja gerade in der Ukraine so ein bisschen, die Amerikaner kommen und sagen, klar, geben wir euch Wereta-Unterstützung. Ihr müsst nur bei Amerikanern kaufen. Und das Gleiche gilt ja dann auch für den Wiederaufbau. Also jedes Mal, wenn der Kongress hier mal 10 Milliarden, da nochmal 30 Milliarden hinterher schießt, ist das genau so ein Verklickungsprogramm, wie wir es hier gerade gehört haben.
Ja, und diese Beziehung zwischen den Saudis und den Amerikanern ist, ihr gebt uns Energie, wir geben euch Sicherheit. Und diese Energie wird natürlich auch gut bezahlt. Also das ist dieser Ölkonzern Saudi Aramco. Und der macht gute Gewinne. Also da habe ich jetzt eine Zahl, hier im zweiten Quartal steigerte der weltgrößte Ölförderer das Nettoergebnis um 90 Prozent auf 48, 4 Milliarden Dollar. Für die ersten sechs Monate steht ein Gewinn von 87, 9 Milliarden Dollar. Das ist ein Thema in den Büchern. So ist es im Handelsblatt zu lesen gewesen. Und man muss dazu sagen, das ist nicht irgendein Konzern, sondern dem Staat, also das heißt dem Kronprinz und den seinen, gehören 98, 5 Prozent der Aktien. Die sind einfach dem Staat. Und man will aber tatsächlich auf Solaranlagen Windkraft setzen. Bis 35 sollen 12 Produktionskapazitäten errichtet werden, die dann 12 Gigawatt bringen. Und auch Erdgas ist ein großes Thema für diesen Konzern, also der sich da umstrukturiert, also der Staat strukturiert sich um. Und wenn man sich jetzt diese Partnerschaft mit den USA ansieht, dann muss noch was hinzugefügt werden. Das ist der Dollar. Also es ist ja auch die Frage, wenn man etwas exportiert oder importiert, wie wird es bezahlt? Und da gibt es ja nun diese Dollar-Hegemonie, die wir haben. Das ist die Weltleitwährung. Und das liegt auch ganz klar daran, dass die Energie darüber bezahlt wird. Und Saudi-Arabien hat sich 1974 verpflichtet, seinen Ölhandel nur noch in Dollar abzuwickeln. Und jetzt ist diese große Frage im Raum, könnte sich das verändern in den nächsten Jahren? Denn natürlich hat Peking auch ein Interesse, das in Wuhan abgerechnet wird. Oder wie ist es eigentlich mit den Russen? Die werden auch nicht so gut auf den Dollar zu sprechen sein. Und würde sich Saudi-Arabien tatsächlich darauf einlassen, damit wäre schon fast so ein Anfang vom Ende der Dollar-Hegemonie am Horizont. Also das ist jetzt wirklich noch Zukunftsmusik, aber davor hat man selbstverständlich Angst. Das ist auch immer etwas, wovor der Gideon Ruffman schon gewarnt hat, weil er sagte, ja, man muss ein bisschen schauen, wenn man solche Sanktionen macht, was ruft man eigentlich da so mit hervor? Er hat auch gesagt, dieses System, mit dem wir Überweisungen machen, über das wir alle diskutiert haben, Anfang des Krieges, sagt er, das gibt natürlich auch in gewisser Weise eine Neutralität, die wiederum sehr hilfreich sein kann, dass die nicht auf die Ideen kommen, sich eigene Bezahldienst zu machen, was ja dann passiert ist, auch schon vor Jahren passiert ist, als man das mit den Sanktionen gegen den Iran gesehen hat. Und nun stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, wird diese Dollarhegämonie auf Dauer bleiben können? Das Problem ist, dass Joe Biden nicht der richtige Mann unbedingt ist, um diese Verhältnisse oder bzw. die Wogen zu kletten. Das Voice of John geht hier mal auf den Bruch ein, den Biden da provoziert hat.
Also während der 2020-Kampagne hat Präsident Biden, oder Kandidat Biden damals, sich mit dieser Frage konfrontiert, wie man mit Saudi-Arabien handelt. Also in einigen Fällen hat Präsident Biden sich in Kontrast mit Präsident Trump befunden. Eine der Dinge, die er auf der Kampagentraile gesagt hat, die wirklich steckte, war, er nannte die Saudis ein Pariah-State.
Wir werden sie in der Wahrheit bezahlen und sie in der Wahrheit die Pariah machen, die sie sind.
Ja, der Paria-Staat, den man aber dann doch sehr braucht. Folglich, so wird es auch im Voice-Vision gesagt, sind die Saudis etwas enttäuscht über mangelnde Unterstützung.
Saudi-Arabien hat sich in einer Zivilwahl in Yemen beteiligt. Die Saudis bewegen die Regierung dort, die gegen einen Grupp von Rebellen, den Houthis, kämpfen. Und während der Trump-Administration war die US der Saudi-Arabischen Unterstützung. Aber Biden hat sich die Entscheidung aufgesucht. Biden hat die Houthis in Yemen als eine Terrorist-Organisation entdeckt, was Präsident Trump vor dem Ausgang gemacht hat. Er hat die Houthis einfach mit der Erinnerung geblieben, dass er nicht so auf den Mittellintern konzentriert war, dass er mehr auf China konzentrieren wollte.
Wir wissen, die führen da einen sehr blutigen Krieg. Und an sich ist es natürlich gut, dass man sich dazu in Distanz halten will. Das ist ja auch was, was Deutschland dann zu wenig gemacht hat. Aber es ist für die Saudis sieht es dann so aus, als sei der Westen gar nicht so sehr daran interessiert, wirklich noch diese Sicherheitsarchitektur zu bieten. Und naja, Joe Biden hat dann versucht, aber doch zu sagen, dass eigentlich noch alles super ist, als er jetzt kürzlich dort war.
Finde ich interessant. Ein deutscher Politiker würde ja nie die anderen Länder beim Namen nennen. Man würde dann so blumig damit andere Kräfte und so weiter. Dann hat er Saudi-Arabien, China, Russia und Iran genannt. Und gegen alle drei verlieren sie ja gerade flächendeckend. Das ist ja auch interessant, wie der Iran sich trotz dieser Sanktionen jetzt zu so einem Exporteur von Drohnen an Russland und so weiter wieder positioniert hat.
Zum Iran kommen wir gleich, denn es gibt ja noch was in diesem Monat. Gab es, dass man das Atomprogramm, noch mal ein Atomabkommen, noch mal neu diskutiert hat und da noch nicht zum Abschluss gekommen ist. Wir hören jetzt einen kurzen Clip von einem ganz interessanten Gespräch. Das kann man bei YouTube komplett sehen. An der Oxford University wurde das geführt mit Prinz Khalid bin Bandar als Saud. Der stammt auch aus dieser berühmten Saudi-Familie, ist der saudische Botschafter in UK, war vorher in Deutschland der Botschafter und stellt sich da eine Stunde den Fragen. Man kann dann auch mal hören, wie das ist, wenn er zu Yeguren befragt wird. Denn eigentlich müsste man doch eine muslimische Solidarität haben und dann kommt erst ganz lange nichts und seine Gesichtszüge entkleiden und dann gibt er eine sehr eigenartige zwei Minuten, drei Minuten lange Antwort. Das ersparen uns jetzt mal hier, wer sich dafür interessiert, kann sich das ansehen. Aber er sieht es auch so, dass man etwas vom Westen vernachlässigt wird.
Jetzt, dass die Zeiten schlecht sind auf unserer Seite und niemand mit uns steht, fühlt es sich ein wenig unfair an, aber das ist Leben. Wir haben Diskussionen mit den Russen, weil wir beide große Ölproduzenten-Nationen sind. Wir haben viel Konflikt mit den Russen, wenn es um Ölproduktionen geht und wie wir diesen Markt regulieren. Aber wir haben eine Diskussion mit ihnen, weil es Sinn macht. Wir haben viele Verbindungen mit China und mit den chinesischen Unternehmen, weil wir denken, dass es einen Vorteil für beide Seiten gibt. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass wir von unseren Freunden wegschwimmen.
Das kann man ja nochmal kurz, weil er gerade und das liegt natürlich nahe, Öl exportieren, allerdings Tourismusorte anbieten und am Ende kommen aber 300 Millionen Chinesen. So viel kann dann Saudi-Arabien auch gar nicht bieten. Das sollst du lieber mal beim Öl erstmal bleiben.
Zumindest müssen sie dann noch viel errichten, da wir hören jetzt erst einen kurzen Clip von Al-Jazeera, da sind Stephen Cook und Steve Clements, die die Reise von Biden bewerten. Also wir haben jetzt vor der Reise den Botschafter gehört, der sagt, nee, nee, es gibt da nicht einen Schiff, aber wir sind pragmatisch. Und jetzt wird mal geschaut, was hat denn Biden eigentlich mit nach Hause gebracht nach der Reise?
Ich meine, es ist erstaunlich in diesem Reise, dass Präsident Biden's Ziel, die Allianz gegen die russische Invasion aufzuwenden, nichts passiert hat, in Bezug auf das Aufwenden.
gab es die OPEC-Plus-Mitteile. Die Saudi sagten, sie würden 100.000 mehr Barrel Öl in der Fall einstellen.
Kurzum, sie haben die kalte Schulter gezeigt. Und das ist schon zu verspüren, wenn man dem saudischen Botschafter in Großbritannien zuhört. Der sagt es, wie er Außenpolitik oder wie Saudi-Arabien Außenpolitik begreift.
Wenn du die Geschichte der Saudi-Arabie und die Richtung der Politik und insbesondere in der Region siehst, sind wir sehr viel ein Land, das in der Non-Intervention in andere Menschenrechte glaubt.
Aber das ist unsere Identität. Also das ist auch eine identitätspolitische Argumentation, wenn man so möchte. Und wir erinnern uns ja an China, die auch immer sagen, wir machen keine Intervention. Also man kann ja jetzt auch bei Saudi Arabien sagen, naja, wir jeden intervenieren die da und nicht zu knapp. Und wir wollen das jetzt nicht alles aufdröseln. Das kann man ja sehr gut recherchiert nachlesen. Aber man sieht natürlich intervenieren die da. Aber was sie eigentlich damit signalisieren ist, ja, das mag sein, dass da Russland sich nicht korrekt verhält. Aber wir werden uns da jetzt nicht einmischen. Und genauso würden wir das bei China auch nicht machen. Und das ist so diese neue pragmatische Weltordnung, die da beschrieben wird. Also wir haben wirklich da so zwei Konstellationen. Einmal die Behauptung einer wertegeleiteten Außenpolitik, wo man dann immer eins hin prüfen kann, naja, sind da auch noch Werte. Also sprich Festung Europa ist eigentlich mit Werten ja nicht vereinbar. Und dann auf der anderen Seite haben wir aber welche, die gar nicht mit Werten kommen, sondern die sagen wir machen unsers, die machen unsers und dann können wir auf so einer pragmatischen Ebene zum Beispiel zusammen Handel treiben, ohne dass das irgendwelche Zugeständnisse abverlangt von dem Partner. Und es gibt noch eine sehr gute Parallele, die im Wall Street Journal benannt wird.
Was wir von den Saudis hören, ist, dass sie denken, dass die amerikanische Politik so unvorstellbar und so polarisiert ist, dass sie nicht wirklich sicher sein können, ob ihre nächste Administration sie zu sich vertreten oder sie zu sich hostile zu sein wird. Während mit einem Ort wie China, das einen Leader hat, der seit Jahren dort war, gibt es ein bisschen mehr Vorstellungen.
Das stimmt natürlich irgendwie, gerade in Amerika.
Ja eben, also da ist ein Trump, der sagt, ach, Mittlerer Osten und so interessiert mich ja eigentlich auch, wir lösen mal das Atomwaffenabkommen mit dem Iran einfach auf. Dann kommt der nächste und will es wieder machen und dann kann sein, dass der nächste sagt, das machen wir jetzt so und so wieder. Oder brauchen wir nicht, wir sind ja unabhängig und jetzt passiert was, dann ruft man wieder und das macht natürlich eine Beziehung nicht besser. Und dann kann man sagen, ja so Autokraten, die können sich dann einander an die Augen blicken und sagen, die nächsten 20 Jahre leben wir noch oder 50 Jahre, dann können wir noch lange zusammen arbeiten.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich kein per se Nachteil einer Demokratie. Man hat halt wirklich dieses amerikanische, im November wählen die einen Präsidenten, die wissen selber bis einen Tag vorher oder dann wirklich am Wahltermin nicht, erst wenn die Bundesstaaten ausgezählt sind. Und dann ist Transition für die ganze Welt. Nicht nur für den Apparat der Administration, sondern dann ist Transition für die ganze Welt. Und im Januar regiert er dann. Und es könnte eben, wer auch immer, bei den Demokraten oder Rick Santis und so. Da kann man sich wirklich nicht drauf einstellen.
China kauft mehr als 25 Prozent des Öls, das Saudi-Arabien exportiert. Das ist ja schon eine ganz enorme Summe. Und diese Verkäufe könnten wie gesagt ja auch in Yuan abgewickelt werden, wenn das gestattet wäre. Hier wird jetzt mal im nächsten Clip ein bisschen darüber spekuliert.
Es würde sich also an der Forderung des US-Dollar als Reservate ausbreiten. Das würde die Dollar-Dominanz verweigern. Das könnte in der langen Runde bedeuten, dass die Länder und die Menschen die Dollar nicht halten wollen. Das wird es verweigern und es wird es schwerer, für die amerikanische Regierung zu zahlen.
Androhung oder ist es schlecht, ist es gut?
Die chinesische Währung wird es gut für die Dollarwährung. Wird es schwierig dann? Also das würde sicherlich dem Dollar sehr viel Macht nehmen. Und daran hängt ja wiederum der Euro dran, was dann für uns schlecht wäre. Also wenn man jetzt wirklich nur in so geopolitischen Interessenkonstellationen denkt, dann wäre das glaube ich von unserer Seite nicht zu begrüßen, dass die Dollarhegomonie dadurch abgelöst wird, dass der Yuan gestärkt wird dadurch, dass die jetzt auch mit Energie mit der eigenen Währung handeln können.
Genau, dadurch, dass da immer eine Ablösung. Und dann wäre es das chinesische Geld, wo wir noch, ich meine, bei Amerika haben wir auch wenig zu sagen, wir imputieren halt die Kultur und so weiter. Aber am Ende machen die, was sie wollen. Scholz hat es ja auch nochmal betont, das ist das pazifische Zeitalter. Europa wird auch aus dem amerikanischen Fokus herausrücken. Am Ende sind wir dann wirklich so ein Spielball und wissen nicht so recht. Und am Ende ist nur Christian Lindner schuld, weil er Europa keiner eigenen Verschuldung zutraut. Und damit diese fundamentale Stärkung schickt seine Gemeinschaft Euro keinen Raum gibt.
Also den Amerikanern kann das eigentlich nur recht sein, wenn Christian Lindner das so weiter macht.
Das stimmt.
Also so Hardlinern, die dann sagen, die wollen mal ja nicht zu viel auf eigene Ideen kommen. Also das ist sehr, sehr praktisch, wenn das so weiterläuft. Wir hören einen kurzen Clip aus dem FAZ-Podcast Machtprobe. Da ist der Journalist, der für die Region zuständig ist, Christoph Erhard zu Gast.
China ist ein wichtiger Wirtschaftspartner für die ganze Region. Und China ist insofern ein angenehmer Wirtschaftspartner, als dass er eben keine Frage nach Menschenrechten steht. Da kann man Business machen. China ist aber kein Partner, der eben einem Land wie Saudi-Arabien eine Verbindlichkeit entgegenbringt, wie man sie sich zum Beispiel von den Amerikanern erhofft. Und China ist auch nicht der Partner, der Iran einhegt, anders als die Vereinigten Staaten.
Iran, das ist das Stichwort, über das wir sprechen müssen. Es gibt einen Vorschlag für ein neues Abkommen. Wir hören das gleich. Wir hören zunächst einmal schon eine Warnung vom Premierminister Israels von Lapid, der mit großer Sorge auf dieses neue Abkommen blickt.
Wenn ein Verbrechen beschlossen wird, dann ist es nicht Israel geblieben. Wir werden die Befehlung des Iranians von einem Nuklearen Staat verhindern. Die Gefahr von Iran endet nicht mit Nuklearen Waffen. Israeli Defense Minister Benny Gantz und National Security Advisor Eyal Chulat sind beide in Washington, die sich auf die Gefahr der Nutzung von Billionen Dollar in die uranische Wirtschaft und wo das Geld endet. Das sind 100 Millionen Dollar pro Jahr, die werden in der Mitte Osten verhindert werden und die Terror um die Welt verbreitet werden.
Die Sorge ist jetzt, wenn die Sanktionen dadurch aufgehoben würden, dann fließt wieder viel Geld in den Iran. Und was geschieht dann mit dem Geld? Da sagt Lapid, vermutlich werden damit eher keine Schulen gebaut werden. Zugleich kann man aber sagen, dass wieder Kommunikation stattfindet zwischen dem Westen. Also die EU ist da ja ganz stark involviert. Amerika und dem Iran ist erstmal ein gutes Zeichen, da man natürlich sonst irgendwann so eine Black Box Iran hat und gar nicht weiß, in welche, weil sich da eine Uran-Anreicherung und sowas entwickelt und wie das eskalieren kann. In der Deutschlandwälder wird das mal kurz zusammengefasst, was sich jetzt so im August getan hat.
Atomverhandlungen mit dem Iran, die hat es zuletzt 2015 gegeben. Doch ein Funken Hoffnung besteht, dass der internationale Nuklearpakt wieder aufgenommen werden könnte. Die EU hat Anfang August dem Iran einen Vertragsentwurf für ein neues Atomabkommen vorgeschlagen, auf den die Machthaber in Teheran jetzt geantwortet haben. Die EU und die USA prüfen den Vertragsentwurf.
Das kann sich jetzt noch lange hinziehen. Nun hören wir in der Deutschen Welle Azadeh Samiri Rat, die mal ein bisschen erklärt wird, wie weit sind die denn da eigentlich mit dem Atomprogramm?
Wir wissen, dass Irans Atomprogramm weitaus fortgeschrittener ist, als es beispielsweise noch vor dem Atomabkommen der Fall war. Iran reichert Uran ja mittlerweile auf bis zu 60 Prozent an. Das ist deutlich über dem, was das Abkommen eigentlich als Höchstgrenze vorsieht, nämlich 3, 67 Prozent. Iran nutzt deutlich mehr Zentrifugen als erlaubt sind. Iran reichert Uran mittlerweile auch in einer weiteren Anreicherungsanlage an, experimentiert mittlerweile auch mit fortschrittlichen Zentrifugen. Auch all das verstößt eigentlich gegen das Abkommen in seiner ursprünglichen Form.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile lässt auch der Druck des Arguments oder sagen wir mal so, dass sie Atomkraftwerke brauchen. Weißt du, es wird immer klarer, worum es eigentlich geht. Dadurch, dass Atomkraft so immer irrsinniger wird.
Wir hören noch mal weiter Samiri Erath, die sagt, was jetzt schon wirklich gemacht werden könnte.
Könnte der Iran quasi schon eine Atombombe bauen?
Nein, ganz so schnell geht das tatsächlich nicht. Hier muss man zwei Zeitschienen unterscheiden. Es gibt einmal die Zeitschiene der sogenannten Ausbruchszeit. Das ist die Zeit, die ein Staat benötigen würde, um genügend waffenfähiges Spaltmaterial für den Bau einer Bombe zu produzieren. Und diese Ausbruchszeit ist tatsächlich relativ gering mittlerweile, weil wir eben keine funktionierende Atomvereinbarung mehr haben. Diese Ausbruchszeit liegt hierbei etwa ein bis zwei Wochen. Das heißt, wenn Iran sich morgen entschließen sollte, eine Atombombe bauen zu wollen, dann bräuchten sie etwa ein bis zwei Wochen, um genügend Sprengstoff dafür zu produzieren. Sie könnten damit noch keine Atombombe bauen. Das würde noch weitere technische Schritte erfordern, die vermutlich so ein bis zwei Jahre benötigen.
Aber immerhin, die Fortschritte sind ganz enorm. Und da glaube ich, es muss ja irgendwas geschehen. Das ist ja ein Pulverfass, von dem reden wir ja schon ganz lange. Aber irgendwie hat man jetzt gerade mit dieser neuen Konstellation, mit diesen neuen Machtblöcken und wie schnell sich da alles verschiebt, die große Sorge und die ist glaube ich berechtigt, dass da nicht auch noch was explodiert. Und das könnte dann noch viel schwieriger vielleicht einzuhägen sein, als das, was wir jetzt schon gerade mit Rustand erleben müssen. Und da ist es natürlich gerade auch interessant, dass Saudi-Arabien so eine merkwürdige Rolle spielt. Denn Saudi-Arabien ist, oder nee, ich muss es anders sagen, China kann mit Saudi-Arabien so gut gerade, weil China am Iran als Land, als Partner, nicht so sehr interessiert ist. Und sich ja auch sowieso nicht in irgendeiner Verpflichtung sieht, da zu helfen, zu machen oder sonst was. Insofern ist das für Saudi-Arabien ein bisschen leichter, mit anzusehen, als wenn der Westen sich jetzt gerade sehr da engagiert und natürlich dann Zugeständnisse an den Iran macht. Also dieses Abkommen wird ja nicht so aussehen, dass Iran einfach sagt, ja, so machen wir es. Und das sieht Saudi-Arabien überhaupt nicht gern und sieht ja natürlich für sich das größte Konfliktpotenzial darin. Und will ja auch eigentlich, dass die anderen Länder lautstark auftreten und gegen dieses Abkommen in Erscheinung treten, bzw. eigentlich sind Saudi-Arabien und Israel in der Betrachtungsweise sehr ähnlich, was das Konfliktpotenzial des Iran anbelangt. Und wenn wir jetzt mal hören, warum eigentlich Iran Interesse daran hat, dass dieses Abkommen wieder aufgenommen wird oder ein neues in Gang gesetzt wird, dann ist das auch erstaunlich.
Es gibt ein Interesse in Teheran an einer Atomvereinbarung auf höchster politischer Ebene und das hat zahlreiche Gründe. Ein Grund liegt darin, dass die Alternative nicht sonderlich attraktiv ist. Wenn Sie sich ohne Atomvereinbarung die weiteren Monate anschauen, dann gibt es eine erhebliche Gefahr für eine militärische Eskalation. Der derzeitige Zustand des iranischen Atomprogramms ist nicht tragbar. Wenn wir nicht wissen, ob das iranische Atomprogramm rein zivilen Zwecken dient, weil wir gar nicht mehr die ausreichenden Kontrollmöglichkeiten haben, dann wird es sehr wahrscheinlich zu Militärschlägen kommen. Also die Eskalationsgefahr ist da.
Ja, Atomwaffen gelten ja immer als Abschreibungswaffen. Und jetzt dachte man ja irgendwie, ja so Atomkraftwerke vielleicht auch. Und jetzt sehen wir ja gerade in der Ukraine Saporizhzhzhzhja, das größte Atomkraftwerk Europas, dass das genau umgedreht gilt. Atomkraftwerke sind gerade nicht Abschreckungen, sondern da geht man gezielt hin, um dort zum einen Schutzschild zu haben, um selber nicht bombardiert zu werden und auch das Land sozusagen in den Griff zu disziplinieren. Wir sind jetzt hier, wir machen euch das Land kaputt, indem wir Atomkraftwerk zerstören. In der Hinsicht ist dieses ganze Unterfangen, was da gerade stattfindet im Iran, wirklich sehr bedenklich und ein Atomkraftwerk, selbst wenn sie jetzt diese zivile Schiene gehen und sagen, wir öffnen jetzt hier ein Atomkraftwerk, wäre das fast eine Einladung, da dann militärisch tätig zu werden am Vorbild Ukraine.
Also gerade diese Eskalation, vor der dann auch wiederum Iran Angst hat, also das ist eine ganz interessante Konstellation, dass die natürlich außen, die Länder drum herum, also Israel, Saudi, Arabien und so sagen, sie haben Angst, dass Iran eskaliert. Und natürlich hat aber Iran auch jetzt Angst, naja, wenn wir jetzt hier alles im Verborgenen machen, nicht, dass die das mal eskalieren, dass die präventiv da reingehen, also Nonsand und was, und darum geht es ja in einem Sinne. Wie ist dann die Herrschaft gesichert? Wenn da eine Invasion oder so ist, dann ist ja auch die Herrschaft dann plötzlich am Bröckeln. Und das ist vielleicht dann auch noch ein Punkt, der hinzukommt. Also Ayatollah Ali Khamenei ist Jahrgang 39. Also könnte zwar noch Kardinal werden, aber könnte nicht mehr wählen. Und er ist ja auch der Oberbefehlshaber der iranischen Streitkräfte. Und da denkt man wohl jetzt auch inzwischen laut darüber nach, dass es ja mal Nachfolger geben wird. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man so tut, als würde dieser Mann noch Jahrzehnte weitermachen. Und das macht die ganze Lage ja auch nicht unbedingt sicherer, wenn man auch noch so einen Machtwechsel hat und dann noch vielleicht eine äußere Bedrohung. Insofern versucht man da ein bisschen wieder unter den Rock zurückzukehren. Wir hören jetzt noch mal Al Jazeera, Steve Clemens und Stephen Cook, die über das Problem des Abkommens debattieren.
Ich meine, die Wahrheit sei gesagt, die Partien, die nicht auf dem Verhältnis lebten, waren die USA, nicht die Iranier. Wir alle wissen das.
Wir haben den Deal verletzt, den wir mit ihnen gemacht haben, nicht die Iranier.
Und also in diesem Fall, wie du das alles wieder zusammen in irgendeiner Weise zusammenkommst, die 2024 überleben wird und wer noch mehr kommt?
Wenn du mit den Saudi, den Emiratis, den Israelis, mit den Ägypten reden, sind sie sehr, sehr interessiert, ob die 180-Grad-Werke in der amerikanischen Fortschrittspolitik die JCPOA sind oder nicht die JCPOA sind.
Sind wir wichtig oder nicht wichtig?
Kontinuität hat die amerikanische Politik eigentlich doch immer sehr stark geliefert. Manche sagen auch, mit Obama hat schon ganz viel gebröckelt da. Obama hat sich auch nicht mehr dafür interessiert. Man könnte vielleicht festhalten, ja, seitdem die Amerikaner sich sehr auf China fokussieren, wird ein bisschen der mittlere Osten vergessen, beziehungsweise man hat ja dann auch viel Schaden in Irak und Afghanistan angerichtet. Er hat gesagt, oh Gott, wenn wir jetzt mit den Ländern uns da auch noch weiter involvieren, nicht dass wir da noch was produzieren. Und das sorgt aber eigentlich für eine unglaubliche Unruhe und ist für alle Länder, alle beteiligten Länder, hat es ja gerade aufgezählt, doch sehr schwierig, diese Konstellation. Und jetzt könnte man ja denken, okay, wenn das so ist und Amerika ist nicht so der verlässliche Partner, dann ist ja logisch, dass da jetzt China kommt. Aber wir wissen auch von China, Intervention ist nicht so die Sache. Expansion im Übrigen schon. Also ist jetzt nicht so, dass China einfach nur bei sich immer bleibt. Aber ist China wirklich in einer Weise ein Bündnispartner jetzt, dass man mit denen auch ein NATO-Bündnis oder sowas machen könnte? Und ich hab ja mir mal so chinesische Blockbuster angesehen, die sehr militaristisch sind. Aber es geht nie darum, dass man sagt, als Verbündete mit irgendeinem Land machen wir was, sondern das geht darum, dass man irgendwelche Chinesen aus prensigen Situationen, aus fremden Ländern rettet. Also es geht nicht darum, wirklich als gemeinsames Bündnis aufzutreten, wie wir das jetzt kennen, dass man sagt, die Franzosen, Deutsche und Amerikaner kämpfen zusammen oder machen irgendwas zusammen. Und Stephen Cook sagt eigentlich auch, ne das wird Chinas Strategie nicht sein.
Du bist hier in Washington, ich hier in Washington.
Ich sehe es nicht so sehr im Mittelfilz.
China ist ein wachsender Staat mit viel Ambition.
Aber die Mittelösterreicher wollen nicht die US-Position ausdrücken.
Man kann eigentlich festhalten, der Westen schafft eine recht teure Sicherheitsarchitektur. Und die Chinesen kommen wirklich als Touristen im weiteren Sinne und sagen, ach, das ist doch ganz gut hier. Praktisch, hier können wir noch Geschäfte machen, aber wir wollen nicht diese Sicherheitsarchitektur bezahlen. Von daher, wenn diese Reise jetzt stattfindet von Xi nach Saudi-Arabien, oder wir werden bestimmt viele weitere Meldungen zu diesen beiden Ländern in den nächsten Wochen, Monaten bekommen, dann sind wir präpariert.
Ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, das dann zu sehen, wie das aussieht. Muss ja die größte Show der Erde sein, wenn Xi in Saudi-Arabien aufschlägt. Da wird dann auch Trump nochmal neidisch und nur deswegen wird er nochmal Präsident werden. Dann mal sehen, wir bleiben so ein bisschen beim Thema Energie, aber gucken uns das hier ganz lokal an, denn es ist ja Zeitenwende in Deutschland. Wir brauchen neue Energiequellen und ich wusste gar nicht, dass wir mit diesem Flüssiggas bisher noch gar nichts zu tun hatten.
Zum Jahreswechsel soll erstmals Flüssigerdgas in Deutschland ankommen und damit beginnen weitere Nachrichten mit Judith Rackers.
Das erste Mal überhaupt, deswegen auch dieses ganze improvisierte, also es ist eine neue Technologie für Deutschland, dass man dieses Gas flüssig anlanden lässt und dann muss man es erst mal ummodeln. Hat natürlich hier mit zu tun.
Vom 31. August bis 2.
September werde durch die Pipeline Nord Stream 1 kein Gas in Richtung Deutschland strömen, teilte Gasprom mit.
Als Grund nennt der Konzern Wartungsarbeiten an einer Turbine.
Danach werde, wie schon seit Juni, weiterhin nur ein Fünftel der maximal möglichen Gasmenge nach Deutschland kommen. Auch das erklärt Gasprom mit technischen Gründen. Erwesten wirft Russland Erpressung vor.
So und jetzt, es geht drunter und drüber, was das angeht. Also das erste Mal Flüssiggas überhaupt. Wir haben aber noch keine Terminals, weil bisher war ja Nord Stream 2 geplant. Die Amerikaner haben ja mit Sanktionen gedroht, weil sie ja ihre Flüssiggas Terminals und so weiter promoten wollten, die wir bislang aber abgelehnt haben. Jetzt plötzlich brauchen wir sie, stellen dann fest. Ah ja, es gibt ja noch die Diskussion, die Claudia Kemfert immer macht. Die hat ja auch bei Instagram mit so ein paar Videos gemacht, wie sie vor Ort war, vor diesen schwimmenden Terminals. Weil die zum einen nur temporär sind und zum zweiten eben flexibel. Die nehmen eben flüssiges Gas entgegen. Das kann aber auch aus Hydrolyse entstandenes Grünes, nämlich einfach abgespaltenes Wasser, Wasserstoff aus, nachdem es mit grüner Energie einfach gespalten wurde, sein. Das wiederum müsste dann ein Fokus auf Namibia legen. Und das sind alles Tagesthemen-Clips.
Aber in Namibia entsteht momentan ein Megaprojekt für grüne Energie, auf das wir dringend schauen müssen, weil es auch für unsere aktuelle Energiekrise möglicherweise Besserungen verspricht. Denn im südafrikanischen Land entsteht ein gigantischer Wind- und Solarpark. Der dort produzierte Wasserstoff soll teilweise auch Deutschland zugutekommen. Viel Wind, viel Sonne und vor allem viel Platz. Perfektere Bedingungen gibt es nur an wenigen Orten in der Welt.
Ja, das ist natürlich dieses Soll auch Deutschland zugutekommen. Ja, da bräuchte man aber so eine Partnerschaft im Sinne, wie sie Adam Tusken vorgeschlagen hat. Jedes Land nimmt sich ein Partnerland und dann guckt man da mal. Oder man macht ernsthafte Reisen und versucht da nicht nur Ausbeuterei vor den Küsten zu machen, indem man doch wieder Bohrinseln usw. Stattdessen wird die deutsche Diskussion gar nicht auf Fokus Afrika gelenkt, außer hier in diesem kurzen Namibia-Stück. Im Heute-Journal war Manuela Schwesig, die ja nun diese großen Vereine da, diesen Nord Stream 2 Rettungs- alles für die Klima- und Umweltschutzverein.
Übergangsstrategie und so.
Genau, ihre Stiftung. Sie wird gefragt, was denn jetzt mit Nord Stream 2 ist.
Jetzt gibt es ja die Forderung von FDP-Vizechef Kubicki, Nord Stream 2 zu genehmigen, damit mehr Gas fließen kann. Sie kennen sich ja ein bisschen mit Pipelines aus. Ist das eine gute Idee?
Diese Frage stellt sich nicht.
Die hat die Bundesregierung klar beantwortet.
So, diese Frage stellt sich nicht. Die Bundesregierung hat die Frage beantwortet. Ich nicht. Ich würde natürlich sofort Nord Stream 2 aufmachen. Ein anderer, der das fordert.
Das kann sie allerdings jetzt nicht sagen. Wenn sie das sagen würde, dann ist auch gleich Feierabend. Also Kubicki hat ja Narrenfreiheit. Der kann es natürlich machen.
Wir hören uns das nochmal kurz an, wie das hier im Deutschlandfunk, die dann ja eine Presseshow machen und so weiter. Wir drehen jetzt gleich dreifach über Bande, wie das in der Presse so widerhalt fand.
Angesichts der hohen Energiepreise plädiert der FDP-Politiker Kubicki dafür, die neue Gaspipeline Nord Stream 2 in Betrieb zu nehmen, um mehr russisches Gas nach Deutschland zu importieren. Dazu schreibt die Frankfurter Allgemeine Zeitung, in der Tat hätte Kremelsprecher Peskov die Behauptungen, mit denen der stellvertretende FDP-Vorsitzende und Bundestagsvizepräsident hantiert, nicht schöner vortragen können.
Ja, der Bundestagsvizepräsident als Kremel-Pressesprecher, das ist natürlich passt gut. Ernsthafterweise gibt es aber doch den Versuch, jetzt mal ein bisschen Ordnung reinzubringen, nämlich hiermit.
Wie wichtig der Bundesregierung dieser Besuch ist, zeigt sich schon an den Formalien. Kanzler und Vizekanzlerreisen an, für ungewöhnlich lange drei Tage. Mit dabei rund ein Dutzend hochrangiger Spitzenmanager wie die Chefs von Volkswagen und Bayer, die politische Mission Deutschlands Energiezukunft sichern. Die Begrüßung, herzlich. Danke, dass du hier bist, Olaf. Olaf ist eine progressive Stimme, die in der Welt extrem wichtig ist. Und ihn hier in Kanada begrüßen zu dürfen, ist eine große Ehre.
Also wir haben es gehört, Kanada, Trudeau begrüßt ihn auf französisch, warum auch immer. Klar, weil die da französisch sprechen, aber man hätte doch erwartet, dass man dann doch das Englisch nicht...
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also das hat mir mal eine Dolmetscherin erzählt, wie viel gereichtes mit Politikern. Das Schlimmste sei, wenn Politiker auf die Idee kommen, nicht in der eigenen Sprache zu sprechen. Dann werden die dritten Weltkriege ausgelöst usw. Die sollen ja in der eigenen Sprache bleiben.
Na gut, wahrscheinlich sind sie auch da in dem französisch-sparigen Gebiet, wo auch immer weit im Norden. Und nicht nur war es eine besonders lange Reise, sondern es war auch das erste Mal ein deutscher Regierungschef in Kanada, ohne es zu verkoppeln mit einer US-Reise. Und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt auch ganz schön interessant, dass man hier Joe Biden wieder aus dem Spiel genommen hat oder eben Trudeau mal so richtig reingenommen hat ins Bild. Es ist jedenfalls Zeitenwende. Also die im Reuterschanal Theo Koll war da ganz eindeutig.
Also geht es ja doch auch um langfristige Perspektiven und um ein politisches Signal, oder?
Absolut. Und das haben die beiden heute sehr deutlich gemacht, auch beispielsweise mit Blick auf die Ukraine. Sie haben gesagt, dass sie die Ukraine massiv unterstützen werden, auch so lange wie nötig. Das hat vor allem Trudeau sehr deutlich betont. Sie haben noch mal den Fall der Turbine klar gemacht. Trudeau war ja hier im Land sehr stark in die Kritik geraten, weil er trotz der Sanktionen die Turbine ausgeliefert hat. Der Kanzler hat sich dafür ganz besonders bedankt. Beide haben klar gemacht, das haben sie bewusst getan, um Putins Bluff im Grunde offen zu legen, dass es nichts mit dieser Turbine zu tun hat, dass Russland weniger Gas liefert. Ich finde insgesamt an diesem Besuch hochinteressant, dass Kanada im Grunde fast wie ein Beispiel ist für die Zeit nach der Zeitenwende. Also die Energiewirtschaft stellt sich ganz neu auf. Es werden langfristige Entscheidungen getroffen für grünen Wasserstoff. Der Kanzler meinte heute auch noch mal, der Schalter ist im Grunde jetzt umgelegt. Das wird ein ganz großer Teil unserer Energiewirtschaft sein, grüner Wasserstoff. Da ist Kanada natürlich ganz entscheidend. Neufundland, wo der Kanzler morgen hinfliegt, hat da riesige Ressourcen und wir werden am Ende davon auch profitieren.
Ich finde, das ist alles so Verlegenheit und auch ein bisschen Quatsch, denn Kanada ist ganz schön weit weg. Wenn Entfernung hier keine Rolle spielte, dann müssten wir uns wirklich Sorgen machen, dass Russland demnächst Peking versorgt, obwohl 7000 Kilometer zwischen Moskau und Peking liegen. Jetzt plötzlich eine Energiepartnerschaft mit Kanada. Die Schiffe müssen sehr weit fahren. Dieses Flüssiggas muss sehr lange gekühlt werden. Das macht irgendwie alles ganz wenig Sinn, dafür, dass wir Nordafrika direkt vor der Haustür haben. Also das Mittelmeer ist kurz. Marokko, ja, da gibt es jetzt diese neue Partnerschaft. Dann hat man das wieder hingebogen. Das mit der Westsahara ist gar nicht so schlimm. Das ignorieren wir einfach mal weiter. Aber diese Kanada-Reise, das scheint mir doch so ein Show-Ding zu sein. Was allerdings medial, auch von Tina Hassel hier, groß gespielt wurde.
Der Kanzler selber hatte heute davon gesprochen, dass die Zeitenwende damit eben auch in einer klimaneutralen Wirtschaft ankommen soll. Kanada sei das Element, sei der Partner, um Deutschland zu helfen, loszukommen von russischem Gas und russischer Energie. Man muss sagen, ganz schnell hilft es nicht. In diesem Sommer, auch im nächsten, wird da nichts passieren. Aber das legt jetzt eben die Weichen und stellt die Weichen für einen großen Deal ab 2025. Nämlich dann wirklich im ganz großen Stil der Plan, Wasserstoff nach Deutschland zu bekommen.
Aber wie ökologisch ist denn das noch, wenn das euch eine Reise beinhaltet? Wie viel bringt das denn wirklich? Also haben wir es da wirklich jetzt mit etwas Ökologischem zu tun?
Also soweit ich und wir sind ja hier, es hören ja Ingenieure zu, die uns dann immer wieder E-Mails schreiben, dass wir das alles zu oberflässig betrachten. Aber soweit ich weiß, ist diese Art der Hydrolyse, man nimmt Windkraft und macht daraus, spaltet Wasser, schon sehr energiezehrend. Also da bleibt wenig Ertrag übrig im Sinne von grünem Wasserstoff. Den da nochmal transportfähig runter zu kühlen auf dieses verflüssigte LNG, ja das nimmt eben so 200 Faktor Volumen, also es macht es wirklich super kompakt, aber auch das ist super energiezerrend. Also bleibt nochmal weniger übrig. Dann muss das ja hier angelande wieder zurückverwandelt werden, bis es dann, was weiß ich, irgendwie durch eine Pipeline, die wir auch noch nicht haben, in Süddeutschland ankommt und Audi und BMW dann damit irgendwie Autos bauen. Frank Rieger hat letztens in seinem Alternativlos-Podcast mal verglichen seine Batterie in seinem Fahrrad. Der fährt irgendwie so ein komisches Fahrrad. Er meinte, der Akku ist so groß wie eine halbe Bierkiste. Also wir können uns alle vorstellen, das ist ein großer Akku. Und der bringt in der Energiedichte am Ende so viel wie 2 CL Benzin. Also so ein kleines Schnapsgläschen Benzin. Und da sieht man, das ist schon eine Umstellung. Das ist schon eine Zeitenwende. Da muss man schon in größeren Dimensionen denken, in mehr Schiffen, als wenn man jetzt normales Öl aus Saudi-Arabien kurz rüber fährt, sondern da steckt schon was dahinter.
Ich glaube, man kann damit loskommen von russischer Energie. Das ist ja das eine nur, dass diese Erzählung, dass das immer gleich mit dem Klimawandel gekoppelt wird. Und zugleich haben wir ja schon lauter Abkommen geschlossen, wo wir Öl und alles Mögliche bekommen. Also diese Erzählung glaube ich nicht. Also ich glaube, bis zu dem einen Schritt, dass man sagt, gut, man bemüht sich da von russischer Energie schnell loszukommen und das wird auch entsprechend Geld kosten, wie man jetzt sieht. Aber ich glaube nicht der Erzählung, dass damit dann die grüne Wende stattfindet, sondern sollte sich auf diesem Weg auch noch das eine oder andere an grüner Transformation ergeben, dann machen wir das auch mit. Aber ich sehe jetzt gerade nicht die Zeitenwende hin zu grünen Energie. Und ich würde dann ja sogar noch ohne, ich hoffe, ich werde jetzt nicht missverstanden, aber ich würde ja sogar noch einem Kubicki dann zugutehalten, dass er wenigstens keine Augenwischerei betreibt und sagt, ja, das ist jetzt alles irgendwie verdammt teuer. Jetzt sollen die man noch Nord Stream 2 machen, dann sinken auch die Preise wieder. Also das ist ja dann so, wenn das so wäre. Ich meine, es könnte ja durch diese Pipeline, die jetzt da sind, da ist Russland mehr liefern. Putin ärgert uns jetzt auch, weil wir ihn ja auch ärgern. Also das ist jetzt das Spiel, das gespielt wird. Wenn man jetzt Nord Stream 2 eröffnen würde, würde man natürlich Putin ein unglaubliches Zugeständnis machen. Und damit, es geht hier nicht, glaube ich, um diese Sache. Dann hat er so und so viele Milliarden mehr für seinen Krieg. Putin hat sehr viele Milliarden jetzt gerade, weil die Energiepreise so hoch sind. Deswegen kann er super verdienen. Aber es geht mehr darum, dass man sagt, gut, dann fängt man jetzt hier eine Partnerschaft an, während er zugleich in ein Land einmarschiert ist. Und das ist die Konstellation. Aber ich glaube, damit kommen wir eigentlich zu den Preisen, die so absurd sind, die dann ja nicht mehr mit realen Knappheiten zusammenhängen.
Na ja, meine Vermutung, ich hab's auch schon mal im Fernsehpodcast Scholz angedeutet, es war eigentlich so, man stellt fest, ja, wir leiten darunter, dass wir zu wenig Gas aus Russland kriegen. Also beißen wir in den sauren Apfel, machen das mit Nord Stream 2, dann rauscht eine riesige Kommentarwelle über Deutschland hinweg. Ganz Twitter ist voll mit Häme und so weiter. Gleichzeitig schreiben aber die ganzen CEO's an Olaf Scholz. Dankes, SMSen.
Genau, so würde es laufen.
Die Gesichtsverlust hingenommen hat, aber Hauptsache russisches Gas.
Aber bis lang würde es definitiv laufen. Nee, es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein. Ich glaube auch, dass da die Bündnispartner richtig uns auf Dach steigen würden. Aber deine Progrose ist vollkommen richtig. Da würde sofort jeder sagen, naja, das ist Realpolitik, dass man das gemacht hat. Und das wäre der Shitstorm, der eine Woche laufen würde. Aber ich erinnere ja gern daran, wie wir dürfen die Menschen in Afghanistan nie vergessen. Und während man es ausspricht, ist es schon geschehen.
Genau. Was wir ja eigentlich tun wollen, ist Leitabwenden im Sinne von zu hohe Energiepreise. Das bedeutet Schrumpfungen auf allen Ebenen, vor allem in den privaten Haushalten. Denn da wird dann weniger konsumiert, man ist arm. Die Dimension der Armut, die wir hier plötzlich feststellen, ist schon verrückt, das muss man wirklich sagen. Wir hören hier am Deutschlandfunk mal, was die Sparkassen dazu eingeschätzt haben.
Die Neue aus der Brücker Zeitung beobachtet, es hagelt Hiaps Botschaften. 60% der Deutschen werden wegen der Preisexplosion und Energienot finanziell nur schwer über die Runden kommen, warnen die Sparkassen. Bislang waren es 15%. Wirtschaftsforscher sagen einen permanenten Wohlstandsverlust voraus. Doch was macht die Ampel, die verspricht seit Monaten Entlastung, ohne das Versprechen überzeugend einzulösen.
60% der Haushalte, das heißt ja, nicht nur haben Rot-Grün damals angefangen, russisches Gas zu kaufen, weil Schröder sich mit Putin gut verstand, sondern damals ging ja auch die Erfindung der Armut in Deutschland los, im Sinne des größten Minijobsektors und so weiter. Und jetzt könnte man ja auch wieder sagen, Putin erpresst uns mit unserer Armut. Wären wir nicht so arm, also würden nicht so viele Familien und Haushalte kurz über der Schwelle aus der Hand in den Mund leben, hätten wir da eine gewisse ökonomische Resilienz, wäre das ja alles ganz anders. Nur jetzt nutzt Putin auch noch unsere eigene Armut als Waffe, die uns Agenda 2010 und so weiter damals eingeborgt haben. Also rot-grün, genau die, die jetzt auch wieder regieren und die Suppe auslöffeln müssen. Man muss sogar sagen, der Bundespräsident gerade war damals Kanzleramtschef und hat das sozusagen forciert. Also da schließt sich auch wieder so ein Kreis irgendwie, dass er jetzt Linderungen über Semantik, er fängt jetzt irgendwie an in seinen Sommer-Interviews und so weiter so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, noch launige Worte dazu zu finden. Auf der anderen Seite blockieren wir uns ja.
Ich will das nochmal gerade, das war jetzt das Kampf von der Sparkasse. Also wir sind jetzt, wir müssen uns mal dieser Dimension klar werden. Wer warnt jetzt hier vor Armut? Es ist die Sparkassen. Also der Sparkassenpräsident war das ja, Helmut Schleweis, der ganz klar gesagt hat, das sieht finster aus für unglaublich viele Haushalte, sodass im Finanzteil, in der Kommentarspalte bei der FAZ, man schon so sagt, ja, was ist da los? Das klingt irgendwie, das klingt ja wie von der Linkspartei oder so. Man war schon etwas irritiert. Und naja, der hat natürlich auch ein Interesse daran, dass Menschen zum Beispiel auch noch ihre Sparverträge, also ihre private Altersvorsorge weiter betreiben können. Und auch da gibt es ja inzwischen schon erste Zahlen, dass das nachlässt, dass die die erst einmal unterbrechen, weil sie sagen, naja gut, die 100 oder 200 Euro, die ich im Monat für die Altersvorsorge mir immer per ETF sparen oder so zurechtgelegt habe, die sind nicht mehr da, diese 200 Euro, und die brauche ich für die Energie. Und dann werden diese Verträge unterbrochen. Aber es ist schon eine absurde Zeit, dass wir jetzt schon den Sparkassenpräsidenten hören, der sagt, Achtung, da kommt eine große Armut auf uns zu.
Ich würde ja unterstellen, dass wenn es die Sparkassen ausrechnen können, die Bundesregierung das auch kann, aber uns hier nicht versorgte mit entsprechendem Wissen, sondern lieber versucht irgendwie zu handeln, dass man um die Thematisierung dessen drum rumkommt. Allerdings haben wir ein bisschen Pech mit unserem Finanzminister. Wir hören hier eine Wortspende.
Die Regierung arbeitet fieberhaft an einem weiteren Entlastungspaket, doch der Finanzminister bleibt dabei.
Wir müssen es innerhalb der Grenzen der Schuldenbremse und ohne Steuererhöhungen finanzieren, weil wir Inflation bekämpfen müssen und die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung stabilisiert werden muss.
Vater Dur des Kreises?
Ja, ich habe nie behauptet, dass der Job des Finanzministers jetzt ein bequemer Spaziergang ist.
Kein leichter Gang für den Kanzler Bürgerna und trotzdem abgeschottet. Denn in seiner Ampelrumore des Hinter-den-Kulissen wird heftig gestritten, Ausgang offen.
Die Preise steigen, so viel ist klar.
So viel ist klar. Also Christian Lindner will hier für keine Abhilfe sorgen. Was er ja meint mit Schuldenbremse bleibt, Steuererhöhungen sind ausgeschlossen. Es muss intern umverteilt werden. Das ist ja schon ein erheblicher Teil des Arbeitsministeriums Domäne, nämlich die ganze Sozialpolitik zu organisieren. Da ist also gar kein Sparpotenzial vorhanden, außer man nimmt noch mehr Armut in Kauf. Also es ist eigentlich wirklich eine Quadratur des Kreises. Und man kam auch in den Abendnachrichten nicht umhin, so ein Massenarbeitsproblem, Armut als neues Massenproblem in Deutschland plötzlich zu sehen.
Vor massiven Problemen, vor viel mehr Armut in Deutschland warnen Verbände etwa Verbraucherschützer. Immer mehr kostet das ganz normale Leben. Einkauf, Strom, Heizen, Sprit, besonders dramatisch für die, die besonders wenig verdienen und keine Rücklagen haben.
Ja, und dann fand ich besonders amüsant, dass wir Manuela Schwesig, eben schon gehört, hier als Gesprächspartnerin haben, die von der SPD sowohl Hardcore, russische Abhängigkeit vertiefen, als auch Agenda 2010-Politik im Geschichtsbuch stehen haben. Und mit ihr wird dann über das Entlastungspaket gesprochen.
Und uns live zugeschaltet ist jetzt die Ministerpräsidentin von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Manuela Schwesig von der SPD. Guten Abend, Max Schwirin.
Guten Abend, Frau Gerlinik.
Frau Schwesig, wir haben gerade die Sorgen von Menschen gesehen, denen die ersten Rechnungen ins Haus geflattert sind. Gleichzeitig leistet sich die Regierungskoalition den Luxus, den ganzen Sommer über die Entlastungen munter zu streiten. Wann wird Olaf Scholz eigentlich seine Richtlinienkompetenz benutzen und sagen, wie das dritte Entlastungspaket aussehen soll?
Das ist ja schön, dass du uns die Antwort ersparst auf diese Frage.
Was erwartet man schon. Man wird sich kümmern und so. Jetzt sind wir hier also in so einer europäischen Falle. Denn aus dieser Armut heraus soll uns eine Gasumlage führen. Nicht nur kostet Gas schon viel, sondern wir machen auch mal einen künstlichen Obolus oben drauf, damit was übrig bleibt, um dann die Unternehmen, die mit dem schon zu hohen Gaspreis zu wenig verdienen, nochmal zusätzlich Geld zu geben. Einfach an Uniper, die komplett pleite sind, aber immer noch am Markt tätig sind, obwohl das längst der Staat ist, der einfach das Öl aus Russland kauft. Das könnte genauso gut einfach die Bundesregierung selber machen.
Genau, das könnte man wie in China eigentlich handhaben. Oder in Saudi-Arabien oder so. Genau, man müsste das jetzt gar nicht mehr darüber spielen.
Genau, und dann gab es ja zuerst Verirrung darüber, weil plötzlich Umsatzsteuer erlassen werden sollte. Dann die EU kam, meinte, ne, das geht nicht. Ihr müsst Umsatzsteuer darauf erheben, sonst gäbe es wieder irgendwelche Fairness-Unfairness-Nachteile mit Europa. Und während Olaf Scholz dann in Prag seine große Wir machen neues Europa und so weiter Rede hält, muss er gleichzeitig tagespolitisch im Fernsehen erklären, dass man das kleine Umsatzsteuerproblem auf die Gasumlage schon irgendwie klärt mit Europa.
Die Notwendigkeit, bei der Gasumlage nachzuarbeiten, sieht auch Bundeskanzler Scholz und kündigt am Nachmittag Gespräche mit der EU an.
Sie wird mit uns über einen reden, wie wir das Geld den Bürgern wieder zurückkommen lassen können. Und diesen Weg werden wir jetzt ganz schnell mit der Kommission besprechen. Dann ist er auch rechtssicher und kann umgesetzt werden, noch bevor die Umlage erhoben wird.
Die EU nutzt das also ihrerseits, um einfach Steuerdebatten anzuregen?
Also mein Eindruck war, dass die EU-Kommission vor allem verhindern will, dass es so einen Flickenteppich aus Steuerregularien und Steuersätzen in Europa geben soll. Daher zum Teil heute auch die Absage an die Forderung an Christian Lindner. Das bedeutet aber nicht, dass die Bundesregierung jetzt nichts tun kann, um die Menschen zu entlasten. Darauf hat Paolo Gentiloni, der zuständige Kommissar, seinerseits auch in einem Brief auch hingewiesen. Er hat gesagt, es gibt natürlich Ausnahmen im EU-Recht beispielsweise bei den Energiesteuern. Man könnte zum Beispiel die Mehrwertsteuer auf Erdgas, auf Fernwärme oder auch auf Strom auf 5 Prozent senken. Das geht jetzt schon. Also das ist nicht das, was Christian Lindner möchte. Der möchte ja gar keine Steuer erheben. Aber man kann auch argumentieren, dass diese 5 Prozent weniger sind als die 19 Prozent, die jetzt auf diese Gasumlage fällig werden. Insofern wäre das ein möglicher, notwendiger Schritt. Aber ein anderer Schritt, da müsste die Bundesregierung auch gar nicht groß um Erlaubnis bitten, wäre natürlich in Deutschland die generelle Senkung der Mehrwertsteuer. Auch das wird jetzt gerade diskutiert. Ich denke, dass es in der Debatte zwischen der EU-Kommission und Berlin auch darum gehen wird, hier bestimmte Wege aufzuzeigen, die es in der Gesetzgebung schon gibt, die man aber in Berlin vielleicht noch nicht so sieht.
Die Berliner Regierung ist immer froh, wenn nicht so viel über das berichtet wird, was in Europa vor sich geht. Denn man hat ja vor Monaten schon gesagt, auf lebenswichtige Waren könnte ja auch eine Nullprozent Mehrwertsteuer machen. Die könnt ihr abschaffen dann. Das heißt, diese Regelungen, die gibt es ja, nur das wissen die Bürger ja gar nicht. Und das wird auch journalistisch ja kaum gespielt. Also hier musste es dann mal thematisiert werden, weil es dann so auf der Hand lag. Aber die ganze Zeit hätte man das schon machen können mit der Mehrwertsteuer.
Genau, und die Gemengelage ist jetzt so absurd. Wir haben, und das kann man eigentlich ausblenden, als Ursache, ein Krieg in der Ukraine, der macht das Gas irgendwie teuer, wohl gar nicht so viel Gas fehlt, aber gut, es ist wie es ist. Und dann sagt die, dann sagt die Bundesregierung, Unipa ist ein privates Unternehmen, wir unterstützen nur. Das hat gar nichts mit uns zu tun, mit unserer Politik und so weiter und so fort. Dann sagt die EU-Kommission, also das, wie ihr das jetzt regelt, das geht so nicht. Die EU möchte also eigentlich auch schon eine europäische Umsatzsteuerpolitik, eine europäische Wirtschaftspolitik. Das sind ja alles diese Kämpfe, die jetzt geführt werden. Nee, eigentlich ist das unsere Dumme. Wieso mischt ihr euch da noch ein, ihr Nationalstaat? Und jetzt sagt die Bundesregierung zum einen, also mit Unipa haben wir gar nichts zu tun. Und dann kommt die EU-Kommission und sagt, also mit diesem ganzen Zeug habt ihr gar nichts zu tun. Und jeder sagt eigentlich, wir hätten gerne damit was zu tun, aber damit nicht. Aber jeder kriegt genau das, was er nicht haben will. Also total verdreht. So, und jetzt ist aber die Gasumlage, weil nämlich die Bundesregierung sich nicht übereinkommt, einfach zu sagen, wir können ja auch diese ganze Verkopplung des ohnehin viel zu komplizierten Energiemarkts und der staatlichen, ja, wir organisieren das halt hier. Wir haben verschiedene Regeln aufgestellt, wie zum Beispiel die Preisfindung. Das ist ja auch nicht marktwirtschaftlich organisiert, sondern das ist ja wie in der Landwirtschaft und so weiter. Überall ist das hardcore-mäßig geregelt politisch, wie die Preise sich entwickeln. Und jetzt stellt man fest, dann könnte man vielleicht mal anders machen, aber es sind eben politische Entscheidungen, die dann notwendig sind. Und jetzt ist es aber wie es ist. Man hat sich für eine Gasumlage entschieden, auch aus Verlegenheit, weil man den Koalitionspartner nicht unter Druck setzen wollte, also auf dem Falle die FDP von Seiten der Grünen. Und jetzt stellt Unipa natürlich seinen Antrag.
Die höheren Preise werden nun teilweise an die Kunden weitergegeben. So haben bisher den Antrag auf die Gasumlage die NBW-Tochter VNG, der Oldenburger Energieversorger EWE und Unipa gestellt. Morgen früh wird es dann spannend, dann nämlich veröffentlicht der finanziell gebeutelte Konzern Unipa seine Halbjahreszahlen.
So, und bevor es dann am nächsten Morgen spannend wurde und wir diese Zahlen mal gehört haben, bei denen man echt nur vom Stuhl fallen kann, wenn man das hört, hier eine kurze Kurzmeldung. Die EU hat sich nochmal kurz reingeholt und hat nochmal Deutschland erklärt, wie man es so machen könnte.
Jetzt nochmal Nachrichten, die Gasumlage bleibt ein großes Thema.
Die EU-Kommission hat der Bundesregierung Vorschläge gemacht, wie Gaskunden in Deutschland nicht zu stark von der Gasumlage belastet werden können. Nachdem die Ausnahme der Mehrwertsteuerbefreiung rechtlich nicht möglich sei, könne Deutschland auch den niedrigsten erlaubten Mehrwertsteuersatz von 5% erheben oder die zusätzlichen Steuereinnahmen im Nachhinein zurückgeben.
Die zusätzlichen Steuereinnahmen im Nachhinein zurückgeben. Deutschland könnte also so ein Fonds schaffen, eine Übergewinnsteuer, die man feststellt, krass da verdient, aber einige ganz schön viel mit Energie gerade. Dann sacken wir das mal ein und verteilen das dann wieder zurück. Steht ja eigentlich auch ein Koalitionsvertrag, so ein bisschen mit diesem Energiegeld, der Grünen und so. Es ist ja genau dieses Modell der Zurückverteilung von...
Es gibt es ja in Griechenland, in Spanien, in vielen Amten.
Selbst im hardcore kapitalistischen England, wo echt alle sterben gerade vor Hunger. Also da ist nicht einfach nur Hunger, sondern da ist wirklich Tod gerade angesagt. Es ist also der 17. August und Unipa vermeldet mal Quartalszahlen.
Thema an der Börse bleiben die massiven Herausforderungen eben der Energieversorger. Heute der enorme Verlust von 12, 4 Milliarden Euro, den Unipa im ersten Halbjahr zu verzeichnen hat. Bereits durch Staatshilfen vor der Insolvenz gerettet, stellt sich die Frage, Sina Meinitz, wie kann es für Unipa weitergehen?
Tatsächlich sehr ungewiss. Bei manchen am Parkett heißt es heute schon, der Konzern stecke im Auge des Sturms der europäischen Energiekrise. Es wird ein langer und vor allem ein teurer Weg, Unipa zu retten. Der Düsseldorfer Gashändler ist ein systemrelevanter Energieversorger und entsprechend groß ist auch die Sorge.
Der Verlust, den Unipa innerhalb dieser sechs Monate gemacht hat, 12 Milliarden, ist höher als das, was das die drei Monate lang gekostet hat, um sich das mal als Dimension klarzumachen.
Und davon haben 25 Millionen Deutsche profitiert und konnten Kreuzerquertestöcke anfahren. Also 12 Milliarden Halbjahresverlust, das sind zweimal 6 Milliarden. Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass Krupp mal einen 5-Milliarden-Verlust gemeldet hat. Und da war damals schon, also das musste kommentiert werden und die Zeitung war voll davon. Aber 12 Milliarden, das sind Dimensionen, die kennen wir in Deutschland gar nicht. Was eben auch bedeutet, man lüftet jetzt mal so ein bisschen diesen Schleier, den Trugschluss, den Trugschleier, die Täuschung, sagen wir so, den wir in Deutschland so haben. Ja, Juniper ist natürlich ein Staatsunternehmen.
Juniper erhält seit Mitte Juni nur noch ein Fünftel des ursprünglich vereinbarten Gases aus Russland, beliefert aber mehr als 100 deutsche Stadtwerke und Industriefirmen. Zum Tagespreis muss das Gas dann anderswo teuer eingekauft werden, damit der Konzern weiterhin liefern kann. Bereits jetzt ist Juniper zu 30 Prozent in staatlicher Hand, doch sowohl der Staat als auch Gaskunden müssen weiterhin einspringen. Die Kunden zahlen sogar doppelt über die gerade verabschiedete Gasumlage und über die Mehrwertsteuer.
Ja, und das mit dem Doppelt, wir bezahlen das auch über die Mehrwertsteuer. Damit muss man, glaube ich, kann man nochmal sagen, Mehrwertsteuer auf alles gerade. Juniper ist jetzt in staatlicher Hand. Das heißt, die Verquickung mit Bundesstaatsgeld ist so eng, dass quasi jeder Umsatzsteuer, die man, egal mit was gerade macht, fließt am Ende irgendwie als Gasumlage, in Anführungszeichen, an Juniper. Also wir sind eigentlich schon mitten drin und diese ganze Diskussion, wie sie hier gerade geführt wird, ist eigentlich totaler Quatsch.
Ja, ich hab's auch gar nicht so richtig begriffen, weil wir schon die ganze Zeit, wenn die Preise steigen, mehr Mehrwertsteuer zahlen, wir die ganze Zeit also schon doppelt in die Tasche greifen müssen. Und dann macht man noch mal eine Gasumlage, um noch mal sozusagen und das hier oben drauf, aber das weiß ich nicht. Also wenn das ist, das hat mich schon immer, es gibt so Friseure, die so komische Preiserhöhungen machen. Ich will einfach zum Friseur gehen und einen Betrag zahlen. Und dann gibt es aber so Friseure, die sagen, ja, also so viel kostet das und dann das und dann berechnen wir das nochmal extra und jeder Gummihandschuh wird dann nochmal extra berechnen. Da muss ich sagen, das interessiert mich nicht. Sagt mir einfach den Preis am Ende. Und hier haben wir auch so, wir haben schon jetzt einen enormen Preis zu zahlen. Und dann kommt man an mit so einer Gasumlage und überlegt, ob man bei der Gasumlage aber dann die Mehrwertsteuer weglassen könnte, aber bei dem anderen bleibt sie dann. Also das ist ja vollkommen irrsinnig. Und macht auch das am Ende ja nicht mehr aus. Also das war ja pro Haushalt, das wurde ja dann hochgerechnet, je nachdem, welchen Vertrag man hat und so, dass das dann 2000 bis 3500 Euro mehr im Jahr sein können. Und dann kommt durch diese komische Gasumlage nochmal 390 Euro obendrauf. Aber da kann man die ja gleich zusammenrechnen. Was soll das?
So und deswegen kommt jetzt das i-Tüpfelchen auf deine Anmerkung zum i-Tüpfelchen. Nämlich Olaf Scholz, der eine Pressekonferenz anberaumt hat, die weniger als 90 Sekunden lang war. Er hat keine Fragen zugelassen, nur so Statement hier, alle sollen kommen. Und daraufhin, wir hören uns am besten erst den Clip an und diskutieren das danach kurz, was das überhaupt sein soll.
Einen Tag später im Bundeskanzleramt eine hastig einberufene Pressekonferenz mit guter Nachricht für alle Gasverbraucher. Die Mehrwertsteuer auf Gas soll auf 7% sinken. Mit diesem Schritt entlasten wir die Gaskunden insgesamt. Deutlich stärker als die Mehrbelastung, die durch die Umlagen entsteht. Ob die Steuersenkung die Mehrbelastung durch die Gasumlage tatsächlich ausgleicht, ist allerdings nicht sicher. Rund 2, 4 Cent pro Kilowattstunde dürfen Anbieter ab Oktober extra verlangen. Für eine vierköpfige Familie mit einem Jahresverbrauch von 20.000 Kilowattstunden bedeutet das Mehrkosten von etwa 484 Euro pro Jahr. Die abgesenkte Mehrwertsteuer von 7 Prozent auf den gesamten Gaspreis entlastet den Haushalt um 433 Euro. Die Steuerersparnis könnte am Ende also die Mehrkosten der Gasumlage nicht ganz aufheben. Darauf weisen auch Preisvergleichsportale hin.
Wir haben ausgerechnet, dass sich unterm Strich ein Minus ergibt für Gaskunden, wenn man die Steuersenkung und die Mehrkosten für die Gasumlage gegenrechnet.
Wenn Gaspreise weiter steigen, wovon wir auch ausgehen, dann ist es durchaus möglich, dass die Mehrwertsteuersenkung tatsächlich noch diese Preissteigerung der Umlage, der Gasumlage, die am Montag beschlossen worden ist, aufhebt. Zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt ist das aber noch nicht so.
Das kann doch nicht mehr sein.
Pass auf, wir visualisieren das jetzt anhand deines Friseurbesuchs. Du gehst zum Friseur und sagst, du hättest gerne eine Frisur. Und dann sagen die, sie haben doch schon eine. Wir können ihnen anbieten. Wir massieren ihnen noch so ein bisschen den Kopf. Und dann fragst du, was würde das denn zusätzlich kosten? Und dann sagen die, naja, wir massieren ihnen den Kopf. Das kostet dann pro Minute 2, 4 Cent extra. Aber da sie diesen Service in Kauf nehmen, wird insgesamt auf ihren Haarschnitt ein Rabatt von 20 Prozent ermöglicht. Und dann stellst du dich hin, fragst nach Zettel und Stift und malst dir auf so einer Zeitlinie auf, 2, 4 Cent plus jede Minute, aber insgesamt 20 Minuten Rabatt auf alles. Wann die Linie, die nach oben steigt durch die 2, 4 Cent pro Minute, die andere Linie, die kein Rabatt beinhaltet, durchbricht. Und dann siehst du unten 17, 5 Minuten Kopfmassage. Ist so viel mehr Kosten durch die Kopfmassage, dass der Rabatt gerade noch aufgefangen wird, sodass du also mit 0 plus minus im Vergleich zu deinem ursprünglichen Plan nur Frisur mitzunehmen, sondern du kriegst dann eine Frisur plus 17, 5 Minuten Kopfmassage. Bezahlst aber am Ende nicht mehr, verstehst du?
Ja, aber zugleich bekomme ich ja noch gesagt. Aber grundsätzlich ist Haareschneiden dreimal so teuer jetzt. Denn das ist ja auch noch die Sache. Also die Gasumlage kommt ja obendrauf auf die Verteuerung.
Es hat sich das ganze Niveau nochmal angehoben.
Ja, 12 Milliarden ist viel Geld. Aber jetzt könnte man ja schauen, wer braucht wirklich Geld, damit er über die Runden kommt, und die Verstaatlichungen müssen wir ein bisschen später vermutlich angehen. Dann hat man Unipa und ein paar andere. Da muss man sehr genau gucken, ob die nicht einfach Teil irgendeiner Tochtergesellschaft sind. Dann rechnen die da ihre Gewinne raus und da rechnen sie sie rein. Dann haben die auch nochmal Anspruch auf Gasumlage. Das ist ja interessant, dass das Habeck nicht reingeschrieben hat in die Sache, dass man schon auch nahe der Insolvenz sein muss, um überhaupt diese Unterstützung zu haben. Wir sichern eigentlich Profite damit ab. Aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, worauf ich hinaus will, ist, hätten wir nicht diesen Finanzminister und hätten wir nicht aber auch diese Krämerseelen sonst in den Ministerien, dann würde man ja einfach sagen, gut, wie viel wird es wohl kosten? 25 Milliarden oder so. Hier die bekommen 5 Milliarden, die bekommen 7 Milliarden und so weiter. Und damit ist das Ding gegessen. Und wir brauchen jetzt gar nicht irgendwie anzufangen, mit pro Kilowattstunde 2, 4 Cent und so. Weil dahin mit ja eine Rechnung, es wird ja so getan, als würde jetzt dieses Geld, das sammelt man in so eine Bottich und da holt man es dann wieder raus und dann gibt man es denen. Also es gibt ja einfach einen Staatshaushalt und aus dem werden gewisse Dinge finanziert. Jetzt können die das darüber mit dieser Gasumlage noch so und so berechnen und dann geht die Mehrwertsteuer runter. Was soll denn dieser ganze Blödsinn? Man hätte einfach durch Zahlungen an diese Unternehmen das abstützen müssen und gleich auch schon alle Schritte einleiten für eine Verstaatlichung, weil niemand braucht dann private Unternehmen für diesen Unsinn, das kostet nur zusätzlich Geld. Und damit wäre die Sache gegessen gewesen. Und was glaubt man dann auch, wenn man als Politiker dann so vorstellt und jetzt ist das so und so und so? Also diese Rechnung versteht man ja auch nur, wenn man studiert hat. Also die Leute haben den Eindruck, es wird alles teurer fertig. Und dieser Eindruck ist ja auch richtig so. Und da hilft das denen nicht und die sagen ja, aber wissen sie da die 7% jetzt nur noch und dann?
Genau, so und jetzt diskutieren wir genau das, was du aufgeworfen hast, mal durch. Denn du hast ja zum einen die Alternative, man hat einfach ein Budget. Oder man macht eine ganz minutiöse interne Leistungsabrechnung. Das kennt man von der Deutschen Bahn, statt da einfach zu sagen, okay, das ist ein Unternehmen, Fernverkehr, Nahverkehr, Gleitverkehr, das sind natürlich drei Unternehmen unter einem Dach. Und wann immer eine S-Bahn in einen S-Bahnhof einfährt, wird da abgerechnet. Das kostet dann 7, 50 Euro. Und dann wird alles aufsummiert, ein Strich drunter gezogen, statt einfach zu sagen, wir fährt zu, wir durch. Gucken wir einfach am Ende, dass es hinhaut. Und das machen die ja hier auch. Denn es steht ja wirklich, statt dieser interne Leistungsabrechnung, jeder einzelne Haushalt muss jetzt gucken, ob 430 Euro mehr kosten durch Gasumlage, mit 438 Euro Ersparnis durch Mehrwertsteuersenkung auf Energie insgesamt, ob das hinhaut. Alternative ist, man macht einfach einen großen Topf und sagt, das Geld soll ja am Ende bei Unipa als Versorger landen, also geben wir es ihm einfach. Die Diskussion stand ja tatsächlich im Raum.
War das klug, eine Gasumlage zu beschließen, ohne sich vorher genau zu überlegen, wie man die Leute eigentlich entlastet? Weil so wie es jetzt ist, hätte man das Geld doch eigentlich besser gleich den Unternehmen geben können, oder?
Unsere Landesregierung hat bereits im März den Gas-Deckel gefordert, den Gaspreis-Deckel vorgeschlagen. Es gibt ja ein solches Modell.
Also Manuela Schwesig, wieder neumal klug, wollte natürlich budgetmäßig einfach Gaspreis-Deckeln. Das heißt, die Firmen und Haushalte werden gar nicht weiter belästigt, sondern es fließt direkt an die Versorger, den Differenten der Energie. Nun haben wir den Gaspreis-Deckel, der das alles aufsplittet. Jede kleine Familie in Deutschland trägt ein bisschen bei. Und am Ende summiert sich's auf. Und da kann man schon denken, das klingt eher nach Budget. Das hätte man auch einfach mal in ein Budget einfach rüberreichen können.
Der Gaspreis-Deckel. Also das war ja auch ein Konzept, das Julian und Weber vorgeschlagen hatten. Das zielt ja darauf ab, dass der Staat da einspringt, um den Bürger zu entlasten und dass der Preis nicht ins Unermessliche steigen kann. Und diese Preis-Deckelung, die hat es ja immer wieder gegeben in der Geschichte. Nur mir ist neu, dass die SPD, also jetzt hat sie sich dafür stark gemacht. Jetzt seit ein paar Tagen. Aber so zu tun, als sei das in März das Ding schlechthin gewesen, das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Deswegen hören wir ja auch nur Ausschnitte von Manuela Schwesig und ist nicht in Gänze. Denn was sollen wir uns mit der Besserwisser Geschichte einzelner SPD-Politikerinnen befassen? Faktisch sieht das alles danach aus, als hätten wir es hier mit so einer krassen ökonomischen Schieflage zu tun, dass man lieber sagt, wie bei der Lufthansa, neun Milliarden ist der Bedarf, kommt hier. Nehmt einfach die neun Milliarden. Wir klären das mit euch. Nicht jeder einzelne Flugkunde wird jetzt belästigt durch eine Preiserhöhung. Und neun Milliarden bei der Lufthansa, hier bei Unipa sind es andere Dimensionen.
Also ein Großteil der milliardenschweren Gasumlage entfällt tatsächlich nur auf drei Unternehmen. Zwei Drittel der insgesamt 34 Milliarden Euro, die für die Gasumlage bis 2024 anfallen, fließen auf das Konto von Unipa, das eben voll auf russisches Gas gesetzt hatte und auch wegen seiner umfangreichen Beteiligung an Nord Stream 2 in finanzielle Schieflage geraten ist. Und 25 Prozent gehen an das Nachfolgeunternehmen von Gasprom Germania Sefe und die NBW-Tochter VNG. Weitere Unternehmen haben sich vorsorglich listen lassen, darunter auch der Energiekonzern RWE, der vergangene Woche eigentlich angekündigt hatte, keine Gelder in Anspruch nehmen zu wollen.
So 20 Milliarden ungefähr allein für Unipa von 34 Milliarden. Und dann noch andere Unternehmen. Diese Diskussion kann man aussparen. Das hatten wir vorhin schon. Ja, wenn Unternehmen angeboten wird, hier gibt es einen Topf. Klar, bedienen die sich dann. Warum sollten die es auch nicht machen? Dafür sind sie ja Unternehmen. Jens Spahn, hören wir jetzt zum einen, der plädiert für dieses direkte Unterstützen.
Klar ist, der Unipa als Gashändler muss gestützt werden, um auch Versorgungssicherheit für Gaskunden zu geben. Die Frage ist nur, wie. Es gibt bessere Wege, etwa direkt über den Bundeshaushalt, gezielt ein Unternehmen zu stützen, das finanzielle Probleme hat und nicht gleich alle, selbst die mit Gewinnen, auch zu stützen.
So, und jetzt gibt es aber Antworten darauf von Ökonomen, die so ein bisschen die Realität in den Blick nehmen. Und damit ist vor allem gemeint die menschliche Natur. Denn der Preis ist hoch. Und zwar nicht, weil er hoch ist, weil jemand viel verdienen möchte, sondern weil absehbar aufgrund von politischer Entscheidung wir auf russische Quellen bei der Energie verzichten wollen. Und wir haben aber keinen Ersatz dafür. Wir müssen also weniger verwenden, weniger Energie. Und Jens Jüdeckum hat das im Deutschlandfunk schon relativ früh, am 15. während dann erst die Diskussion so ein bisschen losbrach, mal knallhart eigentlich diskutiert.
Wenn Sie sagen, die Preise gehen realistisch vierfach nach oben, fünffach nach oben, das Rezept dagegen oder ein Rezept dagegen ist zu sparen, ist das tatsächlich realistisch, Herr Jüdeckum, dass man sparen kann, obwohl die Preise fünffach nach oben gehen, um diese Kostensteigerungen auszugleichen?
Selbst bei realistischen Sparerfolgen wird man weiterhin auf deutlich höheren Gesamtkosten sitzen bleiben. Also man kann nicht genug sparen, sodass die Gasrechnung sich gar nicht bewegt. Das ist im Einzelfall vielleicht möglich, aber sicherlich nicht in der Breite.
Wir werden aufgefordert zu sparen, aber der Preis wird so krass steigen, dass selbst wenn man die Hälfte einspart, man trotzdem noch doppelte bezahlt, weil der Faktor einfach fünf dazwischen liegt. Also es wird wirklich dramatisch nächstes Jahr, dieses Jahr und nächstes Jahr. Und Jens Jüdecom plädiert nun dafür, dass diese Preissignale direkt an die Kunden gebildet werden. Also nicht über die Politik macht irgendwas mit einem Deckel und zahlt das dann so hintenrum, sondern es muss einmal so richtig durch alle Portemonnaies laufen.
Also die Gasumlage erfüllt ja eben den Zweck, die Ersatzbeschaffungskosten der Gasimporteure zu 90 Prozent abzudecken, also insbesondere Uniper und VNG. Und natürlich hätte man die Löcher dort auch stopfen können mit Steuergeld. Dann wäre aber dieses Preissignal bei den Gaspreisen gerade mal eben ausgefallen. Ich glaube, das ist keine gute Idee in der Lage, wo sich eben auf den Großmärkten die Gaspreise per Zehnfacht haben, die Menschen, die Endverbraucher, in so einer Art künstlichen Sicherheit zu wiegen und seitens der Politik die Botschaft auszusenden, macht euch keine Sorgen, wir sorgen dafür, dass die Gaspreise sich nicht ändern. Das ist hochgefährlich aus meiner Sicht, weil gerade dann die Einsparanreize nicht da sind und wir eben in die Gefahr laufen, dass wir eben tatsächlich am Ende bei der Industrie Produktionenstops kriegen, Arbeitslosigkeit, was ja dann auch wieder auf die Haushalte zurückfällt. Also ich denke, es ist deutlich klüger, zu versuchen, dass auch die Privataushalte insgesamt ungefähr so 15 bis 20 Prozent einsparen gegenüber den Vorjahreswerten.
15 bis 20 Prozent.
Aber 15 bis 20 Prozent ist doch einfach nichts. Also das kann man machen und das wird sich auch dadurch zeigen, aber ich verstehe auch nie, was mit Sparen gemeint ist. Also ich wüsste zum Beispiel in meinem Leben nicht, wie ich Gas, und das ist ja dann bei mir Heizung und warmes Wasser, was soll ich da sparen? Also soll ich mich jetzt runterkonditionieren auf, ich kann mit 19 Grad auskommen? Für mich ist das keine dauerhafte Perspektive. Das gebe ich ganz ehrlich zu. Meine dauerhafte Perspektive wird nicht bei 19 Grad Leben sein. Und alle Leute, die das fordern, verdienen so viel Geld, dass die, wenn es zu kalt wird, ins 5-Sterne-Hotel gehen. Ich bin da auch wirklich, ich will es auch noch mal sagen, bei allen Verzichtsauffrufen, ich gehe eher gemeinsam mit Kubicki unter die heiße Dusche, bevor ich mich solchen Verzichtsauffrufen anschließe. Weil das wirklich eine Unglaublichkeit ist. Und ich finde das auch falsch. Weil es ist die Industrie, die jetzt nicht sparen soll, weshalb wir sparen sollen. Und es ist eine geopolitische Entscheidung zu sagen, wir wollen von diesem Russischen Gas loswerden. Das ist eine Entscheidung, die die Regierung getroffen hat. Die kann man für gut oder schlecht empfinden oder vielleicht ein bisschen zu forsch und unüberlegt, wie auch immer. Jedenfalls weiß ich nicht, warum wir alle dafür extrem bluten müssen finanziell. Und wir reden ja hier von 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung, die davon extremst belastet sind. Und ich muss einfach sagen, nein, es kann der Staat auch genau das abfedern, dass das nicht passiert. Wie das am Ende geschieht, ist mir vollkommen egal, ob die sich da komplizierte Konstrukte ausdenken oder ob sie dann direkte Unterstützung leisten in Form von Checks oder was. Aber man kann nicht an 60 Prozent der Bevölkerung Checks schicken. Das ist auch irgendwie komisch. Aber ich halte diese Deckung auch deshalb für wichtig, weil es ja nicht nur die Knappheit ist, die dadurch entsteht, dass wir jetzt so schnell nicht am Ersatz für russisches Gas kommen, sondern auch weil die Energiepreise sich durch die Ab- und das hat dann nichts mit der Gasumlage zu tun, durch diese verrückte Spekulation in Höhen katapultiert haben, die ja gar nichts mit realen Knappheiten zu tun haben, sondern die wissen einfach die Stimmung auszunutzen und wissen, dass wenn die und die sich weigern, jetzt mehr zu produzieren, dann können wir nochmal mit dem Preis nach oben gehen, für Strom ja auch. Also da reden wir auch nicht von realen Knappheiten. Und warum sollte der Bürger für die Spekulationen und die Spekulationsgewinne, die damit einhergehen, bluten?
Also ich stimme dir bei zu, dass es hier die Stunde der Politik ist, im Sinne eines Robert Habeck, der gerade Kesselwagen durchzählt, um zu gucken, wie er was transportieren kann. Bei den Unternehmen ist ja so ein bisschen so viele Prozesse, gerade in der Chemie, wo ja Gas nicht nur Energieträger, sondern auch Rohstoff ist, entweder man nutzt dort Gas oder etwas anderes, so ein Hochofen. Entweder man feuert ihn mit Kohle oder mit wie auch immer. Dadurch ist dieses Einsparen in der Industrie gar nicht so einfach möglich wie im Haushalt, wo man einfach sagt, und ich meine dieses 15 bis 20 Prozent Ziel heißt ja am Ende der 70er Jahre autofreier Sonntag. Ein Tag von sieben, dann sind wir ungefähr so grob bei 15 bis 20 Prozent.
Da müsste man das 9-Euro-Ticket beibehalten. Aber der Preis ist ja trotzdem noch viel zu hoch für die Menschen. Also wenn ich plötzlich 3000 Euro mehr zahlen muss als im Jahr davor und hab 15 Prozent dann eingespart, dann zahl ich noch 2500 Euro mehr. Das ist ja immer noch ein bisschen zu viel.
Pass auf, da kommt nämlich jetzt hier eine Auflösung. Zum einen, bevor wir Jens Südekum nochmal im Detail hören, über zwei Minuten lang, weil das Argument, was er macht, ist raffiniert. Sagen wir es mal so. Vorher hören wir Marcel Fratscher, der Südekum beipflichtet.
Die einzige Art und Weise, wie wir durch diesen Winter kommen, ohne wirklich Knappheiten, ohne dass Fabriken geschlossen werden müssen oder Menschen kein Gas zu Hause haben, ist indem wir Menschen einsparen. Und der beste Weg, die Anreize zu setzen, ist der Preis.
So, hier sind sich also beide einig. Anreiz über einen echten Preis. Also nicht einen Appell, sondern einen echten Preis.
Naja, ich finde Anreize ist immer so ein positives Wort. Also ich meine, wenn man es einfach nicht mehr sich leisten kann, also wenn man sich nicht mehr zu fressen leisten kann, dann ist man auch weniger. Aber das ist ja kein Anreiz. Also ein Anreiz ist, wenn ich sagen kann, ich kann jetzt irgendwas sparen. Wenn du mir sagst, da kostet die Krawatte 100 Euro und hier kostet 70 Euro, dann ist ein Anreiz, mich nochmal wegzubewegen und sie für 70 zu kaufen. Aber wo ich einfach es mit existenzieller Not zu tun habe. Und die ist ja da. Und wir reden, ich rede ja nicht hier von nur Hartz-IV-Empfängern, sondern ich rede ja hier von einfach Familien, die normal verdienen und die jetzt eine Mieterhöhung bekommen und die jetzt noch teure Energiekosten haben. Das ist ja, da kann ich nicht von einem Anreiz sprechen.
Genau, es ist so halb halb. Die Sparkassen haben ja gesagt, 60 Prozent haben dann echte Sorgen. Für die anderen 40 Prozent wär es ein Anreiz. Und wir wissen ja, die 40 Prozent, die sich es leisten können, können auch am meisten sparen. Das sehen wir ja auch bei der Klimadiskussion. 10 Prozent der Bevölkerung verursachen 90 Prozent des CO2s und so weiter durch die Flugreisen alleine. Und jetzt diese Auflösung von Jens Südekum finde ich wirklich gut. Sie wurde mir zu wenig diskutiert, denn man schafft beides. Zum einen ein Preissignal zu setzen, das überall ankommt und gleichzeitig, und zwar genau dadurch, den Staat wieder einen Handlungsvermögen zu bringen, sich genau um diejenigen zu kümmern, die es in dem Falle dann am meisten brauchen. Ist allerdings ein Clip, der ist ein bisschen länger, zwei Minuten 18, aber man konnte kaum was rausnehmen.
Kommen die Gaskunden also noch einmal mit einem blauen Auge davon?
Ja, so könnte es scheiden. Es war ja am Anfang noch die Rede irgendwo bis zu 5 Cent. Jetzt sind es nur 2, 4 Cent geworden. Das klingt erst mal gut, aber das ist keine wirklich beruhigende Nachricht, denn es wird nicht bei diesen 2, 4 Cent insgesamt bleiben. Das ist nur die Gasumlage, aber die spiegelt nicht die volle Realität am Gasmarkt wieder. Es werden unabhängig davon noch sehr viel höhere Preissteigerungen kommen, auf die sich die Menschen eigentlich jetzt schon einstellen können.
Welche Gasumlage wäre denn aus ihrer Sicht angemessen gewesen, um tatsächlich die Realität abzubilden?
Die Realität wird abgebildet werden, in dem Moment, wenn bestehende Verträge auslaufen und Versorger mit ihren Kunden neue Preise so gesehen aushandeln. In dem Moment werden die dramatisch gestiegenen Großhandelspreise für Gas, die sich ja mehr als verzehnfacht haben seit Beginn der Krise, werden dann auch durchgereicht werden. Das würde ohnehin passieren, auch völlig ohne die Umlage. Ich halte dafür plädiert, dass man darüber nachdenken sollte, die Umlage von vornherein deutlich höher anzusetzen. Letztlich mit der Begründung, dass die Preissignale frühstmöglich kommen sollten. Die Preislagungen werden sowieso kommen, aber wahrscheinlich erst im Laufe des nächsten Jahres. Besser wäre es, sie kämen jetzt noch vor Beginn des Winters, damit die Menschen wissen, dass die Lage ernst ist. Und auch klar ist, dass Gas sparen notwendig ist. Das hätte natürlich bedeutet, dass der Gaspreis noch mal viel, viel stärker angestiegen wäre. Aber das hätte auch zur Folge gehabt, dass bei einer höheren Umlage der Staat deutlich mehr Geld hätte einnehmen können. Dass er dann hätte verwenden können für gezielte Entlastungspakete für Menschen mit kleinem und mittleren Einkommen. Und davon ist ja leider heute noch gar nicht die Rede.
Also verstehe ich Sie richtig. Wirtschaftsökonomisch wäre es besser, jetzt eine Schocktherapie, wenn man so will, für die Bürger statt die Preise so oder so dann Stück für Stück nach oben zu drehen. So macht das ja derzeit die Bundesregierung. Damit es dem Bürger nicht so wehtut.
Mir ist natürlich bewusst, dass so eine Schocktherapie ein echter Schock eben auch wäre für Menschen, wo es wirklich an die Substanz geht. Nur diese Realität bei den Gaspreisen, die werden wir ja nicht aus der Welt kriegen durch kein Instrument.
Ja, aber der Staat könnte doch, also ich verstehe das nicht, das Argument, weil der Staat könnte, hat ja Geld, also wir sagen uns das, die MMT-Lehren haben wir ja alle hier hundertmal bekakelt. Der Staat hat also die Möglichkeit, das zu tun. Zugleich gibt es die Möglichkeit, dass man die ganze Energieversorgung anders nämlich nicht privat organisiert. Und natürlich sind wir dann immer noch einem internationalen Markt ausgesetzt, aber auch hier nochmal ganz klar der Punkt, wir haben es nicht mit realen Knappheiten nur zu tun. Das ist auch der Fall durch den Ukrainekrieg. Aber da hängt jetzt nicht alles dran. Und das ist jetzt nicht nur, weil wir von Russland so wenig bekommen, sondern diese ganzen Energiepreise haben sich aufgrund von Spekulationen erhöht. Hinzu kommt ja auch, dass die Spekulation in anderen Segmenten nicht gut funktioniert. E-Commerce, Technologie, Aktien und so weiter. Diese ganzen Dinge gehen alle in den Keller. Gaming sieht extrem düster aus. Da hat man vor einem Jahr noch ganz anders drüber gesprochen. Auf der Gamescom sind dann nicht mal die großen Hersteller aufgetaucht. Also da geht alles runter. Das heißt, man kann an der Börse gerade noch Geschäft machen mit Energie. Und das passiert. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum man das als eine reale Knappheit begreift, mit der wir zurechtkommen müssen, sondern Saudi-Arabien könnte mehr Erdöl produzieren. Machen sie nicht. Genauso könnten wir jetzt auch sagen, ich will jetzt nicht dafür plädieren, aber wir könnten auch sagen, wir erholen jetzt doch Nord Stream 2, damit wir gut durch den Winter kommen oder so. Also das sind ja alles, das sind ja nur geopolitische Entscheidungsrande. Das ist ja nicht um reale Knappheiten, will ich damit ausdrücklich sagen. Und da verstehe ich nicht, warum das auf die Bürger, die jetzt ohnehin durch Corona schon weniger bekommen haben. Also da hat man ja schon Transfers gemacht zu Unternehmen. Kurzarbeit Geld ist nur dafür da, damit Unternehmen nicht so viel bezahlen mussten. Die Arbeit ging ja weiter. Wir haben Mietpreissteigerungen, wir haben Zinssteigerungen, die dazu führen, dass Leute ihre Hausgredite nicht mehr bekommen oder sie sich nicht leisten können. Und jetzt sagt man aber die Energie auch. Und ich finde das falsch, dass man das so tut, als wäre das unsere Aufgabe. Das ist ja dann so wie wie Agnes Strack Zimmermann, die dann sagt, ich habe dieses dieses Zitat noch da. Ich bin ja fast ausgeflippt. Da sagte sie in der in einem Interview. Wir alle haben nur ein Leben und das will jeder von uns so schön und angenehm wie möglich gestalten. Aber es geht nicht nur um uns, sondern ich bin jetzt auch mal pathetisch. Es geht auch um das zukünftige Leben unserer Kinder und Enkelkinder, die auch das Recht haben, so wie wir jahrzehntelang in einem freiheitlichen und friedlichen Deutschland zu leben. Und es war jetzt nicht ein Plädoyer für Klimawandel oder so ein Kram Klimaschutz, sondern sie meinte, wir müssen Opferbereitschaft zeigen, also durch diesen harten Winter gehen, weil sie sich das so vorstellt. Und da muss ich sagen, nö, warum eigentlich?
Also ich sympathisiere sehr mit diesem Südekum-Take, denn das Energiegeld hatte ja schon genau die Logik, nämlich wahrzunehmen, dass, wie eben schon gesagt, diese alte Regel gilt, 20% der Leute verursachen 80% der Probleme. Also schöpfen wir da ordentlich ab und verteilen dann zu den 80% zurück. Was ja bedeutet, dass die untere Hälfte, also die im Verbrauch zurückhaltenden 50% einen Plus eigentlich erwirtschaften dadurch, weil sie vielmehr von Südekum die unteren 50 60 Prozent gemeint, oder geht das jetzt darum?
Na ja, wer jetzt mit der Familie im Reihenhäuschen lebt, der hat halt Pech gehabt. Der muss jetzt dann sich stark einschränken und und kann sehen, wo er bleibt. Und es gibt nur noch so ein paar Transfers dann für die Härtefälle, wo man sagt, gut, man kann jetzt dem Hartz IV Empfänger nicht alles abdrehen. Das, weil das wird mir nicht so klar, wie weit denn diese Umverteilung? Also ist das eine Umverteilung von den oberen 50 Prozent auf die unteren 50 Prozent? Dann finde ich das eine interessante Überlegung. Aber mein Verdacht ist eher, dass man sagt, naja, alle sollen leiden. Und dann gibt es jetzt noch die, die wir nicht ganz durchs Raster fallen lassen. Klar.
Also ich verstehe Südekomm natürliche wohlwollend, so wie ich auch Fratschala immer noch wohlwollend. Südekomm geht es ja am Ende auch um das Aufrechterhalten der ganzen Volkswirtschaft.
Also hier außerdem erhöht man ja die Inflation damit noch mehr. Also das verstehe ich gar nicht, dass man das nicht erkennt, dass man die Inflation ja auch über so einen Preisdeckel bremsen kann. Ja, das Energiepreise sind ja Preise, die sich auf alles nochmal draufschlagen. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagen kann Laptops sind gerade so teuer. Dann kann man sagen, dass das juckt den Bäcker nicht. Aber Energiepreise schlagen sich auf alle Bereiche drauf, auf manche damit besonders stark, zum Beispiel Bäckereien. Da muss man doch erkennen, dass wir gegen diese Inflation durch zum Beispiel Preisdeckel ankämpfen können in sinnvoller Weise.
Das stimmt. Es ist natürlich in vielerlei Belangen eine komplizierte Diskussion, weshalb wir sowas niemals in realer Politik sehen. Schon allein, weil Moritz Hoeffgen sich den Mond fußlich redet. Ja, wir haben eine Inflation und die EZB sollte trotzdem die Füße stillhalten. Nein, wir haben natürlich Kommentatoren in der ARD, die das dann ganz anders sehen und bei Inflation immer gleich in Panik verfallen. Wir wissen aber, wenn Inflation durch 44-prozentige Steigerungen der Energiepreise, ja, das legt sich natürlich nochmal über endgültige Konsumerelektronikpreise sozusagen drauf oder auch was man im Supermarkt kauft. Dennoch, diese Idee, wenn wir eine Verzehnfachung des Großhandelspreises sehen. Zu sagen, naja, dann visualisieren wir uns die mal so, dass wir sie sofort importieren. Aber nicht im Sinne von, dann geben sofort die Haushalte diese Preise, obwohl die gar nicht in den Verträgen geregelt sind, an die Großhändler weiter, sondern der Staat greift sie vorher ab und schafft damit einen zweckgebundenen Finanztopp. Also keine allgemeine Steuer, sondern wirklich eine Abgabe, wie ja die Gasumlage auch als Abgabe fungiert. Die zweckgebunden ist, die also ausgleichen soll, dass für sehr viele diese Energie nicht bezahlbar ist. Ich glaube, da wir immer wieder unterschätzen, wie groß die Vermögensverteilung oder die Vermögensunterschiede in Deutschland sind, dass das auch bei der Verwendung von Gas so ist, dass also die zehn Prozent der Haushalte, die am meisten Gas brauchen, egal durch was, durch große landwirtschaftliche Gärten, die sie da pflegen oder wie auch immer, dass die, die auch nicht in Verlegenheit kommen, irgendwelche Anträge zu stellen, die noch bewilligt werden auf wir brauchen die Unterstützung, weil man einfach sieht, ne, ihr braucht keine Unterstützung, ihr habt genug. Dass die ausreichen, die Energiekosten der ganzen normalen Haushalte, der 50, 60 Prozent, von denen die Sparkasse sprach, komplett zu bezahlen, wenn nicht noch da Geld oben drauf zu legen. Das ist allerdings auch das Argument dafür, weshalb wir sowas natürlich niemals sehen werden in Deutschland. Weil diese Art der Umverteilung von oben nach unten findet natürlich nichts statt. Was tun wir uns schwer mit dem Energiegeld? Und das hat es immerhin schon mal so ein bisschen in die Parteiprogramme geschafft von Parteien, die dann auch gewählt wurden und kommt dann trotzdem zu kurz. Aber sie ist als Idee im Raume. Stattdessen nun und das schließen wir hiermit ab, die Diskussion, die ich vorhin schon kurz angeteasert habe. Was ist diese Gasumlage eigentlich? Wir hören mal zum einen deine Lieblingsnachrichtensprecherin Susanne Daubner, die uns hier kurz... Irgendwas ist in Berlin, es geht runter und drüber.
Die Bundesregierung steht wegen der geplanten Gasumlage erneut in der Kritik. Inzwischen ist klar, dass davon auch Unternehmen profitieren wollen, die gar nicht in wirtschaftlicher Bedrängnis sind, sondern hohe Gewinne machen.
Das hat sie doch hervorragend betont. Die ganzen Dimensionen, die darin liegen, werden einem durch den Klang bewusst.
Richtig. Hast du gehört, wie sie vorgetragen hat, welche Wörter in Rede stehen?
Die Jugendwörter habe ich mir sofort angehört.
Sehr gut. Jetzt kommt sozusagen auf, da ist Unruhe in Berlin reagierend unser Habeck Wirtschaftsminister, der sich dieses mit der Gasumlage aus Verlegenheit ausgedacht hatte.
Das ist eine These.
Es ist noch meine These, aber wir gehen sie mal...
Also das ist jetzt die originellste These, glaube ich, wirklich, die ich auch zu dieser Thematik gehört habe. Ich habe viel gelesen in den letzten Tagen dazu, aber wir sind sehr gespannt, Stefan.
Drei Clips dazu.
Wir müssen sehen, dass die Unternehmen, die eigentlich keinen Zugang zu dieser Umlage brauchen, ihn auch nicht bekommen. Und wie gesagt, das ist ein Problem. Wir arbeiten an einer Lösung. Die Umlage selbst, das habe ich ja nie verheimlicht, ist ein unangenehmer Schritt, eine unangenehme Entscheidung. Aber eine notwendige Entscheidung, weil die Alternative gewesen wäre, dass die Gasunternehmen, die am Markt gescheitert sind, weil sie ihr Geschäftsmodell auf billigem russischem Gas aufgebaut haben, jetzt das nicht mehr bekommen, neues teures Gas nachkaufen müssen, diese Preise irgendwie kompensieren müssen. Und der Staat ist reingegangen. Wir haben ja zwei Unternehmen, Gasprom, Germania und Unipa, mit Milliardenbeträgen gestützt, ist reingegangen. Aber eine dauerhafte Finanzierung durch den Staat ist eben noch kein Geschäftsmodell. Und deswegen mussten wir diese Umlage wählen. Oder eben die Kunden diese Unternehmen alleine mit den Unternehmen lassen. Diese Umlage ist also ein Solidaritätsmechanismus. Das ist wohl so entschieden worden.
Die Umlage ist ein unangenehmer Solidaritätsmechanismus, damit die Kunden nicht alleine mit diesen Unternehmen ist, sondern jetzt alle Gaskunden einfach flächendeckend damit in Beschlag genommen werden. Wir haben es nicht nur mit einer künstlichen Verknappung von Rohstoffen zu tun, sondern, das hat Habeck hier gemeint, auch mit einer künstlichen Verknappung von politischen Ideen. Denn die FDP hat einfach ausgeschlossen, der Übergewinnsteuer zu machen.
Dass Unternehmen, die jetzt nicht in finanzielle Not geraten sind, in der Summe der Umlage zu einem geringen Anteil, aber in der Anzahl der Unternehmen natürlich doch einige, ebenfalls von der Umlage Gebrauch machen, ist die Folge einer einheitlichen Gesetzgebung. Aber natürlich wäre das nicht notwendig gewesen für die Unternehmen. Man muss in der Logik des Gesetzes dann folglich Gewinne dieser Unternehmen an anderer Stelle besteuern.
Müsste man eigentlich Gewinne besteuern. So, und das wäre ja auch nicht so eine Idee der Übergewinnsteuer. Eine interne Verteilung von Gewinnen zwischen den Unternehmen innerhalb des Marktes ist ja nicht ungewöhnlich, sondern so funktioniert es ja. Das teuerste Unternehmen gibt den Preis für alle vor, wodurch diejenigen, die billig liefern können, zum einen zuerst liefern dürfen und dann unglaubliche Gewinne drauf machen. Die ganzen Solar- und Windkraftanlagen verkaufen ja gerade Strom zu Gaspreisen. Die machen also unglaubliche Gewinne, dadurch, dass es ist, wie es ist. Warum sollte man nicht also auch so ein Unternehmensgewinn noch mal anders verteilen, wie man auch ein Produktgewinn intern sowieso schon so verteilt? So kann man ja einfach machen. Und es ist nicht nur Robert Habeck, der hier uns schon mal sagt, also eigentlich wollte ich ja eine Übergewinnsteuer. Und ich glaube, das werden wir im September noch sehr viel häufiger hören von Habeck, dass das eigentlich die bessere Idee gewesen wäre. Sie ist nur leider an der FDP gescheitert. Auch Ricarda Lange, also die Chefin von Habeck, die grünen Chefin, sagt das hier ein? Also glasklar.
Wenig hilft da dem grünen Wirtschaftsminister, das ihm seine Parteivorsitzende zur Seite eilt, mit einem Vorschlag, den in der Ampel rot schon mal gemacht und gelb gleich abgelehnt hatte.
Wenn man eine Situation wie hier hat, wo Recht und Gerechtigkeit auseinanderklaffen, dann braucht es politische Lösungen. Und deshalb ist für mich die logische Konsequenz aus dieser Situation eine Übergewinnsteuer für Energiekonzerne.
Klingt komisch, ist aber so. Je weniger Gas, je höher der Preis, desto heißer wird der Herbst. Gilt für Robert Habeck allemal.
Das ist eine komische Kommentierung dazu. Kann man dann nicht was Vernünftiges dazu sagen?
Nein, das ist stecklich. Ich glaube, wir haben mit Wahlkämpfe vor uns, Niedersachsen und so weiter, und wir werden von den Grünen das noch hören. Wir mussten leider dieses Gasumlage-Ding wählen, weil die FDP alles andere blöd fand. Aber eigentlich ist eine Übergewinnsteuer genau richtig. Und schon der Begriff Übergewinn, das triggert doch alle Wähler in Deutschland. Na klar müssen Übergewinne besteuert werden.
Oder du machst das dann wie der Lieblingsgeneral, der linksliberalen Zackzimmermann, die dann sagt, es gibt gar keine Übergewinne.
Genau, diese Definitionsblödsinn.
Es gibt ja gar keine Übergewinne. Da fragt man sich auch, welche Interessen vertritt dann so eine Agnes Strack Zimmermann da noch? Also klar, zum einen vertritt sie Rüstungsinteressen, aber das hat ja jetzt noch nichts damit zu tun. Wem ist jetzt damit geholfen? Sie ist ja nicht irgendwie noch eine wichtige Akteurin an der Börse, dass man dann sagen kann, und deswegen muss sie das sagen. Also das ist dann wieder pure Ideologie in meinen Augen. Also das ist ja nicht mehr, dass man sagen kann, hier wird irgendwie die Deutschland AG oder so unterstützt, sondern das würde tatsächlich so viel in Gang setzen. Und da wäre ja auch wieder interessant, jetzt haben wir eine EU, die Deutschland die ganze Zeit darauf hinweist, übrigens, ihr könntet auch das machen, ihr könntet auch das machen, wir haben ja ein Programm für euch. Wir haben ja mal was vorbereitet, ja. Und jetzt bei dieser Übergewinnsteuer ist es ja schon so, dass die ganzen anderen Länder oder viele andere Länder sie machen. Und Deutschland könnte jetzt auch nochmal als ein sehr mächtiges Land in Europa natürlich ein unglaubliches Signal setzen, wenn man das anfängt. Man kann ja sogar darüber nachdenken, über Gewinnsteuern wirklich international zu organisieren. Seit Beginn von Corona gab es da ja Vorschläge zu. Aber nee, wird einfach weggewischt. Vielleicht kommt es dann jetzt wieder. Die SPD hat ja auch jetzt ein ambitionierteres Programm vorgestellt, wie man Entlastungen schaffen kann. Das geht jetzt gegen die Grünen natürlich. Man freut sich da über Habecks Niederlage. Das gehört zum Spiel dazu, ob jetzt die Grünen da mit der Übergewinnsteuer kommen. Ich glaube jedenfalls, dass es eine Kombination aus beidem sein muss und auch eine Kombination mit einem 9-Euro-Ticket und auch nicht mit einem 49-Euro-Ticket, weil ich das auch jetzt wieder... Also man kann natürlich jetzt auch sagen, man entlastet diese Leute, die jetzt immer pendeln und so, aber das 9-Euro-Ticket war ja nicht einfach eine Entlastung für Leute, die ohnehin ihr Monatsticket haben. Da würde die 49 Euro helfen, sondern das 9-Euro-Ticket war auch die Möglichkeit, dass sich überhaupt mal Leute, die sich sonst nicht fortbewegen können, fortbewegen können. Und gerade mit Blick auf die Geselligkeit, die du ja stark machen willst, war das eigentlich das Wichtigste.
Die Förderung von Mobilität ist eine der wichtigsten Sachen überhaupt. Und Strack Zimmermann kann von Mios noch ewig behaupten, was ist denn wohl ein Übergewinn? Das ist doch gar nicht, das gibt gar keine Definition und so weiter. Stimmt alles, aber es kommen ja dann wirklich die Quartatszahlen. RWE verdoppelt einfach mal den Gewinn, die anderen Unternehmen vor dreifachen, vor vierfachen. Dann stehen die auch ziemlich blöde da, wenn die dann in so einer Lage, es ist dann wirklich Herbst, der erste kalte Tag im Oktober, und die FDP behauptet irgendwie, es gibt doch gar keinen Übergewinn, und gleichzeitig drudeln in der Börsenberichterstattung diese Energiekonzerne, zahlen da ein. Also da fragt man sich ja auch, ob dann... Also ich würde sagen, wir warten mal noch ein bisschen an. Und geben den Grünen mal noch eine Chance.
Für eine Schwachsinnenslogik zu sagen, das ist Definitionssache. Ja, jede Steuer ist eine Definitionssache, nichts anderes. Jeder Gewinn, das ist alles nur Definitionssache. Genau das ist Politik. Rahmen zu definieren, da gibt es nichts Natürliches dran. Das müsste man eigentlich, wenn man der FDP ist, besonders gut wissen, denn die haben eine verminderte Mehrwertsteuer eingeführt für Hotels. Das ist auch eine reine Definitionssache.
Ja, wenn wir einen linken Populismus im Sinne von, wie wir sie uns allen wünschen, hätten, dann hätte man ja diese Idee der kulturellen Aneignung. Der hat ja ganz viel damit zu tun, dass man einen ökonomischen Profit daraus zieht, Kulturgüter anderer zu verwenden, beispielsweise indem man sie in deutschen Museen ausstellt und dann einfach verschweigt, wo das eigentlich herkommt und wem das gehört und wer da auch seit Jahrzehnten Anspruch anmeldet und so weiter. Und diesen Übergewinn könnte man, glaube ich, auf diese Voker-Art, vulgär Voker-Art, denn die kulturelle Aneignungsdebatte wird ja in Deutschland gar nicht... Diejenigen, die das auf Twitter benutzen als Begriff, wissen ja gar nicht, wo das eigentlich herkommt. Also das ist aus der Kolonialgeschichte und so weiter. Und eigentlich bräuchten wir so eine vulgär Voker-Übergewinnstdefinition, die von kriegerischer Aneignung spricht. Also die von, da ist ein Krieg und ihr eignet, ihr inkorporiert ihn ökonomisch, ihr nutzt ihn aus. Da braucht man so einen Begriff für, der das darstellt. Und dann hätte man die Diskussion, glaube ich, zügig gedreht. Denn ja, natürlich sind das solche Übergewinne. Und dann kann die FDP noch so viel behaupten, ne, es sind einfach nur Gewinne. Ja, aber die kommen ja aus einem ganz spezifischem Grund. Und das kann man in ein Wort oder in zwei Worte fassen. Und in der Ansicht bin ich da gar nicht, also ich glaube nicht, dass das zum Jahresende für die FDP gut ausgeht, diese Art der Diskussion, Übergewinnsteuer, so einen Scheiß machen wir nicht. Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass Habeck dann als Verlierer da steht, sondern Habeck wird dann sagen, wir haben das ja kollegial entschieden, ich durfte mich da nicht durchsetzen, sondern ich bin ein Kompromiss eingegangen, die FDP wollte das so und so. Und dann fällt das ganze Gebäude so ein bisschen in die andere Richtung, während man jetzt so ein klappriges Gebäude sieht, das in die eine Richtung kippt.
Und man hat das ja in die eine Richtung schon verstanden. Also man würde ja nicht behaupten, ah ja, da fließt halt Geld nach Russland, aber das hat ja das Geld, das da über Gasprommen und so nach Russland geht, das hat ja nichts mit dem Krieg von Putin in der Ukraine zu tun. Das würde man ja nicht behaupten. Da sieht man den genauen Zusammenhang. Und dann kann man genauso sagen, ja, genau. Und dieser Krieg produziert, dass es Knappheiten gibt und produziert, dass man erkannt hat, ach, man kann damit noch mehr spekulieren. Also kann man in gewisser Weise sagen, da opfern sich jetzt gerade Menschen in der Ukraine für die Profite von irgendwelchen Energiekonzernen, die sagen, macht ruhig noch ein bisschen weiter, uns geht es gerade prächtig hier.
Genau, auch Strack Zimmermann würde gerade nicht bestreiten, dass Putin gerade Übergewinne macht.
Ja, ganz genau. Also man muss es in beide Richtungen drehen, dann erkennt man es. Jetzt haben wir heute viel über Politik gesprochen, deswegen soll es jetzt noch um die sogenannte Schönheit gehen, was immer man darunter verstehen kann. Ich bin auf das Thema aufmerksam geworden, erst mal durch eine neue Arte-Doku über Instagram, vielleicht hast du die auch schon gesehen.
Ich habe davon gehört, ja.
Es bietet allzu viel Neues, aber auch deshalb, weil da eine Autorin zu Wort kommt, die ein Buch über Instagram geschrieben hat. Dieses Buch haben wir im Salon schon vor vielen Monaten gelesen. Genau, nur Filter. Die Autorin äußert sich da und sagt interessante Dinge, aber das Buch geht ja weiter. Wir haben es ausführlich besprochen. Aber in dieser Doku, die so ganz in Ordnung ist, fallen ein paar Zahlen und Aussagen, die ich wirklich bemerkenswert fand. Und die erste hören wir jetzt.
Miami scheint wie geschaffen für Instagram. Die Stadt des Körperkohls ist auch die Welthauptstadt der Schönheitschirurgie. 20.000 Frauen kommen jedes Jahr hierher, um sich einen Brazilian Buttlift zu gönnen. Das sind 100 Millionen Dollar Umsatz für Mayammis Kliniken.
Was ist ein Brazilian Buttlift? Das sieht so aus, dass man Vorbilder bei Instagram sieht, Kim Kardashian oder wie noch immer, und sagt sich, ich habe ja Fett im Bauch. Das lasse ich mir abspritzen und in den Po hineingeben. Und dann habe ich auch so einen Po. Und das sind Operationen, die immer beliebter werden und die gerade durch Instagram sehr groß geworden ist. Und als wir das Influencer Buch veröffentlicht haben, da war ja ganz interessant, dass so Marketing-Leute oder Leute aus der Wirtschaft interessanterweise total zustimmen den Thesen. Und die profitieren halt davon, dass es so ist, was wir kulturkritisch beschreiben. Aber die sagen auf jeden Fall, so ist das. Und wenn man dann so manche Feuilletonisten dazu hört, dann ist das so, dass sie sagen, ja, aber das, also so einfach kann man das ja nicht sagen. Also es entfaltet doch so viel tolle Kreativität. Und es gibt doch gar nicht diese direkte ideologische Wirkung durch die Bilder. Und dann ist man einfach froh, wenn man zum Beispiel einen Arzt aus Miami in dieser Doku hört.
Seitdem es die App gibt, kommen die Leute mit Bildern von Instagram-Promis zu mir.
Nicki Minaj, Kim Kardashian.
Sie sind berühmt für ihre geshapten Körper. Alle wollen so aussehen wie sie.
Wer einen Po wie Kim Kardashian möchte, zahlt bei Dr. Miami 13.000 Dollar.
Diese Kliniken boomen. Man kann diese Kliniken auch eröffnen, ohne ein richtiger Arzt zu sein. Da geschieht Schlimmes mitunter. Aber dass man sich hier nochmal ganz klar wird, nee, wir wissen schon um die Mental-Health-Effekte, die Social Media hat. Und das ist nicht zu leugnen. Wir haben da Francis Hogan auch gehört. Wir haben über Manfred Spitzer gesprochen. Das bestätigt sich alles empirisch immer wieder. Also da gibt es ja immer neue Erhebungen zu. Auch die Schönheitschirurgie verändert sich durch Instagram. Das heißt, es gibt diese direkte Wirkung. Und das braucht man, das kann man Kulturpessimismus oder sonst was nennen. Es ist nur dann vollkommen falsch, weil man dann nicht begreift, dass es diese Wirkung wirklich gibt. Und dann kommt eine Zahl, die mich jetzt mit Blick auf die Demografie erschrocken hat. Denn wir sind ja eigentlich, haben es ja mit einem alten Land auch in Amerika zu tun, einem relativ alten Land schon. Und jetzt hör dir das mal an.
Seit dem Start von Instagram hat sich die Zahl der Brazilian Buttlifts in den USA verdreifacht. Inzwischen unterziehen sich mehr 18- bis 34-Jährige einer Schönheits-OP als ältere Menschen.
Das sind es 34-Jährige, die machen mehr Schönheits-OP als ältere Menschen. Wir hatten das ja auch schon mal kurz hier mit Bibi angesprochen, die ja ihre Schönheits-OP groß ausgestellt hat. Und da bekommt man ja immer schnell den Vorwurf gemacht, jetzt redet hier ein Mann über einen Frauenkörper. Ich kann natürlich jetzt so heraus sagen, jeder kann machen, was er will. Ich sehe nur die Wirkung, die diese Medien auf junge Menschen haben, die in der Regel noch nicht so selbstbewusst sind, dass sie vielleicht mit den ein oder anderen sogenannten Schwächen zurechtkommen, sondern dass sie sich sehr früh schon dadurch unter Druck gesetzt gefühlt sagen, ach so muss eigentlich eine Nase oder ein Busen oder was aussehen. Aber wir wollen jetzt gar nicht bei den Buttlifts bleiben, denn ein wirklich interessantes Phänomen, auf das ich dann gestern gestoßen bin, dachte ich, gut, jetzt muss ich das bringen. Ich hatte schon diese Clips von der Arte Doku. Ist das Thema Jawline. Was ist eine Jawline? Ich kannte diesen Begriff auch bis vor wenigen Jahren nicht. Die Jawline ist also das, was die Kontur gibt vom Kinn bis hin zum Ohr. Also dass man den Kieferknochen ausgeprägt hat und dass man so eine gute Kontur hat. Das ist ein Begriff, da würde ich mal behaupten, vor 10, 12 Jahren kannte den so gut wie niemand. Mittlerweile ist dieser Begriff in aller Munde. Es gab und gibt eine sehr interessante Dokumentation. Jawline heißt die über junge Männer, die versuchen im Internet prominent zu werden, die aus eher einfachen Verhältnissen kommen. Ganz interessant kann man bei Hulu sehen, vielleicht auch sonst irgendwo im Internet. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Jedenfalls wurde da dieser Begriff für mich so präsenter. Und dann sah ich gestern bei so einem Twitter-Account Komi so und so. Die schreibt immer über Schönheitsoperationen von Stars und Politikern. Da hat sie Bilder gezeigt von Chris Hemsworth und mutmaßte, dass er sich hat Implantate in den Kiefer jetzt reinsetzen lassen, um mehr Jawline zu haben. Also wie gesagt, das sind nur Mutmaßungen, die wir hier nicht bestätigen. Bei Tom Cruise würde ich es auch unterstellen, vielleicht muss man sich mal genauer ansehen und bei vielen Stars wird das inzwischen durchdiskutiert. Die Jawline also spielt eine ganz große Rolle und ich googelte dann und ich guckte bei YouTube und dann merkte ich, okay, ich könnte jetzt tausende Videos gucken, die sich nur mit der Jawline auseinandersetzen. Es ist absurd. Wir schauen jetzt, hören uns mal ein paar kurze Clips aus dem Jawline Universum an. Aber eine Sache, die mir viel geholfen hat, ist, dass du deine Zahnmuskeln wie du die anderen Muskeln hättest.
Ich dachte, das hätte sicher nur ein Marketing-Gimmick sein müssen.
Sie haben mir auch ihre Reihen der Jawliners und sie kommen in diese schöne metallische Tüte und sie sind wie ein schweres Rubber-Erhebungspad für deinen Brustknochen.
Sie sind reaktiv und nach dem Schäumen war mein Brustknochen so sauer.
Dies ist jetzt ein Influencer der Werbung macht für ein besonderes Kaugummi, das sehr schwer zu kauen ist.
Muskelkater im Kiefer, hat er gesagt.
Du bekommst Muskelkater im Kiefer. Ich musste dabei an einen Ausflug ins Senckenbergmuseum mit der Schule denken, denn dort kann man ja auch so einige Sklette finden, Kiefer von Neandertalern und so was. Und ich weiß noch genau, der Lehrer, der Biologielehrer, war ein großer Feind des Kaugummis und sagte zu uns, jetzt schaut euch mal diese Kiefer an. Das sind noch die Neandertaler oder, nee, das waren die, nein, das werden ja auch dann, also noch die Vorstufe. Und so haben die alles da. Und je weiter die Sklette weg waren von dem, was heute der Homo sapiens ist, desto ausgeprägter meinte er, seien die Knochen, die haben nämlich noch so viel kauen müssen. Und dann hat er gesagt, und ihr seid jetzt Homo sapiens und deswegen müsst ihr nicht mehr so viel kauen. Und deswegen lasst ihr die Kaugummis draußen, damit ihr euch nicht wieder zurückentwickelt, in das, was hier in den Kästen liegt. Aber inzwischen scheint das wohl alles anders zu sein. Also Jawline heißen diese Kaugummis. Wir hören jetzt mal kurz den Founder des Unternehmens.
And what we want everybody to know is that an attractive and chiseled jawline is not all about genetics.
It's also up to you.
For five years now, we have been developing different products for jaw and face training with medical support. And what you see here is our last development. It's the toughest and hardest chewing gum in the world.
Es gibt auch für Menschen mit längeren Haaren vor allem, weil man das dann irgendwie verstecken kann, solche Plastikbänder, also Tesafilm in dem Sinne, dass man sich so hinter das Ohr kleben kann und damit zieht man dann offenbar die Haut nach oben und glaubt damit, eine Jawline zu haben. Das haben einige Frauen dann bei YouTube ausprobiert. Dann gibt es solche kleinen, ich weiß nicht, wie so kleine Geräte, die man sich in die Zähne drücken kann, ins Gebiss drücken kann und dann macht man immer den Mund auf und zu und soll das damit trainieren können. Es gibt die verrücktesten Geschichten. Und meine These ist, weil wir jetzt eben noch über Instagram sprachen, die Jawline ist nicht so sehr Produkt von Instagram, sondern ich glaube in ganz hohem Maße ein TikTok-Trend. Also es sind auch fast alles, was wir jetzt hier hören, sind Shorts bei YouTube und das sind einfach nur gespiegelte TikTok-Videos. Weil diese Kameraperspektive, die TikTok so gemacht hat, also dass man die Kamera so ein bisschen nach oben hält und davor so tanzt und dann nicht nach oben hält, sondern man guckt ziemlich genauso rein und bewegt so den Kopf von rechts nach links, macht dieses Lip-Sync-Geschichte und will diesen unglaublich jugendlichen Ausdruck haben und will diese Kontur haben, das ist etwas, was dieses Jawline-Ideal hervorgebracht hat. Und ich glaube, dass wirklich hier das Medium TikTok auf diese Weise jetzt die Gesichter formt. Also es ist eine ganz, ganz furchtbare Angelegenheit, vor allem dann, wenn man sieht, was für Tutorials da angeboten werden. Wir hören jetzt mal gerade so ein Clip und wundern uns erstmal. So, da wir ja in einem Podcast sind und nichts sehen können, muss ich beschreiben, was man da eigentlich sehen kann. Gehört haben wir das? Das ist Matrix, die rote Pille und so weiter. Wir kennen diese Insel-Männer-Bewegungen im Internet. Und natürlich hängt das sehr mit diesem Diskurs auch zusammen. Also es ist einmal dieser TikTok-Fuckboy-Look, den man haben will. Aber es hat auch mit diesem und und Fuckboy ist etwas, das habe ich, glaube ich, in der Zeit gelesen, dass das so der Typus ist, der da verlangt wird. Und es hat aber auch mit so einem Männlichkeitsideal zu tun, wie man eigentlich als Mann auszusehen hat. Und diese Red Pill, die er da geschluckt hat, um jetzt tatsächlich die Wirklichkeit zu erkennen, ist eine Methode, die man in diesem Video sieht. Und zwar wird in diesem Video gezeigt, wie sich ein junger Mann im Gesicht verändert hat, weil er eine Methode angewendet hat. Und diese Methode heißt Mewing. Hast du davon jemals gehört, Stefan?
Nein, oh Gott, wofür ist das hin?
Das geht zurück auf einen Zahnarzt, der auch noch lebt. Der ist über 90 und sein Sohn ist auch im Internet präsent. Der heißt John Mew, dieser Zahnarzt. Und der hat die These gehabt, man muss nur entsprechend die Zunge gegen den Oberkiefer drücken, gegen den Gaumen drücken. Und das immer und immer wieder. Und dadurch kann man auch nicht durch den Mund aber atmen, man atmet immer durch die Nase. Und damit bräuchte man noch keine Zahnspange und nichts, sondern alles würde sich dadurch schon perfekt einstellen. Also ist natürlich im hohen Maße obskur. Ist aber etwas, was sich jetzt gerade im Internet extrem verbreitet, also seit Monaten verbreitet, aber wenn man dann so aktuell guckt, dann jede Woche erscheinen da zig Videos zu. Und wir hören jetzt mal William Lee, der Millionenaufrufe hat, wie er erzählt, wie er dieses Mewing nutzt.
It's a technique called mewing.
It's super simple.
All you gotta do is smile and swallow.
Now your tongue is in a proper position to develop that jawline.
Keep it there throughout the day and when you sleep and you'll have a nice jawline in no time. You got this, King.
Also ich kenne von Fällen in denen.
Zwischen die Zwanziger. Die jawline für sich erkannt haben und geben da jetzt Tipps. Man kann ja nicht immer nur über Bizeps und Trizeps sprechen. Hier ist Brett Maverick.
Ich weiß, das ist eine sehr einfache Frage, das ist warum.
Also die Jawline hat zwei verschiedene Dimensionen.
Einer von denen ist von der Seite, das ist eigentlich dein Seite-Profil, also wenn jemand einen guten 90-Grad-Angle hat, wo der Brustkopf sich mit dem Haken trifft und das Schild ist in Bezug auf den Nose, das in Bezug auf den Vorhaken ist.
Die machen eigene Wissenschaft daraus und das wird aber dann und da sind wir in diesem eigenartigen Männlichkeits-Jordan-Petersen-Diskurs und sonst was. Das wird dann verknüpft mit historischen Funden. Das könnte auch Senckenbergmuseum sein, aber es wird als positiv herausgehoben.
Deine genetische Vorbereitung.
Das ist unsere genetische Default.
Aber über Zeit haben wir sich verabschiedet.
Wir sind alle verweichlicht.
Ja, das ist so eine Fight Club Ansprache von Fred Pitt im Prinzip. Und da muss man ja auch einfach sagen, es ist zwar zum einen richtig, dass früher da mehr gekaut wurde vor tausenden Jahren, ist die Frage dahin, wollen wir da wieder hin? Also man kann jetzt auch sich wieder schwer auf Trockenfleisch konzentrieren. Und man muss aber auch sagen, es ist nicht eine Frage von Überzivilisiertheit, sondern man sieht ja gerade da, wo Menschen wenig haben, zum Beispiel im ländlichen Raum von China oder so, gibt es ganz große Zahnprobleme. Und das sind hygienische Probleme und alles Mögliche spielt da eine Rolle. Und das ist so absurd, aber es wird hier verknüpft mit Genen, mit so einer Idee von, so ist eigentlich der wahre Mann. Und wir sind dann auch schon bei der Völkerkunde fast angekommen.
Sie haben hohe Züge und prominente Brustbeine.
Ja, also das ist und es ist einfach die Reichweite unglaublich, wie da sich so ganze Communities zusammen tun, die sich dann nur darüber unterhalten, wie man die Jawline bekommen kann und wie man dann so eine so so ein Alphamann wird oder sonst was. Also es ist weit über das geht das hinaus, es hat eine sehr hohe politische Implikation. Es geht jetzt nicht nur darum, dass man sagt, ja, das sieht irgendwie ganz gut aus und wahrscheinlich würden viele jetzt intuitiv sagen, dass eine gewisse Kontur im Gesicht ist oder im Gesicht attraktiv sein kann. Aber man muss sich schon auch hier wieder klar machen, wie sehr die medialen Bilder und damit meine ich jetzt mal primär die TikTok Bilder ein Schönheitsideal einem in den Kopf setzen, dass man in dieser Form vorher natürlich nicht gehabt hat. Also wir sind da in so einer ganz merkwürdigen Phase angekommen, wo man einfach eine App hat, die innerhalb von fünf Jahren die ganze Welt erobert hat und jetzt prägt die eine Ästhetik. Und ich hatte mich ja auch schon mal hier im Zuge des Podcasts mit Onifans so ein bisschen beschäftigt oder so. Und auch da ist interessant zu sehen, dass Männer dort bei Onifans auch sehr aktiv sind und diesen TikTok Look haben. Also, dass man dann bzw. man muss es anders sagen. Die Akquise für Onifans läuft ganz stark über TikTok, weil der TikTok-Algorithmus es ja ermöglicht, dass man so von 0 auf 100 kommen kann und gesehen wird. Und da hat man die Möglichkeit, dann auf das Onifans-Profil zu verweisen. Das heißt, man bedient sich erst der TikTok-Ästhetik, um dann auf dem Porno-Portal zu verweisen. Und um dieser TikTok-Ästhetik aber zu entsprechen, muss man vorher schon das Gesicht anpassen. Und es gibt ja wahnsinnig viele junge Männer, die in diesem Onifans-Creator-Bereich sind, die auch schon alle Schönheitsoperationen haben. Plus natürlich die Frauen, die mit 19 die Schönheitsoperationen gemacht haben, die es braucht, um eine Onifans-Karriere zu machen und um zugleich auf den Kanal zu verweisen, wenn man auf TikTok tanzt. Also es ist eine absurde Situation. Und da der Einfluss, den das hat, also ich muss jetzt auch noch mal dran denken, wir hatten doch vor ein paar Monaten diese Debatte noch mal über Germany's Next Topmodel. Und ich kam mir so, das war wie so eine Zeitreise für mich, als ich das so mitbekam, dass ich, wie, die reden jetzt echt noch mal über das Frauenbild in Germany's Next Topmodel. Das hat doch vor vor zehn Jahren ist da alles zugesagt wurde. Also wurde noch mal auch so, wie schlimm das ist oder wie gut das ist, dass die das jetzt verändern. Und dann denkt man, ja, das ist eine Sendung, die kommt wie oft im Jahr, zwölfmal im Jahr. Und die dauert dann jeweils anderthalb Stunden. Und jetzt überleg mal, der junge Mensch nutzt TikTok jeden Tag mindestens eine Stunde und ist all diesen Bildern ausgesetzt. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass der Topmodel harmenlos ist, aber ich würde mal die Verhältnismäßigkeit nochmal überprüfen.
Sowieso. Wir übersehen immer diese generativen Mechanismen. Diese Diskussion, das nervt ja auch schon seit ewig Zeiten, dass man da einfach nicht durchdringt, wenn man sagt, ne, auch der politische Journalismus spiegelt nicht einfach, was in Berlin passiert, sondern er generiert es so. Wir diskutieren das auch gleich nochmal an einem anderen Beispiel. Aber generative Mechanismen werden einfach übersehen.
Es gibt noch andere Methoden, wie man die Jawline sich ein bisschen konturieren kann. Wir hören hier einen YouTuber.
Hallo Freunde, ich hab vorhin eine Frage bekommen, wie sollen wir unsere Balls schneiden, damit unsere Jawline besser aussieht, damit unsere Gesicht definierter aussieht. Genau hier, hab hier einen Aponent drauf zu schneiden, wenn du das möchtest. Ich persönlich bevorzuge diese Methode eigentlich viel lieber. Also ich mach jetzt mal auf 0, 8 und dann fange ich an, den Bereich hier zu rasieren. Dann merkt man, dass es hier ist und hier ist es dunkler und dem Rest ist bisschen heller. Den nächsten Bereich, den ihr wieder achten müsst, ist von hier nach unten. Den Bereich müsst ihr wieder mit 1, 4.
Ja, ein Spiel mit Schatten und Licht und so könnte es dann vielleicht auch gehen. Oder doch lieber filler. Auch hier wird ein Schönheitschirurg oder ein Arzt und ein Patient gezeigt. Naja, wir hören mal, worum es geht. Es ist nämlich gar nicht eine Schönheitsoperation. Der Begriff ist jetzt zweimal gefallen. Es geht nicht um eine Schönheitsoperation, sondern Maskulinisierung soll da stattfinden. Über Filler, also über Spritzen mit Hyaluron, die man sich dann an die entsprechenden Stellen spritzt. Und wir hören uns mal das Ergebnis an. Du kannst es auch.
Es ist wirklich toll und angelt.
Ich finde es, wenn man es jetzt nochmal so verbindet, Völkerkunde, Genetik, Archäologie, Maskulinisierung. Wir kauen wieder irgendwelche schweren Brocken, damit wir da was haben, haben dann eine neue Männlichkeit oder stellen das noch mit dem Bart her. Wir sind wirklich an so einen interessanten Punkt angelangt, wo man zurück in die Höhle geht, aber über den Umweg der Schönheitschirurgie, TikTok und so weiter. Also es ist ganz kürzlich zu sehen. Und noch als abschließend Kommentar musste ich natürlich noch mal zur Literatur greifen, denn ich hatte, als ich so viel jetzt davon gesehen habe, gedacht, warum ist das in irgendeiner Weise, dass man sagen kann, ja klar, dass das kann ein interessantes Gesicht, also jemand mit einer Jawline kann ein interessantes Gesicht haben. Und man denkt natürlich auch an Schauspieler, jetzt weiß ich nicht, Timothée Chalamet wird ja immer sehr gelobt für seine Jawline, die sicherlich nicht gemacht ist, die einfach so ist, wie sie ist. Aber was ich so interessant fand, wenn man sich diese TikTokker, die dann ihre Jawline präsentieren und ihre Ergebnisse zeigen, was ich so interessant fand, ist, dass sowohl bei den Frauen, wie bei den Männern, nicht mehr die erotische Dimension da ist, sondern es geht nur noch auf dieses, ich produziere mir hier die Perfektion, seht her, wie ich dazu gekommen bin. Und es hat gerade nicht das, was eigentlich Schönheit und Erotik ausstrahlt, nämlich dass es so etwas nonchalantes hat, dass es etwas Zufälliges hat, dass es etwas Unbewusstes hat. Und dieses Problem, wenn etwas einem zu bewusst wird, wenn man also zu sehr nur noch im Spiegel guckt, wie sehe ich eigentlich aus, das ist etwas, was Kleist in seinem Essay über das Marionettentheater auf den Punkt gebracht hat, wir gönnen uns diese zwei Minuten. Ich badete mich vor etwa drei Jahren mit einem jungen Mann, über dessen Bildung damals eine wunderbare Anmut verbreitet war. Er mochte ungefähr in seinem 16. Jahre stehen und nur ganz von fern ließen sich, von der Gunz der Frauen herbeigerufen, die ersten Spuren von Eitelkeit erblicken. Es traf sich, dass wir gerade kurz zuvor in Paris den Jüngling gesehen hatten, der sich einen Splitter aus dem Fuße zieht. Der Abguss der Statue ist bekannt und befindet sich in den meisten deutschen Sammlungen. Ein Blick, den er in dem Augenblick, da er den Fuße auf den Schemel setzte, um ihn abzutrocknen, in einen großen Spiegel war, verinnerte ihn daran. Er lächelte und sagte mir, wer ich eine Entdeckung eher gemacht habe. In der Tat hatte ich in eben diesem Augenblick dieselbe gemacht, doch sei es um die Sicherheit der Grazie, die ihm beiwohnte, zu prüfen, sei es um seine Eitelkeit ein wenig heilsam zu begegnen, ich lachte und erwiderte, er sei wohl Geister. Er errötete und hob den Fuß zum zweiten Mal, um es mir zu zeigen. Doch der Versuch, wie sich leicht hätte voraussehen lassen, missglückte. Er hob verwirrt den Fuß zum dritten und führten er hob ihn wohl noch zehnmal, umsonst, er war außerstand, dieselbe Bewegung wieder hervorzurufen. Was sag ich, die Bewegungen, die er machte, hatten ein so komisches Element, das ich Mühe hatte, das Gelächter zurückzuhalten. Von diesem Tage, gleichsam von diesem Augenblick an, ging eine unbegreifliche Veränderung mit dem jungen Menschen vor. Er fing an, tagelang vor dem Spiegel zu stehen und immer ein Reiz nach dem anderen verließ ihn. Eine unsichtbare und unbegreifliche Gewalt schien sich wie ein eisernes Netz um das freie Spiel seiner Gebärden zu legen und als ein Jahr verflossen war, war keine Spur mehr von der Lieblichkeit in ihm zu entdecken, die die Augen der Menschen sonst, die ihn umringten, ergötzt hatte.
Der wurde infiziert?
Ja, der wurde infiziert, noch ohne TikTok, aber bei TikTok können wir es sehen. Und das zu sehr forcierte ist uneerotisch und es schlägt um in unfreiwillige Komik. Und das war auch etwas, was ich bei meiner kleinen Recherche am meisten erlebt habe, dass ich einfach gelacht habe und dachte, du liebe Gott.
Ja, ja, das sind alles idiotische Zeiten, in denen wir leben. Aber wir machen ein kleines Kapitel auf, um genau das, was du jetzt für die Ästhetik des Privatlebens, der Erotik, der Liebschaften und so weiter, darum geht es ja am Ende hier. In der Politik ist es ja so, und wir hatten ja einen kleinen Vorfall jetzt im August, dass Abbas hier war, der, wie nennt man ihn, Regierungschef, ist irgendwie falsch, naja.
Palästinenser-Chef, ist auch ein wenig komisch.
Ich glaube schon. Er ist in Berlin. Olaf Scholz wusste gar nicht, dass er einen Termin mit ihm hat, sondern flog auch gerade erst aus Kanada zurück, oder wo auch immer er war. Es stand dann, es war quasi nur die Pressekonferenz anbraumt. Ich glaube, die haben nicht mal vorher miteinander gesprochen oder so. Und da hat ja Abbas von den 50 Holocausts der Israelis gegen die Palästinenser gesprochen, was ja danach, um das hier nur kurz darzustellen, zu kontroversen führte. Nicht so sehr darum darf man das sagen, natürlich nicht, sondern die Gestaltung der Situation geriet so ein bisschen in die Kritik. Weil nämlich Olaf Scholz nicht ad hoc darauf reagierte. Das hören wir uns mal hier an.
Die Verantwortung übernimmt der Regierungssprecher. Er habe die Pressekonferenz zu früh beendet.
Sie haben gesehen, dass der Bundeskanzler mich beim Abgang von der Bühne schon kurz angeraunst hat, dass ich das etwas schnell gemacht habe und er gerne noch etwas entgegnet hätte.
Scholz meldet sich per Twitter. Er sei zutiefst empört über die unsäglichen Aussagen von Abbas. Übersetzt auch auf Englisch und Hebräisch. Der Opposition reicht das nicht.
Man hätte wirklich direkt reagieren müssen. Alles, was jetzt im Nachhinein kommt, ist einfach zu spät.
Ja, der Opposition reicht das nicht. Wer wir da gehört haben, ist egal. Wahrscheinlich jemand von der CDU. Alles, was danach kommt, ist zu spät. Das wurde dann noch mal in aller Ausführlichkeit im korrespondenten Gespräch diskutiert.
Die Aufarbeitung ist noch nicht zu Ende. Schauen wir nach Berlin und nach Tel Aviv. Beginnen wir bei Shakuntala Banerjee in Berlin. Die Wellen schlugen hoch. Was hat Scholz mit seinem nachträglichen Krisenmanagement jetzt heute ausrichten können?
Er hat heute zumindest so entschlossen reagiert, dass er Schaden begrenzen kann. Es ist ihm schon gelungen, den Eindruck zurückzuholen, dass man in Deutschland, in Berlin, neben dem Bundeskanzler stehen kann und den Holocaust gänzlich unwidersprochen relativieren kann. Aber er tut es eben nur nachträglich. Die klare Haltung, die er heute zeigt, die macht noch mal sehr deutlich, wie sehr er sich da selber gestern vielleicht auch im Weg gestanden hat. Denn es steht ja die Frage im Raum, warum hat er sich gestern nicht über das Protokoll hinweggesetzt? Als Bundeskanzler kann er im Kanzleramt natürlich auch das Ende einer Pressekonferenz aufschieben. Damit brüskiert er vielleicht seinen Pressesprecher, aber er hätte gestern den EKLAR zumindest verhindern können.
Ich habe mich, ich frage mich immer noch, wo genau ist das Problem?
Naja, er hätte, also das Problem ist, glaube ich, wenn er da steht und da relativiert einer in einem solchen Maße den Holocaust, dass er dann nicht sagen kann, so und jetzt ist es einfach die Pressekonferenz, sondern dass er da in dem Moment sagt, so sehen wir das nicht. Er hat ihn ja auch einmal korrigiert, bei Apartheid schon und dann hat er das da nicht gemacht. Ich sehe aber dann wiederum, wenn ich jetzt diese ganze Rezeption mir nochmal vor Augen führe, die wir darum hatten, es ist halt jetzt ein unendliches Gerede darum. Die Sache ist, das war falsch. Er telefoniert dann auch, glaube ich, mit Israel mal kurz darüber und dann twittert er das nochmal und so weiter. Und jetzt kann man da, glaube ich, so eine große, also ich glaube, man möchte jetzt der große Symbiotiker werden. Und das führt aber zu nichts, weil es, glaube ich, einfach so ein ein richtiger Patzer, also nicht, dass ich das jetzt kleinreden will, aber ein richtiger Patzer im wortwörtlichen Sinne ist. Und dann war es natürlich auch vielleicht nicht so. Und jetzt fange ich aber auch schon an, genauso wie dann dieser Logik. Du merkst, wir konnten jetzt so eine Stunde darüber machen. Und das ist so, wir produzieren jetzt das Ereignis. Wir machen, wir machen das jetzt so sehr viel größer als es ist. Aber es war selbstverständlich dann auch ein bisschen komisch, dass der Hebestreit dann mal so den Kopf hinhalten musste und sagen muss, ja, dass ich bin schuld, ich habe die Pressekonferenz zu früh beendet. Natürlich kann der Bundeskanzler jederzeit noch was sagen. Also warum nicht?
Also ich fand die Diskussion so komisch, weil sich alle einig waren, dass Olaf Scholz natürlich nicht auch nur im Entferntesten in Gefahr steht, irgendeiner Holocaust Relativierung irgendwo irgendeinen Platz zu geben. Und trotzdem, obwohl das alle so wissen und auch nochmal extra dazu sagen, machen sie noch den Punkt, da liegt aber eine zeitliche Differenz. Und ich frag mich, ja und? Weil wir jetzt Medienzeitalter sind und alles innerhalb eines 18-Sekunden-TikTok-Takes stattfinden muss, weil nämlich nicht genau klar ist, was der Algorithmus als nächsten Clip spielt und am Ende kann die Antwort, die ja erfolgte, nicht daran gekoppelt werden, weil die Algos das alles auseinanderrückeln, das preisen wir jetzt alles ein in unsere politische Diskussion. Oder, und da stellen wir wirklich irgend wem jetzt zum Opfer Abbas gefallen zu sein, der dann denkt, ach, das kann man plötzlich im Bundeskanzleramt sagen, na dann denke ich jetzt auch so, nein, das ist doch alles nicht so.
Ja, und das ist für mich der entscheidende Punkt, und das führt mich, du gestattest, zu Slavoj Zizek und Lacan's großem anderen. Slavoj Zizek sagt, dass wir manchmal Dinge tun, nicht für jemanden, also Olaf Scholz muss das jetzt nicht der deutschen Bevölkerung klar machen, dass er den Holocaust nicht relativieren will, und er muss es auch nicht den Israelis klar machen, er wird einen Entschuldigungsanruf dann vielleicht machen, aber die werden ja nicht sagen, ach so, dann ist ja gut, dass wir es jetzt nochmal von ihnen gehört haben, dass sie nicht den Holocaust relativieren. So, und Slavoj Zizek bringt das Beispiel mit Kindern, die irgendwann in dem Alter sind, dass sie wissen, dass es den Weihnachtsmann nicht gibt, aber sie ihre Eltern nicht enttäuschen wollen, dass es den Weihnachtsmann nicht gibt. Und die Eltern wollen nicht, dass das Kind weiß, dass es den Weihnachtsmann nicht gibt. Also alle wissen es, aber wir sagen es trotzdem nicht. Und dann sagt Slavoj Zizek, in dem Moment handeln wir für so einen großen anderen. Also wir machen das für irgendeine große andere, man jetzt nicht für den Gott, aber für irgendwen. Genau so gab es, ein anderes Beispiel ist, gab es so Lexikonreihen in der Sowjetunion, in dem natürlich mitunter Protagonisten waren, die irgendwann Stalin unliebsam wurden. Und dann musste Trotsky oder so daraus entfernt werden. Also dann bekam man einen Brief, wenn man so einen Lexikon abonniert hatte, bitte entfernen Sie die Seite mit Trotsky aus dem Lexikon. Und der, der es tut, weiß es, also es ist jeder weiß um alles, aber man tut es trotzdem für so einen großen anderen. Und das hier ist auch wieder so sehr typisch. Und das haben wir wirklich, also das müsste man jetzt mal so dieses große andere Phänomen in den Medien, wenn man da mal so eine Sammlung auf zehn Jahre anlegen würde, würde man nur noch den Kopf schütteln, wo wir die ganze Zeit so was machen, wo man sagt, naja eigentlich ist ja vollkommen klar, jeder weiß es, aber wir müssen es jetzt so im Ganzen machen. Und es ist ja auch irreversibel. Also das ist ja auch interessant, dass man sagt, aber es ist so zu spät, dass es auch eigentlich gar nicht mehr hilft. Und das ist etwas, was aber Journalisten unglaublich lieben. Also wir müssen mal jetzt darauf achten, auf dieses Paradigma, wo dem großen anderen gerecht geworden ist oder nicht und wie das bewertet wird.
Ja, also es durchzieht ja alle Diskussionen gerade. Das Winnie-Toe-Zeug.
Wie getrauert wurde. Also wenn der Politiker bei irgendwas nicht hat, hat er dem dem großen anderen entsprochen. Wann kam die Trauer schnell genug? Also wurde das Statement schnell genug rausgegeben? Was hat man dabei dann gerade getragen? Also das ist immer so eine große andere Politik, weil natürlich man da nicht unterstellt, dass das eigentlich anders ist.
Ja, also G-Check nehmen wir da mal in Beschlag für diesen großen anderen. Denn heute kam ja auch die Meldung, dass Christian Ströbele gestorben ist, schon am Dienstag. Und unter dieser Maßgabe werden wir natürlich lesen können, wie sich CDU-Politiker von ihm verabschieden öffentlich. Und zwar auch nur vor dem großen anderen uns nochmal so Nachruf-Brosa vorspielen, wie man das doch ganz toll fand, wie er immer gegen eingeschossen hat und so.
Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also in deren Sicht ist der große andere vielleicht, den sollten wir jetzt echt mal in diesen medialen Zeiten mehr in Betracht ziehen, weil das war zu albern hier mit Abbas. Gut, haben wir alle Themen abgehandelt, oder willst du uns noch irgendwas über Tierarten erzählen?
Oh Gott, jetzt hast du es angesprochen. Okay, du willst mich jetzt nochmal in Rage erleben. Warum nicht? Die letzten Minuten.
Drei Clips, das schaffen wir.
Also wir haben eine Sommerpause, die ich ja sowieso hasse. Also ich bin ja kein Freund des Sommers und auch kein Freund von diesen ganzen Sommerpausen. Aber das führt dann dazu, dass man im Kulturfernsehen sagt, gut, wir haben Dreisatz nicht und sonst was, also machen wir mal irgendwas anders. Wir könnten doch so eine Doku-Reihe machen über das Thema Tiere in der Kunst, einmal über Katzen, über Hunde, über Pferde und so weiter. Eigentlich ein sehr schönes Thema aus mehreren Gründen. Einmal die Kunst und das Tier sind natürlich wichtig. Die Fragen der Repräsentation. Was repräsentiert ein Tier auf einem Bild, zum Beispiel auf einem Herrscherporträt? Da kann man also mit Erwin Panofsky und Abi Warburg und so nochmal dran gehen. Es gibt Experten, die sich dazu äußern können. Dann gibt es diesen großen Diskurs. Wir sind zu anthropozentrisch oder der Speziesismus. Kann die Kunst, die Tiere zeigt uns einen anderen Blick, wenn das Tier uns vom Bild anblickt, auf uns vermitteln? Das wären alles Fragen, die man auffächern könnte. Und wir sind jetzt hier wieder in der Reihe. Ich knalle eine weitere Tür hin zu den Medien, mir zu. Und dann gucke ich in diese Sendung rein. Erste Folge Katzen. Wer ist der Host dieser Sendung? Dieser komische Funk-Comedian Aurel Merz. Und dann denkt man, hat er irgendwas mit Kunst zu tun? Ist er mir da in dem Kontext schon mal aufgefallen? Nee. Und das hört sich dann so an.
Katzen, ich liebe Katzen. Ich liebe jedes Bild von Katze. Ich würde mir jedes Bild von einer Katze aufhängen, auf der die Katze glücklich aussieht, auch wenn die jetzt nicht so glücklich aussieht. Die dafür umso mehr. Diese psychodelische Katze sieht so glücklich aus. Sofort würde ich mir das aufhängen. Ich bin total besessen von Katzen. Ich bin mit drei Katzen aufgewachsen. Ich in jedem Urlaub, wo ich eine Katze sehe, muss ich die Katzen alle hochnehmen. Hier, das bin ich im Kreterurlaub. Da habe ich diese Katze hier kennengelernt. Hab mich sofort natürlich aufgenommen, gefüttert usw. Zuhause früher bei meinen drei Katzen bin ich öfter mal zuhause geblieben als Teenager, anstatt mit meinen Freunden auszugehen oder so, weil ich einfach lieber mit Katzen rumgehangen bin, als mit Menschen. Und deshalb sind Katzen in der Kunst das beste Thema, das ich mir vorstellen kann.
Ich betone hier jetzt nochmal, wir haben es mit Dreisatz zu tun. Es gibt noch so zwei letzte Bastionen im Fernsehen, Dreisatz und Arte, wo man sagt, ja, da wird der Anspruch noch etwas höher gehalten, als das in den anderen Programmen ist. Und jetzt sagt man sich, wir nehmen so ein Thema, das ja wirklich viel hergibt. Und dann will man aber irgendwie sich an die Jugend andienen, glaubt dann, dass Auremert seine Insta-Follower zu Dreisatz rüber schleppt und nimmt dann jemanden, der wirklich kaum in der Lage ist, einen vernünftigen Satz zu sagen. Anders kann ich mich da gar nicht ausdrücken. Und das haben aber offenbar die Macher. Man muss man diese erste Folge nehmen, man muss nicht. Nee, tut's nicht. Aber wenn man in diese erste Folge reinkickt, dann ist so interessant, normalerweise führt hier ein Host durch die Sendung, würde vielleicht sogar ein Experteninterview führen oder irgendetwas, aber hier ist die Sache so strukturiert. Man hat Experten, die einfach von dem Kamerateam dann an verschiedenen Orten abgefilmt wurden und dann in die Kamera blicken, was sagen. Und zwischendurch sieht man dann, auch im März stehend oder auf einem Stuhl sitzen, in und wieder wird irgendein Katzenbild eingeblendet und der erzählt nur so einen Unsinn. Und das passiert aber auch nur ein paar Mal in diesen 45 Minuten. Offenbar war das Material, das man mit ihm gedreht hat, also ist jetzt alles meine Mutmaßung, aber es kann kaum anders sein. So schlecht, dass man dachte, gut, wo kriegen wir den eigentlich noch runter? Das sollte ja der Host der Sendung sein. Eigentlich könnten die die Experten das tragen. Wenn die Experten sprechen, zum Beispiel diese jetzt hier, dann ist das wieder eine typische Dreisat-Doku.
In seiner Verkündigung an Maria offenbart der Erzengel Gabriel Maria die Empfängnis von Gottes Sohn. Im Zentrum des Bildes eine Katze.
Und wenn dort plötzlich eine Katze auftaucht, dann hat das zunächst natürlich etwas damit zu tun, dass auch damit Realität eingefangen ist. Denn in jedem bürgerlichen Haus gab es hier auf dem Bauernhof eine Katze. Aber die Katze in dem Bild von Lorenzo Lotto, die läuft auch weg. Die bewegt sich. Die ist erschrocken. Wer würde denn nicht erschrecken, wenn ein Erzengel plötzlich in unserem Wohnzimmer kehrt?
Die Katze im Zentrum dieses wirklich dramatischen und auch sehr gewaltsamen Bildes dieser Szenerie weicht tatsächlich zurück. Es ist eben aus einer heutigen Perspektive durchaus zu hinterfragen, ob das eine Gnade ist, wenn da so ein fremdes Wesen in die eigene Lebensphäre eindringt und einem nun verheißt, dass man plötzlich schwanger ist.
Wir haben jetzt kurz abgerissen, worum es da eigentlich geht in dieser Darstellung. Und von dort aus würde ich sagen, würde jetzt die interessante Kultursendung erst beginnen. Also das war jetzt mal so das Grundwissen. Aha, wir jetzt dieses Gemälde verstanden. Und jetzt würden sich ganz viele Fragen daran anschließen, die ich jetzt gerne von Experten beantwortet hätte oder diskutiert hätte, wie auch immer. Aber das war es jetzt schon an hochkulturellem Input. Es geht jetzt nahtlos dazu über, dass Auréme Merz das jetzt schon Gesagte noch mal wie folgt kommentiert.
Das ist sowas von nachvollziehbar. Ich kenne auch den Blick ziemlich gut. Genauso schaut sie nämlich, wenn der Pizzabote klingelt und sie so fragt, okay, wow, was macht diese Person in meinem Territorium? Und jetzt stellt euch mal vor, der Pizzabote sagt euch noch, dass sie ein Kind von Gott erwartet. Natürlich flüchten die beiden zusammen. Und die sind auch ein komplettes Team. Und das kann ich auch so gut nachvollziehen.
Wer da nicht kulturpessimistisch wird, ich finde es alles so abscheudig. Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Wir machen Hochkultur dann im Salon, würde ich sagen. Und zwar können wir ein bisschen noch antisern. Also wir lesen gemeinsam das Buch von Gideon Rachman. Und dann hat Werner Herzog, der große Regisseur Werner Herzog, hat seine Autobiografie geschrieben, über die müssen wir sprechen. Die ist jetzt erschienen. Und ich bin sehr gespannt darauf, was da drin steht. Jeder für sich und Gott gegen alle heißt sie. Und ich möchte das Thema Identitätspolitik tatsächlich einmal aufgreifen, auch wenn ich mich hier sonst da mittlerweile raushalte, einfach auch weil ich davon gelangweilt bin. Ich glaube, man kann etwas Interessantes dazu sagen, wenn man Omri Böhm ist. Der hat jetzt ein Buch geschrieben mit dem Titel, oder es ist ein Buch, das vor allem ein Essay enthält, ein langer Essay, Radikaler Universalismus jenseits von Identität. Das ist für mich sehr vielversprechend und glaube, in so einer Weise kann man auch eine fundierte, kluge Kritik an der Identitätspolitik üben, ohne dass man jetzt da mit diesen komischen Leuten gemeine Sachen machen muss. Ich erwarte mir sehr viel davon und werde dann berichten. Und da ich noch nicht weiß, wie umfänglich das wird, will ich mir die anderen drei Texte noch offenhalten, wie viel Zeit dann noch bleibt. Aber das ist jedenfalls geplant. Und wir sehen uns ja dann auch im Übrigen ganz real wieder. Du bist dann auf dem Urlaub zurück und dann komme ich nach Frankfurt und dann gehen wir Schnitzel essen. Hast du schon was auf der Liste?
Ich hab was auf der Liste, aber ich sag noch nichts, denn ich werde auf der Rückfahrt von Utrecht nach Frankfurt genug Zeit haben, alles mal zu sichten. Es wird wahrscheinlich auch ums Barfuß laufen und sowas gehen. Also es gibt ja die einen, die sich in die Neandertaler Richtung entwickeln, mit Jordan und so. Die anderen, die nochmal ihre Füße so nutzen, wie sie gedacht waren. Und so weiter. So in die Richtung. Aber ich glaube, es wird auch politisch Anspruchsvolles geben. Sehr gut. Bei dem einen sehe ich hier Goethe. Der Economist hat irgendwas über den sitzenden Goethe und wie man aus englischer Sicht über den größten deutschen Autor und so. Ich bin gespannt.
Das ist interessant.
Lesen und sichten. Seid gespannt, so wie ich auch.
Ja, also wir freuen uns, wenn ihr in den Salon kommt und so auch unseren Podcast ein bisschen unterstützt. Und dann wünschen wir einen angenehmen Monat. Und wir sehen uns dann in einer Woche zum Salon wieder.
Richtig. Bis dahin, haut rein!